Master react by Building 25 different
projects and if you follow along you'll
be ready to interview for a job as a
react developer sanum created this
course he's an experienced react
developer hello everyone and welcome so
in this particular video we are going to
create 25 react just projects from
scratch so all the projects that we will
be learning in this one those are
created from a interview point of view
so in top product based companies there
will be always around that we call as a
frontend interiew round or browser
coding round so in that round
interviewer will give you a simple to
midlevel assignment and you have to
complete that questions within a given
time frame so it varies from 30 minutes
to 1 hour I can guarantee you that all
the projects that we will be learning if
you complete all of them because each
and every project is associated to a
particular concept and I will highly
suggest that whenever you will watch
this video try to code along it will
definitely going to help you so let's
quickly see what are the projects that
we are going to build so first we'll
start with this very famous accordion so
here we will be learning two concept so
one will be a single selection so every
time you will click only one will open
at a time then we will be learning this
multi selection so in this case you will
be able to open multi multiple accordion
all right next we'll move to this random
color generator where we will be
learning how to create both hex random
color and also RGB random color so here
you can see that currently we are
creating hex color if I now click on
this Generate random color button so it
will automatically create random hex
color if I click now on this RGB color
so now this will create a random RGB
color then we'll move to very famous
star rating questions and I think I
don't have to explain this one this is a
very very very famous interview
questions after this we will be
basically learning this image slider
where we will be fetching the list of
images from a API endpoint and then on
top of it we are going to implement this
slider
functionality after this we'll be
implementing this load mode data project
so here basically we'll be getting some
certain amounts of or basically certain
data from API endpoint and every time we
will be clicking on this load Moree
products button it will uh basically
face the next set of
data then after this we are going to
implement this next review so this is
also very very very famous interview
questions here they will basically give
you some Ned Json structure and from
that structure you have to recursively
implement this nested review all right
and also you can basically call this one
as Dynamic navigation or dynamic menus
also then we will be creating this QR
code generator so here you have to give
some input and Bas on this input it will
automatically generate some QR code
after that we'll be implementing this
light and dark dark mode so here on
click of this button you will be able to
basically change the theme and also we
going to save this current theme into
our local storage for this one we are
going to implement a custom hook and
here throughout this particular project
apart from the QR code one we are not
going to use any third party Library
packages all right then after this we
will be implementing this scroll IND
indicator and if you noticed here on the
top we are getting this scroll indicator
all right so this is basically part of
this particular project so every time we
will scroll this will basically give you
the progress how much the user already
scrolled after this we are going to
implement the custom tabs so this is
also a very famous interview questions
and then we'll be implementing this
custom model popup so if I click here
this will open this custom model then we
will be implementing this GitHub profile
finder so here you need to give some
random name and if this particular user
exists so this will basically fetch the
details of this particular user from the
geub API and based on this it will give
you the data after this we are going to
implement this search autocomplete so
here whatever you will be typing uh for
this one also you're going to face the
data from API all
right then we will be implementing this
Tic Tac to so I think this is also a
very famous interview questions there
will be also restart functionality then
we'll be implementing this very
interesting uh project this is called
the feature flags flags so what
basically happens in very large
companies so instead of changing the
feature directly in the code sometimes
what will happen they will basically
give you a API endpoint and that in that
API response there will be some data and
from that particular data you will be
able to understand that what are the
features you have to enable and what are
the features you want to disable without
changing anything in the code and for
this one we are going to implement this
particular project and this uh questions
is also asked in very top level product
based compan companies all right so this
is a very important one and after this
we will be
implementing these three custom hooks so
the first one will be very famous this
is called use fet hook and after this
we'll be implementing this use outside
click hook so if I now click on this so
content and click outside of it this
will basically toggle this content and
then we'll be implementing this use
window resize so if I now resize this
window this width and height will
automatically change and at the end
we'll be implementing this scroll to top
and bottom feature where on click of
this you'll be able to scroll to the
bottom and if I click on this scroll to
top so it will automatically scroll to
the top all right so these all are the
very simple projects that we are going
to build and after this we'll be moving
to some mid-level projects so the reason
for this mid-level projects is that
sometimes some uh in uh some companies
will give you some assignment and you
have to complete those assignment like
within one or two days so in that case
they can give you some mid-level
projects instead of giving you some
simple one so for this one we are going
to implement this weather application so
here I can give some uh city name and
based on that it will automatically face
the data all right then we'll be moving
to this food recipe where uh we will be
basically able to search reip is based
on some input that we'll be giving and
you can see that we'll be getting the
data if I click on this recipe details
so it will face the recipes we'll be
able to add the uh recipes to the
favorites if I go to favorites will be
getting the favorites here all right and
if I go here this will be automatically
updated so let's say if I now go on this
one so you can see that this is now add
to favorites if I click this one go to
favorites this uh Apple gallet this is
already added if I now go to the
homepage and click on this one so you
can see that we are still getting
because this is already added in the
favorites after this we'll be adding
this or implementing this shopping cut
so for this one we are going to use
Redux toolkit so we'll be able to add to
the C
and here we'll be getting the result
we'll be able to remove and after this
we'll be implementing this expense
tracker for this one we are going to
chakra UI and some of the projects also
we going to implement using tnd CSS so
here you will be able to add some
expense let's I'll add a expense give
the amount and then check this one as
expense click on ADD so we'll be
basically getting the data here and also
we'll be getting the data as a chart
View and at the end we are going to
implement this monack applications where
we are going to use mongodb express so
here uh we will be able to add a new
blog so let's say I'll add new blog
added and this one we're going to store
in a database we will be able to add the
uh edit this one so let's say I'll edit
this will be edited and also I'll be
able to delete this one so these all are
the projects that we are going to build
in this whole video and I can guarantee
you that this video is going to help you
in so many ways so that's all for the
intro now without further wasting any
more time let's get started and good
luck all right everyone so let's start
with our first project and that will be
simple accordian component so here we
are having two types of accordian
feature one will be single selection and
you can see that there is a button so on
click of this you'll be able to enable
multi selection now in interview the
questions some will be something like
this that they will give you some dummy
data and based on that you have to
create the accordion so if I do single
selection so if I click only one so only
one will be opened at a time you can see
that once you'll complete this feature
if there is a time left so what
interviewer will do they will try to
make this uh project little bit complex
so they will say that now let's say you
have to do or enable multi selection so
on if I click this one so now the multi
selection is enabled so if I click here
you can see this is opened if I click
here this is also opened so this is
something like what we are going to
build so let's start working on this
first project all right everyone so
let's get started so the first thing is
that uh you can see I created a simple
reactj project now what we are going to
do each and every project that we will
be creating for this particular video
inside this Source folder we are going
to create a components folder and inside
components each and every project will
be a simple component because throughout
this particular video we'll try not to
use any third party Library package
because whenever you'll give any browser
coding interview most of the times your
interviewer will expect you to create
everything from scretch so the first one
will be to create accordion now there
can be two things now whenever you will
start a browser coding interview the
first time interviewer will start with a
simple approach so first he will ask all
right so I'll give you some uh dummy
data so now please create a simple
accordian component now obviously you
can either use a JavaScript or any uh
framework that you like so most of the
times because react is a very popular so
I believe that most of the times we are
going to choose
react and then once you solve the simple
approach then they will give you some of
the complex variation so now you can see
that what I'll do inside this Source
I'll create a folder and let's give this
one name as components and inside
components uh I'll create another folder
and I'll give this on name as
accordion now you can see that what I've
done I'm having some dummy uh data here
so this dummy data I'm going to use and
also in the interviewer also most of the
times your interviewer will give you a
dumy data or else sometimes they will
say that okay you create any dumy data
that you
like now inside this what I'll do I'll
create our
index. jsx and also we'll create another
file that will be styles. CSS now inside
this I'm going to create another file
and this will be our
data.js let me just minimize this one
little
bit all right now what I'm going to do
I'll just copy this
one and I'll p paste it here I'll do
export default and this
data all right now first thing what you
should always do while giving an
interview is that always explain the
approach that you are going to use and
that is very very very important believe
me or not so it's not like that they
have given you one example and then you
start uh writing your code immediately
first you have to explain the approach
that how you are going to do this
particular uh uh problem
because it will be very very easy for
your interviewer that okay you got the
problem and based on this approach you
are basically solving it now what we are
going to do first obviously so what you
can say that okay I created a component
folder and inside that I'm creating
another acarian folder the main re
reason being is that I'm creating this
one as a usable component so that in
multiple places we can use this
component throughout the application so
here I'll create our export default
function let's give this one name is
accordion now here uh let's uh do one
thing uh what we'll do we'll simply
return some jsx for now so we having div
and I'll give this on name as
accordian all
right now let's save it so now this
component we are uh we want to use in
this
app.js so I'm going to remove
everything and
then I'm going to uh give a comment so
this is our accordian
component and here I'm going to import
this
component now let's save it so we
getting accordion here now the first
thing is that uh there can be two types
of accordion one will be let's say your
interview give you first you complete a
single
selection so basically each and every
time you select something you have to
open only one accordion menu at a time
and then uh the complex variation will
be you can basically will be able to
open multiple selection also all right
so let's start one by one so for the
first selection you have to explain that
all right because we are doing as a
single selection so I'll take a straight
here and this will be the selected and
set
selected so this is basically the single
one that you will be selecting and
because first time we'll not select
anything thing so here I'm going to use
the UST State and I'll keep this one
name as null now if you noticed here
here we are having this ID this is the
question and this is the answer so based
on this ID you will be able to track
that which accordian item you're
currently clicking and this is very
important all right now here what I'm
going to do so the first thing is that
let's quickly create the uh structure
here so now uh let's give this on name
as a class name I'll give this on name
name is rapper now style we are going to
do later first let's complete the
functionality now inside this I'm going
to take another
div and here I'll give a class name of
accordion all right now here what I'm
going to do so we are having this data
here so I'm going to take this data now
you should always cover the age cases so
let's say you are having the data you
know that this is a dummy data So
currently we are having the data length
but let's say you getting this dat from
a API so in that case let's say the a
data length is empty so in that case
what you should always check all right
if the data and and data. length if this
is greater than zero then we are going
to do something or else you will show
something like uh let's say no data
present no data
found all
right so here what we are going to do do
data do map so this will be our data
item and here what we are going to do
we'll return another
div so this will be our class name and
I'll give this name as
item and here uh what we'll do we'll
take another div inside of
this and here let's give a class name so
this will be our
title and here inside this we'll take A3
and I'm going to render the data item
dot question so this will be basically
our header all
right and also after this take another
span
here and we'll basically show a expand
or uh like cups icon but in in interview
we will not get that much time so far
now we'll do simply like a
plus all
right so now let's save
it let's see how it is looking all right
so we are getting the question and this
is the icon this is fine so now what we
need to do
basically so after this we need to check
that which uh item you are clicking and
that you want to so that answer you want
to show at a time so this is a single
selection so what we can do simply
whenever we'll click on this title so
here this is our title so we'll take on
click here now so so here for now I'll
do the single selection so we'll do
handle
single
selection all right so this will be a
method so this will function
handle single
selection and this will basically
receive the current ID of that
particular question so you'll be get
current
ID as a argument so here I'll just
invoke this and here I'll just pass this
current ID so here we are having this ID
so this will be data item do ID so this
one will be receiving here so now let's
see if I log this get current ID so now
let's save
it so we'll go to console let's see if I
click here we getting 1 2 3 and we're
getting
four so now you basically know that uh
on click of each and everyone we are
getting the current ID so we just have
to set this one to the uh this method
set selected method but here one thing
we need to do so here I'll take this set
selected and here first I'll just uh
save this one as get current ID and
let's see what is happening so that
means we are setting this current ID
that we are clicking and now after this
what we can do we can simply check if
this selected is equal to equal to data
item Ro ID that means the current data
item ID is equal to equal to current
selected that mean which we are clicking
let's say if I click on two so this
selected will be two and this two is
equal toal data item. ID that means we
want to s that accordian item only all
right or else this will be null so here
what I'll do I'll just simply return a
div and
here I'll render this data item dot this
will be answer and here I'll give a
class name of let's say content
so now let's see what is happening if I
know save it and let's log this selected
also so that you'll be able to
understand if I now go back let's say
click here so now we clicked on this
first item so we getting the first
answer if I click here we are getting
the second one so you can see that this
is automatically getting closed and this
is the fourth one now what will happen
if I click here again so this is not
closing right so how we are going to do
that so to do this one what you can do
basically here you have to check that if
the current ID is already selected so we
are having four and this is the one that
we are clicking here so in that case we
can again make this one as null so if I
click here so it is three so here what
we can do simply we can basically check
if this gate current ID which is three
is equal to equal to this selected that
means already selected so we'll make
this one as null or else this will be
get current
ID so now save this let's say if I click
here so now it is null if I click here
again so this is three so let's say if I
click three again so it will be null
again if I click here this is four three
this is two this is one all right so now
this is fine now let's quickly complete
the style and then we will be moving to
the multiple approach so now let's go to
our style. CSS now the first thing is
that we are having this
wer now obviously we'll not uh um
basically cover much of The Styling
throughout this particular video because
our objective is to complete the
function because in interview obviously
you'll get a very limited amount of time
and in that time you have to not only
complete the simple approach but also
they will ask some multiple or complex
variation and obviously in interview
will'll face most of the times I can
guarantee that they will not expect any
kind of CSS from you only basic styling
is more than enough so this is exactly
what we are going to do so we'll do
display Flex height will do 100 VH
uh with we'll do 100
VW we'll do justify content Center and
align items will do
Center then I think we are having a
accordian so let's copy
this so here we'll do a width of 500
PX then we are having item so for this
one we'll do a background so for this
one we'll do this background six
4101 and we'll do a margin bottom
of 10 PX and we'll do padding of 10 PX
PX then I I think we having the title so
we'll do title so here we'll do color as
white we'll do display as
Flex we'll do justify content as space
between and we'll do align item as
Center
and we'll do cursor as pointer and at
the end we are having the content so
here we'll do color
as
white and we'll do height as
Auto and now what we need to do we have
to basically import this one in this so
we do
import
styles do
CSS let's save this let's see awesome
so now if I click here so you can see
that this is working fine now all right
so now you have completed the simple
approach so now they'll ask you how you
can achieve that if I click here this
will open again if I click here this
will also open this will not close only
it will close if I click here again so
this will be a multiple approach and
let's say they will ask you that how you
can do that you are having a button so
let's say enable multi- selection on
click of that only you want to show
multiple selection if I click here again
it will show the single
selection so this is a complex variation
let's say so how we are we can do so
first your uh job will be to create a
simple button and this will be enable
multi
selection let's save it all right so we
are having this button here and let's go
to
our so here we can do Flex direction as
column and we'll do a gap
of
20px okay then we'll do dot wrapper of
button we'll just simply give padding of
10 PX 20
PX and let's see how this is looking
okay background will give uh this one as
black and color will give white we'll do
font style as
bold sorry font weight will give as bold
and font size will give
20px awesome and now we'll give a cursor
as pointer and now let's use the same
background so we copy this and we'll use
the same here also
sorry okay
all right so now what you need to do
again you have to take another state not
only one but two so here I'll do const
enable so we'll do enable multi
selection set
enable multi selection and this will be
U state of
false all right and again you have to
take another state and that will be
multi select so whenever you select
multiple items you have to store
multiple IDs so here I'll do const
multi
multiple
selected or you can also keep this one
as multiple set
multiple and this will be US state of
empt array all right because you have to
store multiple uh
here so now what we can do basically the
first thing is that you have to enable
this m multi selection so here I'll do
on click and on click of this will do
set enable multi selection will be not
equal to enable multi selection so that
means we are basically toggling this one
so if this is false on click of this
button this will be true and vice versa
now again what you can do here on this
on click so if this enable multi
selection is true so that means you will
uh create another function that will be
handle multi selection or this will be
handle single selection so I'll do
function handle multi obviously you can
do the same in this function only but
I'm creating a separate so that it is
easier to understand so this will be
handle multi
selection this is also receive the
current
ID and here what we can do we'll do it
if this is
true
so uh this will basically get the handle
multi selection and here also we pass
the data item.
ID all right so that means if this
enable multi selection is true so that
means here we are doing this handle
multi selection if this is false we only
handle with single selection okay so now
what we need to do the first thing is
that whenever we clicking uh any
particular item we have to store this
one in this uh in this areay until
unless we'll click the same item again
then only you have to basically remove
it so how we do that so we'll do let
here first we'll copy the state from
this state variable so that we don't
mutate this state variable directly so
copy
multiple so this will be this multiple
so first basically we are copying from
this state and now we'll basically check
the index of this current ID if this ID
is already present in this array or not
if this ID play and that means we
already clicked on that so you have to
if I click that that again you have to
remove it from this are or else we'll
push it so con find
index of
current ID so how we'll do that simply
do it multiple sorry we'll do copy
multiple do index of this gate current
ID and now let's log here let's see what
is
happening if I now save it let's go
back so now if I go to cons what will
happen if I click here you can see this
is happening because currently this
multi selection is not
enabled but if I now click here now
let's click you can see we are getting
minus one so that means this is coming
here so that means this ID is not
present in this array so what we going
to do we can check if this find index is
equal toal to
minus1 so we'll simply do copy multiple
dopus and we'll push this uh current ID
all right else we'll do copy multiple do
splice we'll remove it so we'll get the
index so we'll remove this from this
particular index and how many items we
need to remove we need to remove only
one item that's it now if I click here
set sorry I have to set it to this state
so set multiple will be this copy
multiple okay now let's log here
multiple also and let's see what is
happening if I now save it let's go back
we'll enable this one now click
here sorry Let me refresh this
again so we'll enable this one if I
click here so you're getting one if I
click here again we are getting 1 2 3
and we getting four if I click here
again you can see one will be removed so
now 2 3 4 but you can see nothing is
opening the reason is what we can do
simply we can give condition here so
basically here either we can simply do
if this enable multi selection is true
so you have to basically check it from
this multiple or else you have to check
it from this selected so simply we can
do something like this so here we'll do
or multiple do index
of this data item do ID is not equal
toal to
minus1 all right this we can do or else
if this is very difficult to understand
if I now break it little bit so let's do
it very uh one uh line by line so let's
do something like this we'll do enable
multiple selection if this is true so
that means we are currently doing multi
select so if this is true so then we'll
check that in this multiple
array this
current ID is present or not ID is not
equal to equal to minus one all right if
this is true
so we'll s this
message or else we have to check if this
selected is equal to equal to data item.
ID then we'll show this this
one that's it now let me just remove
this or let's comment it out I'll
explain again what we are doing so we
are basically checking if this multi
selection is true so you're checking in
this multiple array if the current ID is
current data item. ID is present or not
so you're showing this if this is false
so that means you have to check from the
single one now let's see what is
happening if I now refresh this now now
enable multi selection is not enabled so
if I click here we are getting only one
at a time but now if I let's say enable
this one so now this is open this is
getting opened see if I click here now
this is closed and this is working
fine all right so this is another very
very important uh uh question that you
will get in some browser coding
interview round now first they will ask
you to create a simple accordion and
then once you'll solve that then it will
ask you to uh implement the multi
selection so that's all for this
particular project let's move on to the
next one all right so the second one now
this is also another very important
interview question so here the questions
will will be something like this that
you are having a button and on click of
this you have to create a random color
so if I click here you can see that the
random color is generated so now I
actually tried to make it little complex
so we'll be having two more button so if
I click here it will obviously create a
hex color so here you you can see that
each and every time if I click hex color
will be created if I try to create RGB
color so now this is getting changed to
R RGB color and if I click here so the
RGB color will be selected uh so sorry
created and here if I click again so you
can see that this is now my hex color so
this is another very very important very
frequently interview question so let's
try to implement this one all right
everyone so let's start with our second
one and that is to create any random
color so how the questions will be asked
uh let's say you are having one button
uh like generate uh random color so on
click of that button you have to let's
say change the enter background of this
particular page now obviously that will
be very the simple approach and after
that we'll be moving to the complex
variation so let's do one thing inside
components I'll create another folder
and let's give this on name as random
color so inside this I'll create another
file and this will be index. jsx I'll
just close everything else now here I'll
do export default function and let's
give this one name as random
color and here uh we return some div all
right
and here let's do one thing let's give a
class name of
container and inside this I'm having one
button and this will be Generate random
color so how the color concept basically
works now if you already have some idea
on the CSS you know that for the hex
color we are having this has and Then
followed by six digit right and then we
are having the RGB which is RGB
and then you have to basically give the
values here which will be like any
random value and this will basically
generate a color all right now obviously
for now uh how this can be asked is that
let's say you are having two more
buttons one is like create hex color and
one is to create RGB color now on click
of each and every button whenever you
click on this create RGB button so it
will create RGB color if you click on
this hex button it will create a hex
color so that will be little more
complex so let's see how we are going to
uh create this so for this one what I'll
do I'll create two more button so one
will be button here and this will be
create hex
color and you have to create another
mode button and this will be uh create
RGB
color all right now for this one uh what
you need to do first again I told you
that you have to explain the approach so
you are going to uh going to take two
State one will be to set the type so
type can be either hix or RGB and the
second one will be to store the current
color so here I'll take const and this
will be type of color let's give type of
color set type of color and by default
we'll take us St and here I'll keep this
one name as hex so hex is our default
color next we are having our color color
set
color and here I'm going to take this
one as US state and the by default I'll
take the black as our color all right
let's remove this one for now this class
name we don't need we'll keep this one
very simple so now what I'm going to do
I take our style uh here now the first
thing we'll do we'll take a WID as 100
VW we'll take a height as 100 VH we'll
take the back
ground so we're having this background
now background will be this color that
we are having all
right so for now this is fine let's save
it so now let's go to our
app.js and here we take another one and
this will be our random color
component and here I'm going to just
import the random color component let's
save
it and let's see what we are getting so
so we getting this random color
component let me just uh comment out
this one all right so that it will be
easier so I'll just comment out this
accordion let's save it all right so now
we are getting this three button so on
click of this you have to generate the
random color on click of here you have
to create RGB color and on click of this
you have to create a hex color so now
what you will do the first thing is that
we have to go here now the first thing
let's keep this one very simple so we'll
take on click method and here I'll do
set type of color which will be a hex
because on click of this I want to
create a hex color and here I want to
create a RGB color that's
it now what we need to do we have to
basically take another on click so here
I'll do handle create random
color so now this method I'm going to
create here so this will be function
handle
create random
color and here uh basically you have to
check that whether you want to create a
RGB color or you want to create a x
color let's do something like this
instead of creating like that we'll do
here that if the type of color is equal
to equal to
hex so I will create a hex
color a random hix
color or I'll do hand create random RGB
color so this will be our hex
color and then this will be
our RGB
color so now how we are going to create
a hex color now as I already told you
that the approach will be like this
you'll be having a has followed by six
digit something like that all right so
to do this one first you have to take
the hex uh array now how we are going to
create that so this will be consist of
the following things so we can have
numbers from 1 to 9 and then we can a
alphabet or basically letter of a b CDE
e f so here I'm going to take one 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 then we'll be having a
b
c d e and then f
that's it so this will be our array of
this hex now what we'll do we'll do let
hex color so this will obviously start
with our has and then what I'll do I'll
do for let I equal to 0 now because the
length will be of six so I'll do I less
than 6 because it is starting from zero
and then we'll do
i++ and here I'll do Hex
color
plus equal to and now what we need to do
basically we have to create a random
color now how we are going to create
this random color this random color will
be based on this length of this
particular uh hex that you have created
so for this one what we're going to do
we create another function and this will
be handle create uh let's give this one
name as function
utility random color utility
now this will basically receive the
length and here it is very very simple
what we need to do to basically floor
this so we'll do math. floor and then
you have to take the math. random and
then we are going to multiply this one
with this length that we'll be
receiving all
right so this will basically give you
the random color so now what we are
going to do will do Hex of this random
color utility and here we are going to
pass this XX do length so this is the
length so this will basically add the
rest of the color here after this all
right so if I now log
this and let's log this hex color let's
see what is happening so if I now go
here let's go to our console I'll create
on this click on this hex color and
let's click on here so you can see that
we are getting a random color here
every time this will be basically
generated so now this is very very
simple you just have to take set color
so you're basically setting this and
then it will be our hex
color all
right so only this part is very very
important that which uh values that you
have to take uh into consideration
inside this areay if I now click here
you can see the background is getting
changed and same will be for RGB color
so RGB color is actually pretty simple
so what you can do simply here we will
basically create our R GB these three
value so here I'll do const R and this
will be our random color utility and
here you have to basically multiply by
256 because this is the maximum length
that you can pass same will be for R
same will be for G same will be for B so
this will be r
g and then this will be B and now here
we'll do set color and here will take
template literals now here I as I
already told you it will start with RGB
and then you to pass this value so it
will be r value then it will be
our G value you have to also give
comma and this will be our uh B value
that's
it now to check this one let's do one
thing uh after this button we'll take
another div
here now here I'll do class name we'll
do display sorry not class last name
we'll do direct style so we'll do
display
as display as
Flex We Do justify content
Center we'll do align
items as
Center we'll do color as
white we'll do font
size as
60px and also do a margin top of 40 50
PX and inside this we are going to uh
let's do one thing uh let's take
something like this we'll take
H1 so here this will be our
color and we'll take a A3 here and this
will be our type of
color so here we can do something like
if the type of color is equal to RGB so
show here RGB
color or else this will be hex
color that's it let's save it let's see
what is happening so we are getting XX
color and now if I click here so you're
getting XX color let's click on this RGB
now you can see this is getting changed
but this is not getting changed so what
we can do simply this is another
interesting thing so you can take use
effect and every time this type is
basically getting changed so here we are
having this type of color so again we
can check if the type of color is equal
to equal to RGB so we'll call this
handle create RGB color else we'll call
this handle
create uh hex
color all
right
all right now let's click here so you
can see RGB and this is looking very odd
let's do one thing uh let's make this on
Flex dxn
as column and we'll do gap of
20px okay let's click X
color you can see this is working fine
if I click here so you're getting RGB
color
here and also I think another thing what
we need to do and that is
we have to go here and we have to give
bracket
here all right now click
here so you can see this is getting
changed if I click X here so you're
getting X color now let's
generate if I click here this is getting
changed and this is working fine so
that's all for this particular project
now this is also another very
interesting project now F first of all
another thing is that if you want to
create the same in JavaScript the
function will be exactly same so you
just have to create your HTML structure
and then you have to basically take all
of this using document. get element by
ID or query selector and then on click
of this button or basically have to add
event listener and then on click of this
even listener you have to basically
write the same functions that you have
written here nothing will change all
right so that's all for this particular
video let's move on to the next one all
right so the third one I think we don't
have to discuss much we all know that
this is one of the most frequently asked
questions in interview mostly in product
Bas companies like Adobe Amazon Atlas in
so here you are having this star and if
you H basically you have to show that
how many Star you are currently
selecting and if I click and then remove
so those many starts you have to
basically select it and again if I just
do hover and then click so this will be
updated so this is a very very famous
interview question so let's try to
implement this one in react CH all right
everyone so let's move on to the next
one so as I already told you this start
rating is another very very important
questions that you might be ask in your
interview now there can be two things
either your interviewer can say that you
have to basically implement this one in
a framework let's say like reactjs or
angular whatever you like or they
actually the requirement can be that
they will say that you have to implement
this one in pure vanilla JS so for this
one what I'll do in the next video that
I'll be creating whatever projects that
I'm creating for this particular video I
will be implementing these projects in
simple vanilla J in the next video all
right so let's see how we are going to
do that so for this one again I'm going
to create another folder inside these
components and let's give this one name
as star rating and inside this what you
can do you can simply create the same
structure index. jsx plus Styles uh
styles.
CSS now as I already told you that we
are not going to concentrate much on CSS
so for this one what I can do whatever
star you will be creating in the
interview either you can simply create
uh using CSS or simply you can create
some kind of circle that will also work
because at the end your interview
requirement will be to complete the
functionality first but because now we
are actually learning so what you can do
you can simply install a um project
sorry install a uh dependency here and
that is npm install react uh icons all
right now in the interviewer in in the
interview also if you are installing
this uh dependencies I think it is also
fine all right so now let's quickly
create our uh component here so you will
be creating export default function
let's give this one name as uh star
rating all
right now let's return here so we'll be
returning a class
name so here we'll return something like
star rating now what uh you can do uh in
the interview in the interview basically
you can ask your interviewer that how
many stars you basically want uh so
whenever you'll give any kind of
interview your Prime objective will be
to ask so many uh questions to the
interviewer obviously you'll get good
points based on that because let's say
uh you uh immediately start coding uh
your component without asking any
questions so that will basically give a
negative impression on the interviewer
so for example there can be requirement
is like let's say you are creating a
common component uh reusable component
and you will be basically receive some
of the proper is from props from the
parent component let's say the number of
starts that you want to create all right
so for this one what we'll assume that
okay we'll be receiving some kind of
props so I will basically receive a
props like number of starts and based on
this uh we will be creating so this will
be number of
STS now here uh what you need to do
basically inside this we will be
creating a array of these many starts so
here we'll do aray of this number of STS
all right by by default this will be
five let's say so if you're not passing
anything it will be five by
default now what you can do we can
simply map this one and here we
basically need this
index all right now here what we are
going to do basically I'll basically
explain the approach first let me return
that that star so for this one we will
be basically importing a icon from the
react icons package so let's import
something from uh react icons CL fa and
this is fa a uh
star all right so here we'll be
returning this fa
start now here the first thing we need
to pass the key so we'll be passing key
as this index all right and also here we
need to pass some kind of class name
that we are going to do later we need to
pass a onclick uh property here sorry so
on click uh whenever we will will be
clicking on some particular star we need
to basically take the current current
index and then we have to basically show
some kind of styling and also we need a
on Mouse enter so whenever we'll be
basically hovering on that particular
and also we need on Mouse leave now
these all the things whatever we are
creating here you have to basically
explain that this methods we want to
create in this component only all this
all the methods we will be receiving
from the parent component all
right and at the end what we are going
to pass we will also pass the size so
size will be let's say 40 now here what
I'm going to do I'll create a state here
so this will be let's say give this one
as rating and this will be Set uh rating
for this one we are going to keep a UST
start of zero all right first time we
will not select any start and also you
have to take another state and that is
whenever we will be hovering on some
particular St you have to to basically
show some kind of styles also that uh
which is the current state or basically
current index you are hovering so for
this one we'll take a hover uh State and
this will be set
hover and this is also will be U state
of
zero all right now here what I'm going
to do I will be basically receiving uh
sorry I'll be creating a method so this
will be handle click now this handle
click what it will receive it will
receive the current index that you are
clicking so this will be G
current index and I'm actually repeating
this again and again whenever you'll be
giving any interview you need to explain
all of this that why you are doing this
one so that it will obviously give you
good points same next we'll be creating
another uh function this will be handle
Mouse enter now obviously I can directly
do this one here but I'm just uh writing
or breaking everything so that it is
easier to understand now whenever you'll
be entering or Mouse entering it will
also receive the current index same will
goes for handle uh let's say mouse
leave this is also will receive great
current index so these all are the uh
method that we are creating here so this
I'm going to call this one so this will
be handle click and here I'm going to
pass the index now what we are going to
do so this will start from zero so what
we can do simply we can increase this
index by one so simply we can do index +
one so that means here whenever we'll
pass IND index instead of zero it will
be passing let's say you are passing
number of Star as five so it will start
with uh index one then it will be two it
will be three four and five all right
that's it now same you have to pass the
index here also sorry we have to
basically call this method so we are
going to call handle Mouse enter and
here I'm going to pass index and here
I'm going to do handle Mouse leave and
I'm going to to pass the index that's it
now let's log here let's see what we
getting so I'm going to copy and paste
it and let's paste it here now let's
save it now let's
see also you have to basically import
this component here so I'm going to
again comment it out and I'm going to
giving another one so this is our star
rating component so here I'll giveing
star rating and here I'm going to
passing the number of Star as let's say
10 let's save this let's see what we are
getting all right now you see if I now
go to
console and if I now you can see we are
getting this three four if I click here
we are getting four if I removing we are
getting four that means we are first we
are getting Mouse enter Then if I click
we are getting on click and then if I
now remove this cursor we'll be getting
on leave so that means let's see if I
just overover or click this one so I
have to basically show some kind of that
these many are selected so this is the
end point and this all will be basically
selected if I click on the last that
means last will all last will be or
basically all the starts will be
selected so how we are going to
basically do that so what we can do
simply
here we have to basically take a class
name so that we can show some kind of
active state so we take a class name all
right so here what we can do basically
we can take this index so this index is
basically current index if this is less
than or equal to the current hover state
that we are
having so this one or this rating state
so let's say if I click on this current
uh star which is let's say three so we
are basically showing some kind of State
in this uh all these three starts
basically so the current one will be
three and the current overover which is
basically the we are basically setting
on this mouse enter or basically Mouse
uh leave all right so if this is true so
what we going to do we basically show
some kind of um here uh class which will
be let's say active or
inactive now here we need to do
basically set this set rating as this
get current
index and here we need to do set hover
as get current index all right but for
this mouse leave what we need to set we
have to set this set
over this will be basically equal to the
current rating because if I already
clicked on this fourth start that means
these four are already selected so if I
now leave this mouse this should be
selected here so that means we are
basically one Mouse leave we are setting
this uh handle Mouse leave or basically
on this method setting the set over as
the current rating which is we already
selected so in this case we basically
don't need this get current index so we
can basically remove this one and I
think that's it so now we can go to our
style before that let me just import
this
one and let's go to our style so what we
can do we can simply we'll take a uh
class of active so for this one we going
to make the color so we'll do this color
FF
f70 all right if this is
inactive so we are going to make the
color as let's say
black and I think that's it if I now
save this now let's see so you can see
if I now hover this is working if I now
let's click here and now remove this see
these four are already
selected all right if I now come here
and selected Sol three are selected and
if you see if I now enter here so till
this part is now selected if I now
remove this one you can see the previous
one whatever is there that is actually
selected so that is the reason we are
taking the current rating state but if I
now go to this let's say fifth one and
now click and then remove now you can
see this is now updated so this is the
whole process that you need to do or
basically this is how you can explain in
your interview now this is a very very
important questions that you might
encounter in your browser coding
interview so that's all for this
particular project let's move on to the
next one all right so the next project
project is another very important
interview questions and that is to
implement a image slider so here most of
the times your interviewer will give you
some dummy data or dummy array where
let's say you are having the image URLs
and you have to you have to just render
and create this slider now for this one
we obviously not using any third party
Library packages so I'm I actually make
this one little bit Advanced so here the
data you are basically seeing so this
data we uh we are getting from API and
then we are rendering and based on that
we'll be creating this image
uh slider so let's start working on this
particular project all right everyone so
let's start with our next one so next
one as I already uh discussed so you
need to create a image slider now there
can be two things in the interview one
is that the interviewer will give you
subd data with some image URL and then
they will uh tell you that based on this
image URL you have to basically render
these images and then you have to create
your slider or the second thing will be
they will give you a API URL so first
they will tell that okay first you have
to fetch this list of images you have to
render this and then you have to create
your slider on top of it now obviously
this URL can be dynamic anything so
you'll be receiving this URL from props
and also you can see the page number and
this limit so this limit can be anything
So currently we are having 10 if I now
pass here five so it will give you only
five images something like that so let's
see how we are going to do that now the
reason why I'm doing with API because
API version is is obviously the little
bit complex if they will give you some
dummy data obviously it will be very
very easy so you just have to take the
dummy data as a props and then you have
to pass that data to your component so
for this one what we'll do again let's
create another component here and I'll
give this on name as image slider now
one thing is that if they're giving
giving you some dummy data so let's you
will create one file inside of this
let's say dumy data.js and then you will
basically get the data from this
component currently we will be basically
calling the API so for now this is fine
so here I'll be creating index. GSX
let's close this
one and we'll be creating our uh so here
we'll be creating styles. CSS now here
let's create so this will be export
default function image slider now this
will receive the URL and also it will
receive the limit for example let's
say now here what what we are going to
do we will be returning a
div and let's give this one name as a
class name as a
container all right so now the first
thing what we are going to do will be
basically calling the API so here for
this one we need to take some state so
here let's take something like
const uh so here the data we uh let's do
one thing let's take our images straight
here only set images and this will be US
state of empty array also we need to
take another one and that is our current
slide so this will be our current
slide and Set current
slide and the current slide will be set
to zero for the first time so this is
our initial state so now what you need
to do you have to again I already
mentioned that you have to explain
everything so you'll be receiving this
URL you have to basically check that if
this URL is empty or something goes
wrong so you have to show the or
basically render the message so for this
one what we going to do we'll take a use
effect and here we'll take this URL as a
dependency because based on this URL you
need to check and here we'll check if
this URL is not equal to equal to empty
then only we want to call some API so I
think we can remove this part so we'll
call fet images something like that and
we are going to create this one so this
will be asnc method so as sync function
Fage
images all right and I think here we can
pass this URL so we receive get
URL and now uh now see whenever you'll
give some interview always try to cover
the error handling process because they
or else they will ask you that why
haven't you uh handle the error properly
so take a try catch
here and and here let's say I'll take
another state so this will be our
error message
set error message and let's give this
one as a use St of
null something goes wrong so that means
we'll set here set error message as e do
message something like that now here
what we'll do we do const
response this this will be AIT
Fage and here we need to pass the URL
sorry we have to get the URL so get
URL all right and then we'll do const
data this will be AIT response.
Json all right now here we are going to
check if this data is true so we are
going to set uh set images as this data
or basically whatever you'll be
receiving for I'm keeping this one as
data now here always take another state
and that is the loading State because
whenever you will be handling any kind
of API call so always take the loading
State and this will be U state of
false all right now before calling the
API we're going to make the set loading
as true and if we are getting the data
so make the set loading as
false if there are any error we are
going to make the set loading as false
all
right so this is fine now we are going
to check if there if it is loading so
we'll simply return some uh message
like
loading data please
wait all right and also you can
basically check if there is any kind of
error message if this is not equal to
equal to
null so so we are going to return the
div we show
error
occurred and I'm not sure if this
spelling is wrong or correct but that is
fine and then we are going to render
this error message
here all right now let save this now
what we going to do uh we basically need
to pass the URL from this parent
component because obviously this is a
reusable component so need to call this
one from the parent so I'm going to just
comment it out again then give another
comment so this is our image slider
component so here I'm going to call our
image
slider and we're going to pass our URL
so now let's see so let's copy this one
from
here so this is our URL and also you're
going to pass the limit as let's say 10
all right
uh so this is fine so now let's go here
so what we going to
do here we can take a template literals
so we get our gate URL and here we are
going to pass the extra PMS now
obviously if you want you can pass this
extra params also from your pattern
component but for now let's keep this
one simple so pass it here page equal to
one I'm keeping and this limit will be
this uh limit that you will be receiving
from your component
if you want you can also pass this page
let's pass the page also so here we will
give uh pass here
page let's make this one default as five
and the page as
one and here I'm going to pass the pag
as
one all
right now let's save this now let's see
uh what we are getting in these images
so I log here
images so now let's go
there all right so you can see that we
are getting 10 images here so this is
working fine if I now go to parent
component let's pass this one as a four
limit as four now let's see if I now
refresh this we are getting four now so
this is working fine so now what you
need to do we have to basically render
these images here based on your parent
whatever you're passing you're able to
basically face the
data so this is working fine let's keep
this one as St only now I'll go back and
then we'll basically create our uh GSX
so the first thing is that what we going
to do here we are having this container
now I'm going to take some uh icon from
this react
icon so here let's import something from
react icons
slbs and the arrow name is I think BS
Arrow left Circle fi yes and then we are
having BS
Arrow right Circle
fill now here I'm going to basically
render this left one so we are having
two arrows so this is the left one and
here we need some on click but that we
are going to do later and here I'm going
to take some class name so we'll take a
class name we make this one as Arrow
Arrow
left all right so after this what you
need to do you to basically render your
images so you'll check if the images and
then images. length if this is true or
else this will be null so here what I'm
going to do I return this one so we'll
do images. map so this is our image
item and here what we going to return
written a simple
image we'll pass a key here which will
be image item do ID we are having then
we pass alt here which I'll keep this
one as let's see what we getting here so
we are
getting
author I think let's uh pass this
download URL
only so we'll pass the same so we do
image item. download
URL next we need to pass a source so
Source will be image item. download
URL and also you have to pass a class
name but for now this there is a trick
part so that we are going to do for now
we'll keep this one as current slide or
current image something like
that all right so this is fine now next
after this what we going to do we'll uh
render our right
Circle and here what we can we can
simply take a class name so for this one
also we'll take Arrow Arrow right also
have to take a on click and then we also
need to basically render the circles so
here what we are going to do we'll do a
span
here and we'll render a class name and
we'll give this one as uh
Circle
indicators all right here I'm going to
render again the images and then
images do length if this is true so here
or else this will be null so again I'll
do
images do
map so we need the current
index and here I'm going to re render a
button and we are going to give some key
so key I'm going to give this one as
index and also we going to give a class
name so we'll give this one as current
indicator later we are going to do when
we'll do the we'll uh complete the
functionality so this is our current
indicator if I now save all of this now
obviously this will
break nothing will work for
now so you can see that we are not able
to see anything all right so this is
fine but now what we are going to
do we need to basically start working on
the functionality first but before that
let's uh quickly complete the
CSS so let's start with our first one so
we are having container uh let me import
this one first so we do import style.
CSS so we'll start with our
container all right so we'll do po as
relative we'll do display as
Flex we'll do justify content as Center
we'll do align items also as
Center uh we'll do width as 600
PX and we'll do height as let's make
this one as 450
PX this is
fine okay now next uh we are having
the current image so here we are having
the current image so let's copy this
so we'll do current image and for this
one we'll do a border radius as 0.5
RM we'll do a box sadow we'll do 0 PX 0
PX 7
PX 666 this is the color and we'll do
width as
100% and height as
100% all
right all right we are getting some
error a is not
defined all right here we are getting
okay okay now this is coming you can see
but obviously this will not work that is
okay now what we are going to do next we
are having the uh I think we are having
what else we're having the arrow so we
going to take dot Arrow so so for Arrow
we'll do this one as Po and as absolute
because we already have taken the parent
as relative all right and here uh we are
going to do width as 2 RM height as 2 r
m and color we are going to take as
white let's take a filter also here so
we're going to do filter we'll do a drop
shadow and here we're going to do 0 PX 0
PX 5 PX we'll do
555 okay now next uh we are having
the arrow left so we are having do Arrow
left so for Arrow left we are going to
do left as 1 RM then we are having the
right so for the right what we're going
to do sorry for right we'll do the right
so we'll do right and this will be right
as 1
RM this is fine now next we having the
circle indicators so let's go there
let's copy
this and here we having the circle
indicators so we'll do as display as
Flex we'll do poison as
absolute and we'll do bottom
as 1
RM now next we're having the current
indicator so this is the one so we copy
this and we'll paste it here so we'll do
background color as
white we'll do a height of 15 PX we'll
do width of 15
PX we'll do a border radius of uh border
radius of how much
50% uh we'll do border as none we'll do
outline as
none all right uh what else we'll do a
margin
we'll do 0 comma 0.2 RM and we'll do
cursor as
pointer all right so you can see that
this is coming here now what we need to
do see the main logic of a slider is
that you have to show the current one
and you have to hide all of the others
correct so how you are going to do that
so for that is the reason uh we have
taken this state which is the c current
slide so now we have to basically work
on this one so what we need to do we are
having two arrows and based on these two
arrows we have to take a on click so the
first one so we'll take on click here
sorry we'll take on click here so here
what we can do we'll take handle uh
previous something like that and then
here we are having the on click and
we'll do handle
next now another thing what we need to
do we have to take a on
click on this button also but that we do
in some time but let's quickly create
these two function first so we are
having function handle
previous and then we having function
handle
next now what we going to do to set the
current slide so do Set current slide
now for the previous how the logic will
be let's say you are at the end of the
sorry you are at the first so let's say
you in the first image and you're
clicking here but on left we don't have
any other image right so what you have
to do I have to basically show the last
one on click of the previous Arrow but
if you're at the end of this slide let's
say here and you're clicking on the next
one so again you have to show the first
one correct and if you are at the first
and if you're clicking here so you to
show the last one so here what we can do
we do set previous so we can simply
check if the Set current slide when
you're clicking on the first one if the
current slide is equal to equal to zero
that means you are at the first so what
we can do we can simply set this one as
this images. length minus one so we'll
be showing the last image or else this
will be current slide minus one okay so
that means again I'm explaining let's
see if you're here on the fourth one so
if you're clicking on the left one so
you'll be going to the third one you
clicked again you go to to the second
one you clicked here again go to the
first one now you're at the first we
don't have anything else if I click here
we are again seeing the last one okay
now same will be for the next one so
this will be Set current slide so here
we'll check if the current slide is
equal to equal to data sorry we having
images. length minus one so that means
you are at the end here so if you click
here you against so the first one so in
this case what you need to do to set
this one to zero or else this will be
CCT and slide plus
one that's
it now let's save it now what we need to
do to basically set a uh class name here
we have to update this class name so
what we can do we can basically cut it
and we can check that if the current
slide is equal to equal to current index
so we'll take index here let's take an
index here so if this is equal to equal
to this index so that means we are going
to show this current image or also we
going to hide this one so we'll do
current image and then we'll do hide
current image all right I hope you're
getting the same basically you have to
do it for the uh this one also so we are
having this circles right so here also
we're going to hide so we'll cut it here
so we'll going to do if the current
slide is equal to equal to this index so
you're going to show the current uh
sorry we are going to do the current
indicator so we'll copy this
one if this is true so you're going to
set this onto current indicator or else
this will be current indicator and hide
current
indicator all
right this is fine and here on click of
this button this is pretty simple what
we can do so whenever we'll click on
this this one here so you have to show
the fourth one if I click here it to
show the current fifth one so this is
pretty simple we can simply set the
current slide as this
index now let's format this now what we
need to do we have to go to the style
and then you have to basically hide that
one so we are having this height current
image so copy
this go to
Styles and then we'll
do here display as none so you don't
show the others and same will be for
this one also what we can do so we can
go here and we can do let's make this
one as not hide we'll do
update so we'll update the current
one so the all let's make this one as
what we can do so we having already
current we'll do inactive we'll do
inactive inactive
indicator so here we'll copy this so
those are are not inactive we going to
change the color so let's make this one
color as uh
gray let's save it now let's
see all right so this is changing but
this is not uh the color is not changing
here all right let me just
check so we having indic uh inactive
indicator oh sorry we have to make this
one as background
color now I think this will work yeah so
now if I change this one so this is
changing now let's go at the end click
here it's going to the
first if I now click here again so it's
going to the last and this is working
fine awesome all right so I think that's
all for this particular project now this
is another important project that you
might get ask in your browser coding
interview and this is pretty simple what
I have done if they're giving you d data
obviously you can directly take the d
data instead of calling the API but if
they're telling that you have to call
the API so you call Api set a current
slide set a loading State and then you
just have to basically make this
functionality that's it so that's all
for this particular project let's move
on to the next one awesome now this
project is very important so this is
called load more products or load more
button or also the same concept you can
use in infinite scroll also obviously
I'm not I'm saying that
that is not exactly same but the concept
will be almost similar the uh properties
and the features and the methods that
you're going to use for infinite scroll
that will be different so here what we
are doing we uh in the interview
interviewer will give you a URL and
there will be a limit uh property in the
API URL so let's say we are calling some
20 data first time if I click on this
button again so we have to render the
next set of data obviously but the data
we are currently having we don't have to
reender under this data again so this
data is already present here right so if
I click this one we'll be showing some
loader and next set of data is uh
selected now the uh here the point is
once it will reach to the 100 products
you have to disable this uh button so if
I click here so now we are getting next
set of data and if I click here again so
you can see that now this button will be
disabled and you have reached to the 100
products now if you are giving interview
companies like Amazon on Adobe and Atlas
and also you might get ask these
particular questions so I'm requesting
everyone to please uh practice this one
all right so let's uh try implementing
this one obviously for this one also we
not use any any other third party
Library packages we'll be using only
react the same logic you can also
Implement in your
JavaScript if you're implementing the
same in vanilla GS all right everyone so
let's move on to the next one so next
one is another very important questions
that you might get in in your interview
and that is uh let's say you are having
some scenario like you are getting a
data from API but instead of calling all
the data at once you are having a load
mode button so every time you'll click
on this button you will be basically
loading the next set of data now this is
actually similar to infinite scroll but
this is also another very very important
question that you might get asked so
let's do one thing let's create another
folder inside these components and let's
give this one as load more
button
or let's keep this one as load more
data so here I'm going to create index.
jsx and styles do
CSS all right so for this one uh we are
going to use this dummy Json uh products
this URL so how this will basically work
you can see that we are having this
limit and this skip so we going to
basically use this parameters now it
doesn't matter that what you you are
getting at the end the functionality
will be same for most of them so now
what we going to do will be basically
fishing the products we will be
rendering the products and there will be
a button at the bottom of the page and
every time you click on this button
you'll be rendering the next set of data
now if I know show you the output you
can see that we are having the total is
100 so once the data length is 100 we
need to basically disable the button and
you will not be able to load more uh
data again so this is basically the
function
so let's quickly create this component
and now I'm again telling now this is
one of the very important asked
questions in like companies like Amazon
ad Atlas on these
companies so let's create this one as
load
more data now it's up to you if you want
to change the component name you can
basically change
it for now I'm going to R return here a
div and let's give a class name I'll
give this one as container
now if you want you obviously you will
be able to take the URL from your parent
component as we have already done in the
image slider well let's create all the
state in this component only so here I'm
will be taking some State one will be
our loading State as I already done in
the previous project so this will be set
loading and which will be used state of
false then we need a uh data state or
let's make this one as
products set
products and this will be US state of
empty array and also we need basically
the count or page number whatever you
can take count is basically how many
times you're clicking on this button so
we'll take a count here and this will be
set count now first time this will be
zero
right so this is all the state we need
so now what you need to do you have to
basically ask all the clarifying
questions to to your interviewer that uh
will this URL will be always same or
basically this will basically change
based on different
requirement this limit 10 will be always
fixed or basically you have to change
this one this skip something like that
but for now what we going to do we will
be keeping the limit as 20 and then uh
we will be basically skipping every time
20 all right so the reason is because
whenever we will be loading the data for
the first time we'll be loading 20 data
next time whenever we'll be clicking on
this but but and we no need to load the
previous data because that data will be
always stored in our state so let's see
how we are going to do that so again we
are going to take use
effect and here I'm going to create a
method so this will be fet
products so this will be asking function
fet
products we'll take a try and catch
block
and we're going to log this error for
now if you want you can take another
state and you can set the eror here now
this will be const response this will be
equal to AIT
fet and here now the trick part and that
is we are going to take till this por
and here we are going to copy this and
then we'll paste it here now see what we
need to basically do the limit will be
20 limit is always fixed means every
time we want to get 20
data so this will be 20 but skip here
the catch so first time you're loading
the 20 data right so first time you
don't need to skip anything so first
time you have to keep this one as zero
but next onwards let's say if I click
the button first time so the count will
be one so when we'll be clicking the
data for the the button for the first
time we already have 20 data in our
state so we are going to skip those 20
data or basically previous data so how
we are going to do that so the logic is
something like this so here we are going
to do let me take this on as template
literals so here logic will be if the
count is equal equal to zero that means
for the first time we don't need to skip
any data because we don't have any data
currently but next onwards what we can
do we can simply take this page sorry
the count number so next time when we'll
be clicking on this button the count
will be one and then we already have the
20 data so we going to skip 20 I hope
you're getting now when the count will
be two so we'll be skipping 40 data
something like that then we are having
const result and this will be equal to
AIT
response.
Json and let's log this result
here and what else we need to do I think
this is fine let's save this and I'll go
to our app
.js and I'm going to comment out this
component
here I'm going to take another one and
this will be load more products
component so this will be
load more data let's save it let's see
what we are
getting so you can see that we are
getting products 20 you are getting only
20 products the total is 100 the limit
is 20 here and we are skipping zero all
right awesome so this is fine so now
what we can do we can simply check here
if this
result and and result dot length sorry
result do
products and then result do products do
length if this is true sorry this will
be length so we are going to do set
products as result dot products also we
going to make the set loading as true
here and here we are going to make the
set loading as
false and if there are any error we are
going to make this one as
false awesome so now let's save it and
here we'll check if the loading is true
so we'll return return something like
div that loading
data
please
wait all right now here uh we'll take
another
div and inside this we're going to check
if this products and then products.
length if this is
true so you're going to map these
products do map this will be item let's
take a div
here
and now so let's see what we are getting
in the products so you're having the ID
so you can take the key as this item.
ID and we'll keep this one very very
simple we'll see what we are getting we
are having this thumbnail so let's
implement this one let's take this one
so we'll take a
image it will be source which will be
item do
thumbnail all right also let's take a
alt so alt we're going to take the item
dot I think we are having
[Music]
name uh we'll take this one as title so
we're having item.
title and inside this we going to sorry
after this we'll take the item do title
and I think this will be more than
enough for now for this one we're going
to take a class class name and this will
be our
product and here I'm going to take
another class name and this will be
product
container let's save this now after this
we'll take another div and here will be
having this button which will be load
more
products so here I'm going to take a
class name and we will give button
container awesome so now let's go to our
Styles and and let's quickly create our
style so we having the container so for
this one we'll take a display as Flex
Flex Direction we'll take column and
we'll take a gap of
20px next we are having the product
container so we'll copy
this so here we are going to take this
one as display grid we'll take grid
template columns as repeat we are going
to repeat let's say four and one eer
and then we are having we'll be taking
gap of 10
PX next we are having the product so
here we're going to take dot product so
we'll take a padding of 20 PX we'll take
border of one PX
solid all right and what else uh we are
going to also take a display as Flex
we'll take Flex direction as column and
we'll take a gap of 10 PX
now let's import
our style.
CSS all right we are getting
something let's see what is happening
here oh I think we I think it's taking
from somewhere else this 600 let me give
some different uh name here so we'll
give this one as load
more
container so let's save
this yeah so this is
fine uh let's make this one as three
let's see what is
happening all right I got it so we'll do
one thing we'll take this do product and
then
image uh we'll make this one as width
small 200
PX and height 200
PX awesome so I think this is fine for
now see at the end we need to see
whether our functionality is working or
not so we getting 20 data so now what we
need to do whenever we clicking on this
button we have to render the next set of
data but we not be R we'll not be
rendering this data we are already
having in the UI so for this one what we
can do uh we can we are already having
this button and then we'll take a on
click here and we'll basically do set
count as count +
one all right so this is the first step
and then here we are having this set
products we storing right so we can take
our previous data here so we do pre data
which is already stored so we'll
basically first take the pre data and
then we'll take our result. products all
right so now let's see what is happening
here so if I now go back now let me
refresh it again all right now if I now
go to inspect go to network
tab now let's click here all right
nothing is happening so the what is the
reason so the reason is pretty simple
every time this count value will change
you have to call the uh this F H
products uh function so we'll take this
count as a dependency now let's
see so now let's refresh this so we
getting 20 data now let's click on
next so you're getting 20 data again
let's click here so you're getting next
data if you go here you can see we are
now skipping 40 and the limit is 20
first time we skip 20 and at the first
time we skip zero if I click here again
to it will skip 60 data because we
already have
all
right and now next we'll go here if I
click here so you're already having
total you can see we are now having
total 100 data and this total is also
100 so let's say your interviewer will
tell you that if some of the your
current data which is basically this
products if this data is length is 100
so you need to disable your button so
how you're going to do that so that is
pretty simple so we'll take another
State here so we'll do uh
disable
button and set disable button which will
be use state of
false and now you'll take another use
effect
here and then we'll keep these products
as a dependency and we can simply check
if these products and and products do
length if this is equal toal 100 so
you're going to make set disable button
as true all right so now what you can do
we can simply make this take a disable
property and this will be equal to if
this disable button is
true that's it and now we can also
render if this disable button is true so
render message that you have reached to
100 products
or else this will be null now let's see
if this is working or not let's save
it so now let's refresh
this so
20 now this is
60 we are having 80 now if I click here
again so now we having total 100
products you can see this is not disable
and you reach to the 100 products so
you'll not be able to call any uh API
now so this is how the main logic of
load mode button load mode button
functionality works all right so I think
that's all for this particular project
let's move on to the next one now this
one I can guarantee you that I'm not
telling that you will not face the
similar questions in your interview but
the questions pattern will be somwhat
same so they might say that you have to
create a Tre view so you the logic will
be almost same they can say you to
create a dynamic navigation menu the
answer will be almost same they can also
tell you that please create a Implement
a recursive menu UI then answer will be
also same sometimes they will give you
some uh nested uh data structure and you
have to basically uh they will tell the
interviewer will tell that you have to
simplify it so then also the structure
will uh the answer will be almost same
so here you can see that we having main
parent menus if I click here the child
will be basically uh opened you have to
toggle this one so if I now click on
this parent all the Childs will be
hidden all right so this is what exactly
we need to implement here now also
sometimes they'll say that on click of
this level you have to render some page
but again this is pretty simple the at
the end our objective will be to learn
this feature because if they tell that
on click of this you have to render The
Details page so you'll give the URL of
this page and then based on that you'll
be rendering so I'll be discussing that
one in the later while implementing this
one but in this project we have to
basically see how we will be rendering
this child parent relationship and then
based on that we'll create this tree
structure so let's start working on this
very very important uh interview
questions in the next part all right
everyone so let's get started so as I
already told you that in the interview
most of the times they will share some
kind of data which will be like nested
now this data format can be anything at
the end you should know basically the
logic how this is working now I'm
repeating this one again because this is
one of the very very important question
most of the times they will ask you this
now the question can be vary like they
can tell you that you have to build a
nested navigation menu or you have to
implement recard menu UI or like uh what
they will say that will give you some
Json structure you have to simplify it
and then based on that you have to
render that one in the UI so here you
can see the structure that we are having
we are having a label and then we having
a two two is basically path so don't uh
worry about this one because currently
we have to basically focus on this
particular structure how this data is
actually coming here and inside each and
every object we are having this children
now this is very very important which
will be arrrow of objects now again
inside this the structure is exactly
same so again you are having a label
then again the two two is basically the
path that you want to navigate to on
click of this particular link and again
you are having the children which is
again the same
structure so now in the interview first
you have to explain all of this that
what you want to do what part you want
to
and how the function will work once you
have done all the discussion then just
you just take the data and then we again
do the same process we'll create another
folder now again I am here giving the
name as treeview you can give based on
the requirement that you are getting in
your interview all right so if they're
telling that you have to create a menu
UI so obviously you'll be giving the
folder name based on the requirement so
here the first thing I'm going to create
a
data.js and I'm going to paste this data
data so this is our uh let's give this
one name as uh menus all right and then
we are going to do export default
menu that's it let me just close
everything now let's create our index.
jsx and then styles. CSS so here let's
quickly create the component so this
will be export default function now here
I'm giving this one as uh Tre
now again here you will be basically
getting the data or basically the menus
from the pattern component so always
you'll be receiving from the pattern
component so I'm giving this one as
menus which will be empty array and here
we have to basically do the
functionality now here how this will
work now the first thing is that if you
see the structure so let me just show
you so here you have to first render
this label and then you have to check
that whether this particular object is
having any children or not so so yes
there is a children so you have to again
recursively call the same component and
it will basically go on so again this
will take this children it will render
this level and again it will check
whether there is a children or not yes
there is a children so again it will do
the same process again and again so for
that is the reason we need two more
component here so I'll be giving the
name as one is menu
list and then we are having a menu item
which will basically render the each and
every item so here this is item this is
item here this is the item and this is
item so on so this will be our menu item
do jsx so now in the main component so
this is your tree view component here
you will be first checking that whether
there is a length is greater than zero
or not in this menu's length so here we
are going to return return and here
let's return a div which is our main div
so here I'll give a class name name
let's give this one a three view
container and here first we need to what
we can do we can simply render or let me
just quickly create the menu list
component so list will take the list of
data now I'm creating each one each and
every component separately so that it
will be easy to understand also in the
interview time also you should different
um create small small chunk of component
so that you will be able to explain your
interview properly and also this is also
much more structured so here I'm going
to create this on export
default uh sorry export default function
this will be menu
list now again this will receive the uh
list of data which will be again default
I'm taking this one as empt now it will
return a div now here what we can do uh
we'll take a class name here we'll give
this on as uh menu list container
something like that now here you you
need to basically check if this least
and and list do length if this is
greater than zero or basically if this
is true or else we show null here or you
can show some message that is also fine
that no menu is present so here what you
need to do basically this menu list will
map the list of data and it will return
the single menu menu item so here let me
just quickly create this component also
so that it will be easier to understand
so here I'll be creating the component
so this will be function and this will
be menu item now what this menu item
will receive menu item will receive a
single item as I already told you so
this is our single item
here all right now here let me just
quickly return some menu item and later
we'll be changing this one so that we'll
be able to understand what is happening
so now this will basically map here so
this will do list do map this will be
list item and here it will going to
return menu item item and here you'll be
passing the item which will be your
Leist item all right so that means it is
actually three-step process in your
pattern component you are calling the
menu list item and then sorry from the
pattern component first you're calling
your main treeview component which is
calling the menu list component and this
is calling the menu item component so
here I'll simply return so here in this
component what we going to do we simply
call the menu list component and here
we'll be passing the list which will be
our menus all right these
menus awesome so now let's save this now
we'll go to our
app.js and let me just quickly comment
out this part here I'll give another
comment and this will be our tree view
component or this will be menu UI
component or this will be also recursive
navigation menu anything you can
basically use the same logic here so
here I'm going to call the tree view
component and here I'll be passing the
menus which will be basically our menus
that we are having here all right so
this menu is basically this static data
so now let's format and save this and
let's see what is happening here so you
can see that we are getting menu item
three times now here I want to explain
each and everything the reason is why
you are getting three times because it
is only rendering the parent com parent
uh menus here so you're having one then
you're having two then you're having
three so that is the reason you are
getting this one three times because
currently we are not checking if the
children is present or not if the
children is present again we have to
basically recursively call the same
component but how we are going to do
this one now to do that each and
everything the logic mainly will be in
your menu item component so here now let
me show you how we can basically do that
so the first thing let let me just go to
menu list component and here uh what we
can do uh instead of rendering a div I
think we can render a
ul and here in the menu item we render a
AI instead of a div now let me just
remove this one now the first thing what
we will basically do uh later we are
going to change the structure but first
let's understand so here I'm going to
render the item. level
now this item do level is basically this
level that we are having here so let me
just save this so we are getting home
profile and settings main three parent
so now what we can do
here the first thing is that we need to
basically check whether this item has a
children or not so here we can simply
check if this item and and item do
children and and item do children.
length if this is true let's give
greater than zero so we render null or
else what we need to do here now you can
pause the video and try to find out by
your own because this is a very
important concept that you will
basically learn how you can recursively
call a particular component so here what
we need to do we have to call now this
is very important you have to call this
menu list component only because this
will receive the list now if you go to
this structure you'll see that okay for
the first one we don't have any children
so it will basically give you null but
for the second one we are having this
children so children is again the array
of object so this Arrow of object we are
going to pass in this menu list
component which will again call the menu
item component so that means in this
component we are recursively calling
this menu list component if the item has
a children if the item don't have any
children so it will be null so here what
we can do simply we'll call the menu
list component here and then you have to
pass the list now list will be basically
this item. children I hope you're
getting so that means what we have done
we are recursively calling this menu
list component from this menu item
component which will again call the menu
item component inside of this if I now
go here see now we are getting all of
this so we getting home profile inside
profile we are having details then we
are having location then we are having
settings account security and inside
security you can see that we are having
login and register so till this part you
have done now your interviewer will ask
you that okay so you are able to
basically see what will happen if I not
try to add a new one in this location
inside location so let's see what is
happening so I'll go to data now let's
go to location so here I'll again a
children and here I'll add a label so
I'll just add a Rand random value so
this will be random value or let's add a
CT so this will be a
CT and and I'll add two which will be
to uh
City so now if I save this sorry if I
now save this see now inside location
you are getting City so that means it is
recursively calling the same component
again and again so this is working fine
so now your interviewer will ask you
okay till this part this is fine now
what you need to do for the parent one
so let's say this parent this parent and
this parent and again each and everyone
is the parent of its children
you have to show a plus iccon if that
that particular item has a children so
you have to basically show a plus icon
and whenever we will click on this plus
icon or basically expand icon then only
you need to basically show the children
and vice versa so if you click again so
it will be toggling basically so that
toggle functionality you need to
implement so how we are going to do that
now later we'll do the uh styling but
for now let's complete the functionality
so to do this one what you need to do we
have to go to this menu item component
and here here we are going to take a uh
state so here we'll uh take something
like uh
display uh display current
children set
display
current
children and here we are going to take
this one as U state of empty
object now here uh what you need to do
basically so the first thing is that you
have to basically show a plus or minus
icon so now what I'll do I'll take a d
here now I'll paste it now here I'm
going to check if this item and and item
do uh
children sorry dot
children and an item do children. length
this is true so we'll take a span and
we'll show a plus icon for now or else
this will be
null now let's format this let's save it
now let's see so you can see that we are
getting plus here here here here and
here because these all are having the
children for now let me just give Here
style as later we'll change this we'll
do display as flex and we'll do a gap
of
20px okay now what we need to do we to
basically take a on click so we take a
on click and do handle toggle
children all right now here what we
going to pass we'll pass the
current label now obviously most of the
times you will have a ID also for each
and every but currently we don't have
any ID that is fine but most of the
times you'll have ID if you are having a
ID or something like that any unique key
you can also pass it but at the end the
concept is actually same so for now we
are going to pass the uh item do
label now let's quickly create this so
this function
handle
toggle
children it will get current
level now here what we need to do we'll
simply take set display current children
so here we will basically take the
existing one and then we'll basically
set this get current level which will be
not equal to display current children so
this is the one that we are already
having so that means we are basically
checking if the current level is already
existing here so you're toggling if this
is true it will be false if this is
false this will be true of this gate
current
level that's it so now let me just show
you what is happening here and I'll go
to log and then you'll do display
current
children so now let's go to
console so first time you can see we are
having nothing if I now try to click
here we are getting profile true if I
click here again we are getting profile
false so that means this is working fine
so now based on this you will be able to
see if we are clicking on this one then
only I want to expand the children of
this particular menu all right so now
what we can do we can simply go here and
we can give the condition that if the it
uh sorry the if the current item
children length is greater than zero and
if the current display current children
of the current item. label if this is
true so that means we are checking if
this profile is true then only we want
to
expand so then only it will show the
children if I now save this now you can
see we are not getting anything if I now
click here we are getting details if I
now click here we are getting here but
this icon is not changing so this also
we can simply do we can go here and then
we can check that if this display
current children of this item do label
this is true so that means what we need
to do we will basically show a minus or
else will show a
plus now let's see so let me just close
this so now I'll click here this is
minus I'll click here I'll click
here and you can see that this is
working fine if I know X sorry minimize
this one this is working fine if I here
that this is also changing and the uh
children is also now not s so this is
now working fine so this is all about
the functionality that you need to do
now after this only we will be moving
towards to uh styling we'll do very
little bit of styling here all right so
the first thing what we can do I think
uh let me just check whether we are
having this react icons okay so the
first thing is that we'll import some
two icons so we do import something from
we'll do react icons slfa
so one will be fa
minus and one will be fa
plus okay so here we'll basically change
this one to fa minus sorry this will be
fa
plus all
right sorry this will be F A
Plus and uh let's give a color of
white and also give a size of
25 and let me just copy
this and we'll paste it here so this
will be AFA
minus let's
see okay I think we are having colored
white so we need to basically change
this uh main styling actually for this
container so let me just copy this I
think we are already having the
Styles so we'll paste it so let give a
mean height of 100 VH we'll give a width
of
350px and we'll give a background
of RGB we'll give 0 comma 71 comma
1110 let me
just uh import this one so you
import want to do styles do
CSS let's save this all right
okay this is expanding so this part we
need to check what is happening
here so for this one let's go to our
main menu list
component and let's go to menu item so
we having Ali here so we'll give a class
name we'll give this one as menu
item and let's go to our style. CSS so
here what we can do we'll give this on
SD display
Flex we'll give align items as
Center we'll give gap of 20 PX and we'll
do cursor as
pointer now next uh we'll go to our menu
list uh so for this one what we can do
sorry I think we have given in the wrong
place that is the reason so let me just
copy this instead of manualist I to we
have to give this one in the main sorry
we have to give it here not
there so here what we can do we can give
this one as uh this is fine we'll give
this one as I think this was correct
review container so let me just copy
this and we'll change this one here
instead of menu list this will be
preview container and then we'll be
having menu list container which is for
the UI sorry UL so for this one we'll do
Leist style as none and we'll do a
margin top as 0 PX and we'll do margin
bottom as also 0 PX now let's see what
is
happening okay so here something is
[Music]
wrong let me just
check so I think we are having this is
fine okay we don't need display Flex
here
I got it so the reason is I think we
have given in the wrong
place you can copy this and we have to
give it
here and we can remove it from
here all right so now let's save it now
let's see what is happening okay now
this is working
fine awesome also let's make the color
as uh White we having menu so we'll do
color as
white okay so now let's see okay so this
is working fine awesome if I now so here
you can see that everything is working
fine uh let's add another one inside
this register so we go to our data and
then inside this register if I now add
another
children and we do label so here what we
can do we add some random data
and we'll do a two of something else
empty let's see what is happening so you
got the plus icon and we getting random
data here if I uh toggle this one this
is working and everything is working
fine so this is one of the very very
important questions that you might
encounter in your browser coding
interview now as I already mentioned
that they will give you the question in
many different ways but that the end the
concept will be exactly similar so
that's all for this this particular
project let's move on to the next one
all right so this is the first project
you can say we'll be using a third party
Library package the reason is that
sometimes uh you might get asked that
whether they will check that whether you
will be able to integrate a third party
Library package or not so that is the
reason I've chosen this project also so
here it will be pretty simple you to
give any value let's say I'm giving my
name and then based on that it will
generate the QR code and the same you
will be basically able to scan it so
this is a very simple project that we
are going to Implement so let's see how
we are going to do that using a third
party Library package all right everyone
so let's get started with our QR code
generator now as I already told you in
the introductory uh section that this
will be a very very small project now
sometimes interviewer will basically
test that whether you will be able to
work with any third party Library
package or not so that is the reason I'm
actually including this very small
project so let's see so for this one
what we going to do will be using this
particular package that called react QR
code let me just quickly uh install this
one so we'll do npm install and this
will be react QR code all right so you
will be having one very simple input and
there will be a button so whenever
you'll be typing some input you have to
store the value and on click of this
particular button you have to basically
generate some random QR
code all right so this is done so let me
just quickly create a component so here
I'll do QR code
generator
so I'll do index. jsx and
styles.
CSS so let me just quickly create the
component so this will be export default
function and this will be QR
code
generator all
right now
here we we are going to Simply return
some
div now here we'll take a H1 and this
will be our qword
code
generator awesome so now after this we
will take another div and here we will
take a input
simple and there will be a button so
this will be generate something like
that so here we'll be giving a type
which will be text name will be now
another thing is that uh you should
always ask the interviewer that whether
this all this input that you are giving
here this name type whether this you
will be receiving from the parent
component or not if the interviewer says
yes then in that case you have to take
all of this in your props now I'm not
doing this one for this particular
project because I'm pretty sure that you
already have that idea so that is the
reason I'm repeting uh this one again
and again that you have to basically
Drive the interview you have to ask
interview a lot of questions so that
they will understand that okay whatever
you are doing you actually not blindly
doing anything okay so that is very
important for now we'll give this one as
let's say QR
code all right and let's give a
placeholder and
enter
your value here that's it and inside
this what we are going to do take a div
and here we are going to render our QR
code which we need to import from our
react QR code now this will basically
take a ID so here we'll give our uh
QR
code uh value anything and also it will
take a value property so for this value
property we are going to basically take
a state which will be our
QR code set QR code
and this will be of use state
of
empty now what we can do uh now because
we need to create this on on click of
this particular button so we will take
another state which will be our input
and this will be our set input now again
I'm repeating if he's telling that or
your interval that you need to basically
get these values from your parent
component so you have to again take this
one from Pro but there is another way
that I'm going to explain so here I'm
going to take this one as UST state of
empty so that is fine now what we are
going to do uh we will basically take a
on
change so this will give you event and
here I'm going to set this on event.
target.
value that's it and we are going to take
a on click for this button which will be
handle
generate QR code
so here let's quickly create this method
so this will be handle generate QR
code and here simply this is very very
simple what you can do you can simply do
set QR code which will be your input
value now here another thing very very
important that always handle some kind
of error let's say if the input is empty
somehow so you will be basically
disabling this button or you'll show
some kind of message that your input is
empty so here we can basically take a
dig
and we'll check that if the input and
and input do trim if this is not equal
to equal to
empty so if this is not equal to equal
to empty so this will be false or else
this will be
true that's it now here you have to pass
the value and so value will be your QR
code and it will also take a size I'm
going to take this one as 400 and also
let's give a background color of
white that's it and I think that's it uh
that's all you need so now let's go to
our
app.js now I'm going to comment out this
one and I'll create so this will be our
keyword code generator so I'm going to
import our QR code generator and then
let's save it and let's see what is
happening awesome so you can see that we
are some getting some value and I'll
type something here suum and let's click
generate you can see this is basically
getting uh generated so this is also
getting disabl now once you will
generate something let's reset this
value also so that we can very easily do
so here we can make this set input as
empty again let's save this so now we'll
give some random value random value
generate this is getting changed but
this is not getting reseted so the
reason is pretty simple simp because we
haven't given the value here so here we
have to give the value which will be our
input all right so I'll give again I'll
generate now this is getting reseted and
you getting a new all right I think
that's it so as I already told you this
will be a very small project but this
will actually give you some idea how you
can create some kind of QR code so
that's all for this particular project
let's move on to the next one all right
so the next one I'm pretty sure that you
already know this one uh so this is a
light to Dark theme switch and the vice
versa so this is the first uh project
where we will be creating a custom hook
and that is called use local storage so
we'll be storing the current uh data in
our current choosen theme in the local
storage and on click of this button
we'll be able to change the text color
the button color background color if I
now refresh this you can see that now
only light will be light mode will be
selected the reason is if I go to this
application you can see that we will be
basically saving the current theme using
a custom hook if I change this one this
will be basically getting changed all
right so this is another very very
important project uh interview question
that you might get asked and for this
one also we'll be not using any third
party Li package we'll be creating each
and everything from simple scratch using
simple CSS and react jsx so let's see
how we are going to implement this one
all right everyone so let's start
working on another very very important
uh project that we just now discuss and
that is how you can switch from light to
dark mode and vice vers so so for this
one what we'll do let's create another
component so we'll do like uh light dark
mode or switch whatever you can do so
here first let's quickly create the our
structure now here we'll create our
component so this will be export
default function light dark
mode here I'm going to return
some
div and
here uh let's do one thing for now we'll
simply return the jsx then we'll explain
the uh functionality how we are going to
implement that and at the end we'll be
doing the
CSS and here I'm going to do a div and
let's give a class name of
container here I'll give a class name of
Light Dark
mode we'll take a simple paragraph and
we'll render here hello
world all right now here we will be
having a button which will basically
switch from uh or basically change the
theme so for this one we'll keep this
one change theme this is fine so this is
all about the GSX structure that we need
but first let's imple uh let's discuss
that how we are going to do
that so the first thing is that what
we'll be doing we will be creating a
custom hook that will be basically a
kind of storage which will store our
current uh theme in local storage so
that whenever we refresh the page we
will be getting our latest uh uh stored
uh theme from our local storage and
based on that we'll be doing the
functionality but because you'll see
that whenever you'll go for an interview
most of the times in this case your
interviewer will say that you can't use
any kind of third party package because
if you are using any like let's say
style components or material UI or
something else it will be very very easy
for you to implement so because they
will give you inbu hook that you will be
able to uh easily use and then you have
to just pass the property and based on
that you have to change the style
because here what you will explain your
in your interviews that we will be
creating a custom hook of our own and
there we want to store our Uh current
theme and based on that we want to
change that first we will be basically
explaining how we will be able to create
a custom hook so for this one inside
this you will be creating a uh file and
I'll give this name as use local
storage.
jsx now custom Hook is basically again
I'm pretty sure that you already have
some idea so it's like a reusable hook
that you can use throughout your
application all right in the later
section of this particular project we
will be creating some more like use fet
use responsive use preview yes but for
now let's start with this one so now
here we'll do export default function so
first you have to give the name so we'll
give this one as same use local storage
now what this will receive this hook you
will be calling from anywhere in your
component right so hooks are always
actually called on the top level on the
component so it will receive something
so it will receive the key that what
what is the name of the key that you
want to store in your theme so it will
receive a key and and also it will
receive the default value that you want
to save for this particular key so let's
say you having this key that is light
theme and the value will be true
something like that or the value will be
false so this is the key value pair now
here what we'll
do we'll take our state which will be
our value and then we'll set our value
now here we'll do US state and this will
take a method now this is pretty simple
what you can do you can take a current
value and here you can do a try catch
block now obviously if there are any
catch any error so you can log the error
first all right you can also set the
error so that I will also show you and
then what you can do you can set the
current value that you are having so
this value is with the default value
because this default value you will be
always passing from from your component
correct so this you can set which will
be your default value or else if there
are no error so your current value will
be your json. pars now what will be the
current value pause the video and try to
find so what you need to do if any value
is already stored so you are going to
get it from your local storage so this
will be your key that you'll be getting
or else you have to basically take this
one from string of this default value
sorry this will be this will be default
value so this your setting and at the
end because this is a function so here
you are going to return the current
value what I'm doing you have to return
the current value that's
it all right so this will do all the
functionality saving and everything and
at the end I'm sorry not saving you have
to basically extracting and now how you
are going to save this one so this is
also pretty simple so first you have to
take a use
effect and here it is very very
important to keep this key and this
value as a dependency because based on
this key and value only you want to do
this one sorry this value I'm talking
about this value here and this is the
key that you are passing from your
parent component now here you can simply
do local storage. set item which will be
your key and the value will be see
because you're already setting the value
here right here so this will be your
YouTu do stringify so it will be JSM do
stringify of value so this will set your
uh value in your local storage or
basically your theme and at the end you
are going to return return the value and
the set value which is your set State
method here so this is all about your
hook that is need now this hook you need
to basically store sorry you have to
call from your component or any
component that you want so here what you
are going to do you will be getting the
theme now this is very important so I'll
show you why so here you can take any
name you want because here you are going
to call this use local storage and if
you noticed here this is receiving a key
and the default value so here I'm
keeping the key as theme so now this
theme this key can be anything also and
here I'm keeping this one as a
dark so that means by default my theme
will be dark and the this method you are
basically getting from here so this is
the value and set value are getting
right so this is same as this one all
right now let's say what you need to do
you have to basically change the theme
so you'll take on click so we'll take a
on click here and this will be handle
toggle
theme so here we'll do function handle
toggle theme and here we are going to
Simply do set theme so here you have
having this theme right so here you'll
check if the theme so this theme that
you are having if this is light
theme if this is light so you're going
to make this on vice versa or else this
will be light so if this is light we
going to make this on dark and or else
this will be light now how I am actually
explaining each and everything in
interview interview also please please
explain each and everything that you are
doing you will get extra points for sure
and you'll thank me later in this
comment section I'm telling you so these
thing please always explain in your
interview that how you are doing and why
you are doing this now let's see what is
happening here let me just log this
theme
here let's save it and let's go to our
app.js I'm going to comment out this one
and what you're having dark light and
dark mode so I'll give another command
so this will be light and dark theme
switch so here we are having light and
dark mode let's save
it now let's go to our console so you're
having dark I think we are getting some
error here all right no nothing is
happening this is fine change this one
light click here dark light let's go to
our
application theme is light now click
here this is getting changed to dark
light dark so this is working fine now
this is also a custom hook that you have
created so obviously get extra bonus
marks for sure in your interview all
right so this is now working fine so now
this is pretty simple so now you have to
work on the CSS but so how we will be
basically implementing the CSS see for
this one what we going to do we'll take
a data property here and here I'll do a
data theme which will be this theme that
we are having here so that means based
on this theme we want to change the
style for this particular
component so how we are going going to
do that so now it's everything in the
CSS so now let's quickly create our uh
theme do CSS so here we'll take our root
oh sorry we'll take
root and here I'm going to take some
variables so first I'll take background
which will be white then I'll take a
text
primary so for this one this will be be
black then we'll take a button color so
this will be button BG so which will be
button button background now you can
take any name you want that doesn't
matter at the end we should basically
understand that if we are able to
understand the concept or not all
right and then we are having the button
text so we'll take this one as
white so this is about our root colors
that we need now how you are going to uh
set for Dark theme now noticed here we
are taking this data theme here so based
on this you'll be able to do so here you
can do basically simply take a data
sorry data theme this will be data theme
and this if this is equal to equal to
dark so that means you want to do
something so based on that I want to
change the color if the theme is dark or
else this will take from the root so
here I'll copy all of
this and for this one I'm going to make
this one as opposite means if this is
white for black it will be dark this
will be
white this is also will be white and
this is will be
black that's it now let's save it so
this is now will basically change now if
you notice we not using any third party
Library package so now we're going to
import our theme do CSS this is fine and
now let's copy out this class
name so here uh we'll start with this
one
sorry so we're going to take a
background color and for this one we
going to use a uh background this one
we'll take a height of 100 VH we'll take
display as
Flex uh we'll do a flex direction as
column we'll do justify content as
Center we'll do font size as
20px and we'll do a transition we'll do
all uh. 5
Seconds let's save it let's see what is
happening now go back now change theme
see is working I now refresh
this see this is now black because
currently it is STO show in the black so
it's working fine even though we refresh
the page right now if I now change this
one now you see this will be light only
and it's working fine awesome now next
what we'll do we are having this
paragraph I think so we'll have
paragraph uh let's make this on chaining
or else this will apply in other
components
also so inside this paragraph what we
going to do we'll do a color so for this
one we'll do text
primary and we'll do a font size of 40
PX awesome then we are having buttons
we'll do dot Light Dark theme of button
so we'll do a background color so for
this one we'll do we button
BG and we'll do a
border uh for this one we'll do one PX
solid where I'll do button background
color we'll do a color of where button
text
that's it we'll do a margin of 6 15 PX
let's do 0 PX we'll do a padding of 12
PX we'll do a border radius of 8 PX
we'll do font weight of 600 and we'll do
cursor as
pointer this is fine and I think we are
having another one which is our
container so let's copy
this and let's give here container
also so we'll do do light dark mode of
container so for this one also we'll
make display Flex we'll do justify
content as Center we'll do align item as
Center and we'll do a flex direction of
column that's fine and let's take a gap
of 30px and I think in that case we
don't need this margin here now let's
save all of this let's see what is
happening awesome so now uh for this
paragraph also we do margin of0
PX okay now let's see if I now click
here it's changing don't worry about
it's not middle that is fine at the end
we should see whether the function it is
working or not so this is changing from
black to white this button background is
also changing and the color if you
noticed if I click here background is
now black this is now white this is now
White and the color is black and this is
also changing so this is how you will be
able to implement your light and dark
mode without using any third party libr
package so what we have done we created
a simple uh reusable custom hook which
will take the key and the default value
now here basically we are extracting the
value current value and in the use
effect we are setting in our local
storage and then from the component we
are basically calling this
we are setting our Uh current theme as
dark and on button click we are changing
or basically toggling from light to dark
and dark to light the catch is a Pally
we basically we are doing this one based
on this data attribute here the same we
are utilizing in this CSS file yeah I
think that's all for this particular
project and let's move on to the next
one all right so this will be our next
project this is called custom scroll
indicator so here what we are trying to
do we will be fetching the list of data
and there will be scroll indicator if
you visit some of the website you might
notice that whenever you scroll it will
basically show you the progress so if
you see that if I scroll here and just
change the scroll view this will be
basically the progress bar will be
changed and then if I go to the at the
end of the page so it will basically
show 100% so this is what exactly we are
going to build in this project you'll
learn that how the scroll functionality
and what are the properties that window
properties that you need to use to to
create this progress work so let's start
working on this particular project all
right so let's get started with our
scroll indicator so for this one as we
already discussed that we will be
basically fishing the list of products
and based on that we'll be showing how
much we have scrolled into our page so
we are going to use this URL here so
let's go here and let's create another
component and this will be our scroll
indicator so we'll create our index.
jsx and we'll create create our
scroll.
CSS so let's quickly create the
component so this will be export default
scroll
indicator sorry this will be
function all right now here uh let's
simply return our
div and so basically now your work will
be first you have to uh ask your
interviewer that the URL that we are
calling the API will that be always same
or that you will be receiving from a
parent component or that URL can be
basically anything if that is the case
you will be receiving the receive the
URL from your parent component as a prop
so let's say we will be receiving from
the parent
component so the first thing is that uh
we are going to take our state so this
will be our data State and set data
which will be use state of empty aray
all right now later we going to do the
scroll thing but for now let's first
Implement our uh data fishing also we'll
do a loading State see always implement
the loading State because this is always
a good practice to implement and this
will be US state of
false and
now uh we will be taking our use effect
and then we'll keep this URL as a
dependency because that is the we are
depending on the parent component and
here we'll create a phage data
function which will take this URL as a
parameter that's it now here let's
create the function so we do as sync
function Fage
data which will take our gate URL and
here we are going to implement our try
and catch
block all right so here for now we'll
simply log the
error also so you can take another state
which will be our error
message set error
message which will be used state of
empty so here you'll basically render
this as this error Dot
message now here the first thing what
you need to do the first thing is that
you to make the set loading as true
because you are calling the API and then
you have to do const response this will
be AIT
F and here you have to do
URL so this URL you are getting sorry
this will be get
URL and
here we'll do const data which will be
AIT response. Json and now we are going
to first log the
data so let's format this let's save it
so now go to our app.js let me just
comment out this part again and here
we'll create another component and this
is our scroll indicator
component so here we are going to
implement uh sorry import scroll
indicator which will take URL so this
URL will be this one here so let me just
copy
this and here uh we are going to pass a
limit so we'll pass a limit of of 100 so
we want to fetch 100 data at once let's
save it so now we already logged in this
data let's see what we are getting
here we are getting object and you can
see we're getting the products we're
having 100 products this is
fine so now we will simply check if data
and
and data do
products and and data do products.
length this is greater than zero so
we'll do set data which will be data do
products and we are going to make the
set loading as false
again all right so now let me just cut
it from here and we'll log this uh data
and this
loading let's
see okay let me just refresh this so
you're getting false true and then again
we are getting the data done so now what
we can do
simply uh let me take here H1 tag and
we'll Implement custom
scroll we'll do custom
scroll
indicator all right and then uh inside
this uh what we can do we'll take a
simple
div and we'll take a class name which
will be our data
container and inside this simply you
will just render the data for now we
keep this one very simple this will be
data. length if this is greater than
zero or else this will be null and here
we are going to render uh the data so
this will be data. map data
item and let's take a paragraph and we
are going to render the data item. title
that we are
having let's save
it now let's see what we getting awesome
so we are getting 100 data here okay so
now here we have to basically show that
uh the scroll that how much we have
scrolled and if I go to the bottom of
the page so that means we have we have
completed the 100% so for this one the
first thing is that what you need to do
you to manage a state so we'll take
another state and what we can do we can
check that uh SC
percentage something like that set
scroll
percentage which will be US state of
zero for the first time and now here
what we need to do we'll take another
use
effect all
right and
then we will have to take event listener
so we'll do window do add event listener
ER and this will be on scroll and we'll
do handle handle uh what we can do we
can handle scroll
percentage all right and we'll just
simply do R so on on unmount we are
going to remove this one so we'll do
window. remove even listener scroll and
we'll make this one
as like this that's it now let's quickly
create this one so we'll do function
handle scroll
percentage so this is our method now
here what we need to check we have to
check the following things now I'll show
you that there are three things we have
to calculate the first one is that how
much we have scrolled and what is the
full height all right and then how we'll
be able to basically uh get that so you
have to take the SC height and the
client height we have to substract and
then based on that you have to calculate
the percentage that how much you have uh
scrolled so for this one I'll just log
some of the things so first we'll do
document. body do
scrolltop this one or we'll also do
document. document element do
scrolltop we will also log here
document dot document element do scroll
height
and also we do document do document
element. client
height so these all the things that we
need let me just save it now let's go to
our console and I'll just do scroll so
you can see that we are getting all of
this so one we are getting the full
height you can see this is our scroll
height and this is our client height all
right and this 130 is basically how much
we have do we have done till top so so
this is a scroll
top okay if I know if you see if I now
scroll down so this will obviously
increase right and see this increase
this is increasing so now we will be
able to basically create the uh get the
percentage very easily so we'll create
our percentage like that so we'll do
const uh how
much uh I'm keeping this one very funny
not funny like I'm uh writing this
variable name little bit long so that it
will be easier to understand so this
will be how much sced so this will be
document.body do scroll toop or else if
this is not so this will be document do
document element do scroll
toop all right and then we'll be
calculating our height so this one is
pretty simple we need to get the
document
dot document element dot we are having
this scroll height and we'll basically
substract with our client height so this
will be document dot sorry document
element dot client
height that's
it and now we can simply create our
percentage so this will be set scroll
percentage so here this will be how much
you scrolled divided by your height
right into 100 so we just do like this
into
100 let's save it so now let log here uh
scroll
percent let's save this
one so I'll just refresh
here and let's scroll down so you can
see this is getting
changed if I go
below and now this is almost 100 so you
can see that this is almost 100 so this
is now working fine if I know scroll top
little
bit so you can see this is now
decreasing right so this is working fine
now based on that we have to create our
CSS so now let's give some name of the
classes so what we can do uh let me just
create another one so we'll create
another div here and and I'll give this
one as class name so we'll give this one
as
call
progress
tracking container something like that
and inside this we'll take another
div and here I'll take class name this
will be our current progress
bar all
right and here we'll take a style and
we'll mark the width of of this one as
this uh scroll percent sorry we take
template
literals and here we'll do our scroll
percentage of percent so this is the
current width each and every time we
will be scrolling so this width will be
either increasing or decreasing I hope
you're getting all right and here we'll
take another one so we'll do here class
name this will be our top
[Music]
container and let's move all of
this inside
this let's format this let's save it now
let's start working on the CSS so first
one we be our top container so we'll
copy
this and here we are going to make this
one position as
fixed we'll do top as zero we'll do J
index as one we'll do width as
100% we are going to do text align as
Center we'll do background color as
black sorry let's use hex code
only all right and and I think for now
this is fine
sorry okay now next we are having our
progress bar so this one scroll progress
tracking
container so for this one we'll do a
width of 100% we'll do a height of 10 PX
and we'll do a background of Let me just
take some random color then we'll change
this one or let's use this
color anything we can use for now we
keep it like this let's see how this is
looking based on that I will change and
after that I think we are having our
current progress bar so copy
this and for this one we'll do a height
of 10 PX
we'll do a background of this one has 8
b0 2
B5 then we are having width of
0% yeah I think that's it now let's save
it let's see how this is looking so let
me just go here and let me import
our scroll.
CSS if here loading we'll show some kind
of message here that at if loading true
so we going to return some div uh
loading data please
wait and if there are any
error so we're going to return that
error
occurred error and we'll just render the
message let's save it let's see what is
happening okay this is I think we have
kept this one as black only okay let's
use some different color what we can
use uh we'll keep like this this
one let's copy this we'll go to top
container and then we'll make the color
as
white
now let's see
awesome okay now let's refresh
this awesome so you can see that now
this is working
fine so we are scrolling and this is
also giving you the progress right and
this is working
fine now another thing if you want what
you can do basically let's go to
this
here so here we are having this data
container we can copy
this and then we can give a margin
top uh margin top of 100 PX because we
are having that uh because the position
is fixed you have to give the margin top
to get the full
data all right let's save
it so now you can see it's working fine
right yeah I think that's all for this
particular project now this is another
important concept that you have learned
how you can s see another thing we are
not using any third partyy Library
package so obviously these all are the
very very important uh uh questions that
you can practice for your front end
interview so that's all for this
particular project let's move on to the
next one all right so here we are again
another very important very frequently
Asked interview questions and that is to
create custom tabs with Dynamic content
without using any third party Library
package so this is exactly what we are
going to build so here we are having so
this data is dynamic so what about how
much data we want to pass or how many
tabs we want to create based on that it
will automatically create the tabs and
that this content can be dynamic so you
can see that this content whatever we
will pass and based on that we'll be
creating this uh simple tabs component
without using any third party Library
package so let's start working on this
particular project all right everyone so
let's get started working on the custom
tabs component so now uh now here also
another very important thing is that
most of the times in interviews whatever
your interviewer will tell that let's
say you will get some components from a
parent component basically so list of
child components and those components
you have to pass to your custom tab
components and on click of each and
every tab you have to render that
content based on that particular tab so
for this one for this particular
component we will be basically having
three files so I'll create here like
custom
tabs so one will be my tabs so we'll
give this one as
tabs.
GSX then we'll be having the Styles
we'll give tabs.
CSS and then we are having tab test so
that means uh this will be our custom
component or basically the sorry this
will be a parent component so this is
just for example in this component we
are going to uh use this tabs component
all right so now uh let me just do one
thing let me close everything else all
right so here we'll create the component
so this will be export default function
and I'll give this on name as tabs for
now now here what uh it will receive it
will basically receive the tabs content
that we are going to pass from the
pattern component so we give this name
as tabs content you can give whatever
you want also it it will going to
receive another on change property and
I'll discuss
why all right now let's return our
j6 so here uh let's give a class name
and uh styling we are going to do later
for now I'll give a class name of
wrapper for this one inside this uh we
will take another
div and here we are going to give a
class name and let's give this one name
as
heading all right now here what we are
going to do basically we will map this
tabs content and based on that we are
going to render the label that we are
going to receive now obviously this
depends on that in which uh way or
basically the how you are getting the
data and based on that this key or the
value pair will automatically change so
this will be our heading section and
then after that we will be basically
having our tab content section so I'll
take another div now and here we are
going to take this one as content all
right now here I'm going to check if
this tab
content uh or directly we can do do map
so here we'll give tab
item and here what we are going to
return let's return a div
here the first thing is that we are
going to give a key which will be our
tab item do
label now inside this we will take a
span and let's give a class name of
label and I'm going to render this tab
item do label here that's
it now next inside this content again
here what we need to basically check
if we are clicking on that current tab
based on that we have to get the current
tab index so for this one we need a
state that we need to manage so we'll
take a state here and let's give this
one name as current tab uh
index Set current tab index and here I'm
going to take this one as a u state of
zero all right now here what we are
going to do see we are having this tabs
content that we are going to receive
from the pent components we'll do tabs
content of this current tab index if
this is true then only we will basically
take tabs content of current tab index
do content that we are going to pass now
for now this is fine let's quickly
create the pent component so that it
will be easy to understand now let's say
this is your pent component and from
here you want to call these tabs all
right so now here what we are going to
do will be creating out uh this
component so here we are going to import
this tabs component so let's quickly
create so this will be export default
function let's give this on name as tab
test and here I'm going to return and
we'll keep this one very simple so what
we can do return here tabs so this is
our component and here we need to pass
the tabs content so now let's say we are
having the components like this so we'll
create a array here so this will be our
tabs and here if you now go to a tabs
component so here you can see we are
getting Level and the content so these
two things you need to pass so here I'll
pass level and let's give you some name
as tab one and I'll pass a Content which
will be I'll take div and this will be
this is content for tab one now let's
copy this and we'll paste it two more
times so this will be tab
two and this will be tab two now let's
say you are having a separate component
so this is just to show you so you're
having function some random
component and this is returning a div or
let's say H1 and some
random
content okay now here what we are going
to do we take a label here also and this
will be tab three and here I'm going to
pass a content
which will be instead of this now I'm
going to pass this random component here
so we can simply pass this random
component also this will work so now
this is our tabs or basically the arrrow
of tabs and this we need to pass it here
that's it and now if you go here we are
also passing this on change so that
means the current tab that we are
currently clicking we need to get the
tab index and based on that let's say
you want to do certain operation for
example you want to save the data in the
database or whatever you want to call
Api so now for this one here I'll pass
on change which will be my handle
change so now let's quickly create this
component so this will be function
handle change now here this will
basically receive our current tab index
current tab index so basically what we
are doing we are doing a parent to child
and child to parent relationship and
let's say I want to log this current tab
index that's it now let's save it now we
need to go here and now here what we are
going to do we need to basically create
this functionality that whenever we will
be clicking on this particular header I
need to set that onto the current index
because you can see we are checking that
if the current index is true then only
want to show the content here so here we
can take on
click and here I'll create a handle on
click and I want to pass the index let's
say we are having this index so this
index we want to pass it here so now I'm
going to create a function handle on
click so this will get the get current
index now simply set this current tab
index to get current index now we can
call this parent function here and we
can simply pass this get current index
also this will be done now let's format
this let's save it now this component I
want to use in my app .js so now I'll
just commit it out and let's give
another comment so this is our custom
tabs
component and here I'm going to import
tab
test that's it let's save it now let's
see what is happening all right let's
see what is happening here I think this
is some styling
issue okay so you can see that we are
having here let me just give some
styling for now so we go here let's go
to our
tabs content for now we'll give a style
and we'll give a color of
red now let's
see all right now if I change this one
tab two and if I click here we are
getting some random content click here
so this is working fine all right now
let's start working on the styling so
this is all about the functionality that
we
need so now let's go to our tab. CSS so
the first thing is that we are having
our wrapper components we'll take dot
wrapper and let's give a padding of how
much
8px next I think we are having heading
so we'll take heading we'll give display
Flex we'll give justify content Center
and we'll give a margin bottom of 2
lpx uh next I think we are having
label or let's do one thing let's also
give some uh class name to this also so
this div so let's give a class name here
and for this one we are going to give a
dynamic class name so here what we can
do we can give a class name of tab item
and then we can basically check that if
this current tab index if this is equal
to equal to index that means this is
currently selected so we give a active
class name here that means this tab is
active or this will be empty
all right so now let's copy this tab
item so for this one we'll give this one
as display as inline
Flex we'll give font size of uh let's
give how much
30px uh we'll give font weight as
bold sorry this will be bold we'll give
a text align as
Center uh we'll also give a adding of 10
PX 15
PX what else we give a cursor as pointer
and we'll do border as
none Also let's give a color color will
give white and let's give a background
so background will give this one 4 e 01
a that's it now if this is active so
we'll give tab item do active
so we will basically change the styling
so we'll do a border
color color of
black and we'll give a background color
or
background so we make this one A1
D60 and we'll do a color
of
white that's it now next we are having
label so we'll take this for label I
think uh what we can do I think for
level it is fin not required let's give
some styling in the content so we'll
take
content and here we give a padding of 20
PX 10 PX we'll give a height of 300 PX
we'll give overflow as
Auto and also let's give a background
color of white
and I think for now this is fine let's
save it now in this tab test component
only I think we can
import
tab.
CSS now let's save
it let's see what is happening all right
we are getting something but this is
fine let's see what is happening here so
you're getting tab one this is content
for tab one this is tab two and this is
tab three where we are getting some
random content so this is working fine
see at the end our Prime objective is to
complete this small small uh project so
that whenever it gives any kind of
interview because whenever you're
learning at the end your objective will
be to get good com good job in a good
company especially product based company
now whenever you give some interview
they will always ask you very simple
questions but the questions will be in
such a way that they will basically
judge that how you are approaching that
problem what is is the approach and how
you are explaining that uh whether you
know that what basically you are doing
so that is the reason you should always
explain these all of the things that you
are doing in your interview and that
will definitely going to help you a lot
so I think that's all for this
particular project now let's move on to
the next one all right welcome to the
next one so next one will be another
very important uh interview question now
I'm tell telling all of this B C you
might say that okay he's telling each
and everything important see this is the
reason why I've have taken so much time
while selecting these questions because
most of the times you will get the
questions from this particular video
Whatever projects that we are doing so
here again we are using not using any
third party liy package we'll be
creating this um custom model component
where we will be basically able to
create this model where will this data
whatever data we're having here each and
data can be customized and based on that
we'll be creating this model for this
one also will not use any third party
liability package because whenever
you'll face this interviews uh these
questions in your interview especially
the model they will ask you not to use
any third party Library so let's see how
we are going to do this all right so
let's uh create our custom model
component so first I'm going to create
another folder here and let's give this
one name as custom model
popup and let's create our here also
we'll create our model.
jsx we create model do CSS and also we
create another one which will be model
test. GSX
let's close everything else now here
also how this will work so let's say
this is your parent component and you
are having a reusable model component so
you will be managing the state from this
component only so you'll be let's say
you are having a button here and on
click of this button only want to open
the model so that means we are going to
import the model in this component only
and that model we are going to use
throughout the application so this is
the main idea so now here now obviously
see the approach you can do this on many
many different ways is at the end our
objective is to understand the concept
uh very carefully and how you can
Implement those in real life projects or
basically in your interview whatever so
here I'll create
a uh component first so this will be our
function and this will
be model
test all right so now here let's quickly
create our model component also so this
will be export
default function this will be our
model and here I'm going to just return
here model for
now so now here in this component I'm
going to return a
div and inside this let's say we having
a
button and we having open model popup or
anything now to manage the state from
this component you have to take the
state here and you have to pass this one
in your model component so let's quickly
take a state so this will be so
model popup set so
model
popup which will be obviously used of
false all right now uh because you are
managing from here so you have to take
on click in this button so I'll take an
on click like handle
toggle
model
popup so so this will be
function handle toggle model popup now
what you need to do here you just need
to Simply toggle this so this will be
set so model popup it will be not equal
to so model popup that means if it is
false it will be true if it is true it
will be false vice versa so now what you
can do you can simply check now this is
pretty simple the only thing they will
check I'll tell you whenever they will
give you to create any kind of model
they want to test how you are good at
CSS because in this particular project
function it is very little at the end
they will tell you that how you are
going to implement the CSS and also
let's see if you want to pass some
custom content to the model how you're
going to do
that so here you will basically do if
this so model popup is true then only
you want to render the model component
that's it now here uh what we'll do for
now this is fine now let's save it so
let's go to app.js I'm going to comment
out this one and here we are having
custom
model
component so this will be our model
test let's save
it so I click here we are getting model
so this is working
fine so now let's go to our model
component
first so this is our model so here what
we are going to do so the first thing is
that it will receive some of the props
now why it will receive some of the
props the first thing it will receive
the ID of the model it will also receive
the class name it will receive a header
content body content and the model
footer content if you don't have any of
this then it will basically uh what it
will do it will basically render the by
default content so what you can do here
the first thing let's quickly give a ID
here so ID here will be ID or if it is
ID not present so this will be our model
and this ID it will going to receive
from this parent
component so this is first thing then it
will be class name will be let's give
this one as model inside this we'll take
another div we'll give a class name
we'll give model uh we'll give this one
as
content all right inside this will take
another div this will give class name as
header and after this we going to take
another class name sorry another div
this will be class name this will be our
body and after this we'll take another
div we'll take a class name this will be
our
footer all right now here it will
receive a header content it will also
receive the body it will also receive
the
footer so now how you're going to
basically do that and before that let's
take a span here so this will be class
name will give close
model
icon and here we are going to pass this
so we'll
do
times that's it it will basically create
a cross icon and here I'm going to take
a A3 let's uh H2 also is fine and here
I'm going to check if the header uh is
present so it will render header or else
this will be uh
header that's it
same here also so you're going to check
if body is true so it will get body or
else we are going to render some default
content here and inside this uh let's
take a p so this is
our model
body and same will be for
footer so if footer is present it will
do footer render footer component or
else this will be will take this one as
uh H2 so this is our
footer all right now let's save it now
let's see what is happening so if I now
click here all right nothing is
happening
here I think we are getting some
error okay I think the content is coming
and the point is I think there are some
issues happening with this tabs content
all right I got it so we'll give this
one as model content let's see now see
now this is coming okay so this is
working fine now let's see what will
happen if I try to pass some uh random
sorry some Custom Body so here we'll
pass body and we'll make this one as a
div component and this is will be our
customize
body now let's format it save
this if I click here we are getting
customized body so that means it's up to
you you will be able to manage whatever
you want to do from here right so this
is the advantage of creating a reusable
component so I think that's all for this
particular project in terms of
functionality now let's start working on
the CSS so now the first thing we are
having this model class name so we'll go
to our model CSS and this will be our
model so we make the PO as fixed we'll
do J index as
one uh we'll do a padding top
of uh 150 PX we'll do left of zero we'll
do top of
zero width will do 100% height we'll do
100% we'll do overflow as
Auto
and also we'll do a background
color which will be our uh we'll do
black color only so this is fine next I
think we are having the model
content so copy
this and here I'm going to pass the PO
as
relative we'll do background color as
Fe F
Fe then we having margin as
Auto we'll do padding of zero we'll do
border of 1 PX solid
red we'll do width as
80% and I think this is
fine now first let's see what is
happening if I save this let's go here
because in this component you have to
import so I'm going to
import model. CSS let's save
it all right so it's coming black this
is looking very bad let's do one thing
let's change this color to something
else uh let's see I'll go
here we'll do something
different let's
see okay I think this is fine at theend
now another thing what we need to do we
have to basically close this
here all right so this what we are going
to do so for this one let's take a on
close method here so we'll do function
on
close and here I'm going to do set so
model popup and this will be equal to
false all right and this I'm going to
pass it here so this will be our on
close all right so this it will receive
in this model jsx so it will receive on
close and now the advantage is is that
you can easily manage this using on
click so you on click and you'll pass
this on close that's it so now if I go
back if I now click this is closing and
it is working fine all
right now let's give some more uh
styling also so the first thing is that
what we can do we can give some styling
to
the uh this close icon so let's go to
model. jsx we having close model icons
we copy
this and we'll do here cursor pointer
first we'll
do all right color I think let me
see color this is
fine uh we'll do this one
as we'll do font size as 24
PX we'll do a float
right and we'll do font
weight as
bold
okay this is coming here let me do this
one
40 all right now next we are having I
think header so let me copy this so
we'll do dot header we'll do padding of
for PX 16 PX we'll do a background color
here we'll do this color 5 C B 85
C and we'll do color of
white awesome now next uh we are having
body so we'll do dot body we'll do a
padding of 2 PX 6 15
PX uh let me see what is the name body
is fine and after that we are having
footer so we do do footer we'll do
padding as 2 PX 16 PX let's make this on
16 PX only and after this we are going
to do a background
color should use the same color
here
sorry what I'm doing okay this is fine
and we'll do color as white
only okay and for body let me just check
what is happening in
here uh let me just give a height of 200
PX okay yeah I think this is
fine if I now close this open
this so this is working fine if you want
you can also give some uh animation Also
let's give some animation here so we'll
go to our model content and here we'll
do some animations we'll give Animation
name animate
model and also we give Animation
duration of uh 0 uh how much 5 Second
and this uh key frame you need to create
so we'll create a key frame so we do at
theate Key frames we have to give the
name so here we'll do from so it will
start from let's say we want to give a
bottom or whatever bottom let's say we
want to give minus 200
PX and that time we will give a opacity
of zero and then what you need to do to
give a two so this will be
bottom we give bottom
zero or let's do one thing let's make
this one as STP instead of bottom and
I'll do this one a stop and then for two
this oppacity will be
one all right so now let's see what is
happening if I now save this I click
here see
it is working fine and this is looking
nice so now if you want you can pass
customized header so let's pass some
customize header also so here let me
just format this so here you can pass a
header component which will be let's say
your
H1 so this our
customize
header and also if I now copy this and
pass it so this will be our footer so
this will be our customize
footer I now save it so you're getting
customized header customized body and
customized footer and this is working
fine also if you want you can pass some
id id custom
ID that's it so this is how you need to
create a model component now this is
also very frequently Asked interview
questions and you should always practice
this one so that's all for this
particular project let's move on to the
next one all right so this is another
project simple project that we are going
to build where we will be using the
GitHub uh public API to F and username
details so if I search something here
let's say Tom and search here so you can
see that we'll be showing the loading
State and based on that we'll be getting
the data here and I will be basically
able to visit this particular user
GitHub page and if I type my name
here so you can see that this data is
coming and then will be basically going
to my homepage so this is another very
simple one that we are going to create
so let's see how we are going to do this
one all right everyone so let's start
working on our GitHub profile finder so
for this one let's quickly create
another component inside this and I'll
give this one name as GitHub profile
finder so inside this I'll create our
index.
jsx and we'll create styles.
CSS and let me close everything else so
the first thing is that we are going to
create the component so this will be
export default function and we'll give
this one as G profile
finder so how the approach will be so
we'll be calling a simple API based on
that we'll be getting the uh that
profile data based on a input that we
will be basically typing and then
whatever data we'll be receiving based
on that we want to render the user based
on that particular API response so here
I'm going to return a div and inside
this I'll give this on a class name and
let's give this one name as GitHub uh
profile
container all right inside this we'll
take another div let's give a class name
so here I'll give this one as input
wrapper and here let's take a
input so I'll give this a name as uh
like what we can do we can give name as
a
GitHub or let's give this on name as
search by
username we also give a
type which will be
text we'll give a placeholder which will
be
search GitHub
username all right and after this we'll
be having a
button and here we are going to uh do
something like
search that's it so later we are uh we
will be implementing the CSS but for now
this is fine so here in this button
we'll be having on click method which
will be handle
submit so here we're going to create the
function this this will be handle
submit and now we need to basically take
some
state so one will be our user name state
so which will hold the username that we
are typing in the input and let's say by
default I want to keep this one as my
name so I'll give this one as s mukarji
so on page load it will be always this
value here all right and here I want to
pass this value as this
username that's it now here the next
thing what we are going to do we'll take
a onchange method which will give you
the
event and this will be set username
which will be event. target.
value that's
it all right till this part this is fine
so now what we going to do we will take
use
effect all right so now here what we can
do we can simply take a use effect so on
page load we are going to call uh API
and let's do this on something like
fet uh D have
user
data and now let's quickly create this
method so this will be assing
function Fage gav user
data and here we'll do const response
which will be AIT
Fage now here what we need to do we have
to give this URL which is https api.
github.com
slash users slash and here you have to
basically pass the username
that's
it so having const data which will be
have it race.
Json and we're going to log the data
here so now let's see what is happening
now first so we'll save it and let's go
to our
app.js and now
here we're going to give GitHub
profile finder
and this will be GitHub profile finder
let's save
it and now let's see what is happening
all right so you can see that we are
getting s mukarji here and if I go to
console we're getting object and inside
this we are getting all the data here
now whatever data we need based on that
you will be able to render the data as
simple as that so for this one what we
can
do uh let's do one thing let's take
another state here so this will look
const user
data and set user
data and this will do US state of null
and then we are going to check if the
data is true so we are going to do set
user data will be our
data and also let's take a loading state
so I'll take another one so const
loading set loading which will be use
state of of
false and before calling the we're going
to do this one as
true and here we are going to make this
one as
false all right now here we'll do if
loading is true so we'll simply return
H1 and we show like
loading
data
please
wait now let's save it let's see what is
happening phras
this so you're getting immediately that
is fine we can also make this one as
true also that is also fine now let's
see now let's refresh
this okay now this is fine now let's
create another component here and uh
what we can do we'll give this one
as uh what we can do we'll give this one
as card do
jsx and basically we are going to pass
the user data let's make this one as
user so this will be export default
function user so this will receive the
user
item and we are going to basically
return the jsx
here all right so first let's go here
let's see what we are getting and what
are the things that we need so the first
thing is that you can see that we are
having having this URL or uh this one
basically here this is the image that we
can
use uh what else we need we can also
check
like when this is created we can also
get the followers data here how many are
following all right uh what else we need
we can also check like how many repos
are there uh repo URL like whatever you
need basically you'll be able to Al able
to check that if this is a type of user
or not all right and this is the URL or
basically the website that you want to
visit so let's start with this one so
let's say I want to take this one here
so first let me return something
here so we going to destructure a our
URL then we need the
followers then we need how many are
following then we need the what else you
can check the public
repos and also you'll take the URL
here so this will be from our user let
me just format this all right all right
now let's quickly create the uh jsx here
now we'll give a class
name and let's give this one as
user and inside this we'll take a
div and we'll take a image
here we'll give the source which will be
our this this URL
here also give a class name
aor and we'll give alt which will be
your user uh user that will be fine we
don't need to specifically say like it's
a image that is fine all right now after
this we'll take another
div and I think we are also having the
name that we can take I
think so you can see that we are having
this name which is null for now that is
fine we can also take this login name
that is the name that we can check so if
the name is null so we render the login
one so we'll check the name
or the
login so here what we will do uh we will
basically take a paragraph and we'll
render the or or let's do one thing uh
we will take a anchor here and we are
going to render this if the name is
present or else this will render the
login and here we are going to give a h
rdf so this will basically go to this
URL here on click of this so this is the
URL you can can
see this one let me see what is
happening here it is giving this data
this we don't need what we going to do
we don't need this URL then so we'll
give a let's give a template literals
here and we'll give
https SL github.com
and then here we will be able to pass
this login data that we are having the
reason is because if I show show you
here this login is basically my username
that we are having here so this we can
basically use and I think this will be
fine all right let's see what is
happening till now so I'll go here and
here we'll basically check if the
user uh user data if this is not equal
to equal to
null or else will show null or else we
are going to render the
user and we'll pass the user which will
be my user
data all right let's save it and let's
see what is happening awesome so you're
getting the data here and also once we
call the data let's make this one as uh
false sorry let's make this username as
empty so we set username as
empty let's refresh
this awesome I'll search something like
let's give Tom also okay on click of
this also you need to give this so let
me just quickly call the same one so on
handle submit we can call the same F get
user data this will
work okay now I'll give S mukarji
search we getting we'll give Tom search
we getting something let's give some
random value let's see what is coming
we're getting some random data let's
give some
name awesome so it's working fine so now
we have to start working on the uh
styling so what else we can render here
we can render there uh when basically
this
user uh created the data or basically he
created this data so this is the created
data that we'll be able to get so let me
just copy this so go here I think we are
already have taken let me check we don't
have
taken okay so now here what we can do we
can create our date so this will our
created date which will be our new sorry
this will be equal to new
date of this created date and after this
what we'll
do uh let's take after this only we'll
take a
paragraph and we'll show something user
joined on and then here we'll take a
template
literals and we'll do create a date dog
datee so this is the date it will give
and after this we'll give a space and
here we will do this created date sorry
created date do to local
string and here we can pass
en
us all right and after this we'll give
the property will'll Pass a month we'll
make this one as
sort awesome and after this what we can
do we can simply take another template
literals here and here we are going to
pass this created date Dog full
year so let's format this let's save
it so user join on this is fine let me
refresh
this so you can see that user joined on
17 March 2019 so this is working fine
all right now next what we going to do
we'll keep this one very simple we'll
take another div all right and you'll
render here three more Dives so we'll
take
one we'll take two and
three and here we'll take a paragraph so
this will be the public
repos all right and we'll take another P
so this will be our the number of repos
so this will be public repos let's copy
this render here for followers and
following so this will be
followers and this will be
following
awesome let's save this let's see so we
getting the data
here let me refresh this let me search
like what you going do here
I'll give something like this let's
search it so we getting some data here
okay so this is now done so now let's
quickly create uh little bit of a
styling we don't need that much styling
the only uh objective is to learn the
functionality again I'm repeating the
same thing but let's give some basic
styling actually I think that will be
more than enough so what we can do
having the Styles let me first import
this one in this
component also let me remove this
console so here we can import
our
Styles uh sorry this will be styles.
CSS all right so the first thing we are
having
this uh what we are having the gab
profile container so we'll copy
this so here we'll do margin zero
Auto we'll give a width of
90% we'll give Max width of 1,00 PX
we'll give padding of 20 PX and we'll do
border radius of
8px that's it next I think we are having
this input wrapper so let me just copy
this so here we'll give display uh let
me just check what we are
[Music]
having okay so we getting some wrong
value here let me see what is
happening okay this is fine so this is
coming in the middle so now let's go
back here so you're having this input
rapper so what we can do first uh let me
just take this input rapper do
input and also we'll do input rapper
we'll make display as flex and we'll
just do a gap of 20px that will be
enough okay and here also do justify
content Center
all right and let's give a margin bottom
of
20px so input what we'll do we'll do a
padding of 12 PX we'll do font size of
PX we do uh border
none okay so this is fine next we are
having the buttons we do Dot input
wrapper of
button so what we can do we'll give here
padding as 5 PX
12px we'll do border as
none uh border radius we'll do 8 PX
only we'll give some background color
what we can give we can give like let me
just give some random color for now and
then we'll take it from here let's give
something like anything
yeah I think this is
fine let's give a color
of
black and also going to give a color of
sorry cursor as
pointer okay I think this is fine this
is more than enough for this now next uh
we are having this card so let's go to
our card let me just close this so did
not cut the user component so you're
having the user so copy
this so you're having do user will give
a padding of 15
PX we'll give a border radius of 10 PX
and yeah I think this is
fine okay now next uh what we can
do uh we are having this image so let me
just copy
this and here what we'll do we'll give a
height of 70 PX we'll give aspect ratio
of 1 by
1 and we'll do border radius as
50% awesome let's make it 150 let's see
how this is
looking okay and for this one we give a
border actually we'll give one PX
solid awesome so now uh next we are
having if I now go here we are having
this part which is our name container so
we'll give a class we'll give name
container and here let's copy
this so here we'll do name container
we'll do display as flex and we'll do
gap of
20px all right and here I think we are
having something let me just check here
what is
happening okay so what we can do we can
give a flex of one this is also
fine and I think this is cheing the
margin I think that is the reason
because we're having the P right so what
we going do we can give it do name
container of P we'll make the margin as
0 PX we'll do font size as 20 PX
font weight will do
bold this is
fine and name container will do justify
content
Center let's see what is
happening okay and also we'll give
a margin top of
20px okay if I now click here it should
go to this page only and see this is
working for
fine now let's do one thing we'll use
the same structure for this one uh so
we'll make the uh this two three also
make this one as display Flex so what we
can do uh we'll give a class name so
we'll give this one as uh
profile info something like that so here
we'll copy
this and then here we'll do div and
we'll do display as Flex this one also
and we'll do justify content as
Center okay and also give a gap of
20px and let's use the same style that
we are using here so copy all of
this paste it let's save it let's see
awesome yeah I think that will be more
than enough so let me just sear
something else we give something value
like
okay we are getting the name here let's
search for something
Richard you can see this is working fine
right so that's all for another
particular project now this is a kind of
a general project where uh what they
will do like they will give you some
kind of uh API URL they'll tell you that
simply pH the data create a usable
component just like we have created this
user component you can also give this on
name as a card doesn't matter and also
you have to do a little bit of styling
so that's all for this particular
project let's move on to the next one
all right so this is another very very
important questions and that this is
called search autocomplete now in
interview most of the times they will
give you some dummy data and from that
data only you have to filter and show
the auto complete but for now in this
project what we're going to do will be
fetching the list of users from API and
then based on that you can see that
you'll be getting the data here so if I
update this will be updated
all right so if I click here this is
selected if I again remove this will be
updated so this is another very simple
project that we are going to build so
let's see how we are going to implement
this one all right everyone so let's
start working on our search autocomplete
component so for this one I'm going to
use this dumy Json uh API so the first
thing is that what we are going to do
now again uh the question will be
something like this either uh they will
give you some dummy set of array of data
and then based on that you have to
basically search and show the options or
they will say that face the data store
the data in a state and then whenever
you will type something you have to
basically filter from that data so
you're going to do the complex part so
we'll go to a docs let me close this now
let's go to which one we can do we do
this get all
users anything is fine like this is just
for
example all right so now uh let me first
quickly create another components we'll
give this one as search
autocomplete we'll give search
autocomplete with API all right now
inside this we'll do index.
jsx and let me close everything else so
the first thing we quickly create this
component so this will be function and
this will be
search auto
complete all
right now inside this we are going to
return return so we will return return
uh first we'll take a class
name so this will be Search autoc
complete
container and here uh we will take one
input simple input then we'll give a
name which will be
search uh because we are calling the
users API will give search
users uh then we'll be having a value
onchange that we are going to do but for
now we give a placeholder uh it will be
search
users search users
here and also give a class name but that
is also fine this will work now now
first thing there are so many states we
need to take so we'll do one by one
first we'll need a loading State again I
always told you that we should always
show the loading uh State while calling
any kind of API so this will be US state
of false then we are having the users or
basically our data so we'll do this on a
set users and use state of Mt all right
now first time the page load we are
going to face the data and then we'll be
storing in this users so we take a use
effect for now we have done so many
times now we'll be like this will be
like a piece of cake for you very very
easy just take a method so this will be
Fage
list uh list of
users and this will be
async function Fage list of of
users uh let's take a tri block here if
you want you can like it's always better
to do these
things uh we can simply uh let's do one
thing let's take another state here so
this will be const error set error which
will be used of uh
null so here we are going to log this
error first and we'll do set eror as
this
error
all right so this is fine now here we
are going to call the API so this will
be const
response uh which will be equal to AIT
fet so let me just take
this all right and this will be our data
which will be AIT response do
[Music]
Json and let's see what we are getting
in this
data let's save it uh let's go to our
app.js let's let me just comment it out
and we'll create another one and this
will be our search auto
complete so this will be search auto
complete let's save it now let's
go all right so we are getting object
and here we are getting users so we can
check if the user length is true so we
can go here and we can check that if
data and and data.
users and and data. users. length if
this is true so set users will be data.
users we'll do set loading as
false and also do set error as uh null
and here we are going to make the set
loading as
two and if there are any error then also
you can make the set loading as
false that's
it all right so this is about the
getting the data so now what we need to
do whenever we will be typing something
we have to fet the data from this list
of users correct now we can do another
thing and that is if you go here let's
say we want to uh filter based on only
first name so instead of setting the
full object we can make this one much
simpler so we'll do data. user. map so
this will be user item and we'll just
take uh store this user item. first name
instead of storing all of this so now
let me just log this and let's see what
we getting in this
users all right so we are getting all of
this you can see that we are getting all
the first name right right so now we
need to basically implement the uh on
change so for this one the first thing
is that what we are going to do we will
take another state and this will be our
search
param and set search
param and this will be used state of
empty so
here we are going to uh give the value
as search
Pam and now we need to basically
check that when we want to S the uh drop
down to the user drop down means
whenever we'll be typing something if
there are any match so you have to show
some kind of drop down here so for this
one we will take another state and this
will be const so uh drop down set
so uh drop
down and this will
be equal to UST state of
false all
right so now what we are going to do
first we'll be doing the on change so
we'll take on change let me format this
so we'll take on change and this will be
handle uh change something like that and
now let's quickly create this method so
this will be handle change all
right now here first we'll be getting
the event so what we can do we can take
the query all right so which will be the
first thing is that query will be our
this search Pam that we are having here
that is fine but we can do something
like this so we'll take a query first
let's make this event sorry we'll do
event.
Target do value that we'll be receiving
and we'll make this on to two lower
case all right and then we'll do set
search Pam which will be this this query
that we are setting now here what we are
going to do we'll check if user is
typing at least two characters at least
two they need to type so we do if the
quiry sorry if the quiry is greater than
one so then we want to do something so
what we are going to
do again we will set take another state
which will be our
filtered users and say
filtered users should be US state of
empty obviously you can directly also uh
like manipulate this uh method here but
I think it is always better to take
another separate State here now here
we'll do const filtered data now this
will be this users that we are having so
this will be
users and then if this users. length if
this is true then only we want to do
this will be empty now here what we
going to do we do users do filter so it
will filter will take
item now here it will do this item dot
to
lowercase then we are going to check the
index
of this quy that we are typing that
means in this item whether this quy is
present or not as simple as that index
of this query that we are typing here if
this is greater than minus1 that means
that is basically present so this is
this will basically give us our filtered
data now we'll do set filtered user will
be our filtered data and we'll do so
drop down as true correct else the so
dropdown will be
false and I think that is fine now
you'll see what will happen happen uh
let me just do one
thing I think we are logging here let me
just log users and then we'll uh do
filtered
users and now let me just go there so
you're getting ter you can see that we
are getting two data now I'll search for
T okay I think we are getting some ER so
drop down is not a function I think we
have done wrong so this will be set so
drop
down okay so you can see now you type
here
e
r okay so you're not getting
anything okay let's see what exactly we
are doing here in the
code so getting the query you're setting
this part is
fine oh sorry we need to do query.
length
now this would work and now let me
refres this so do t e we got two result
you can see here if I give like let's
give R still two R now I'll give
y so we are getting only one if I remove
we are getting two so this is working
fine so now what we can do
simply if this is true that means so
drop down is true so we want to S
another component so I'll create another
component here I'll give this name as
suggests.
jsx and here I'll look export default
function and this will be
suggestions now here what we are going
to do will be receiving the data from
the parent
component and then we are going to
return simple
ul and here we'll do this data Dot
length sorry first we'll check if the
data and and data do length if this is
true or else this will be
null and here we are going to do data do
map so this will be our item and we are
going to Simply return
Ai and in the key we'll render this
we'll take the index
here so we take the index and we're
going to render the item here
that's
it all right now let's save it now let's
go back and here we're going to do if
this s drop down is true and then I want
to render the
suggestions and here you have to pass
the data which will be our filtered
users I hope you're getting now this is
a reusable component now you will be
obviously will be able to pass all of
this as a prop also from another parent
component and you'll be able to easily
manage that now another thing we can do
and and that is here we can show
something like if loading is true so uh
we'll do another thing here instead of
here because we're calling the API so we
need to manage this
loading so we'll do loading
data
please
wait or else we want to render this
item so let's format this now let's see
what is happening so we go here see we
are already getting the result here so
I'll type something te we are getting r
r y we are getting only one now let me
give something else we'll give M sorry m
i we getting one what else we are having
to let's see M A we are having so we'll
give M A we getting four I'll give C we
getting only one remove R and you can
see that this is working fine all right
I I think till this part this is fine so
now what exactly we want to do so
whenever we are typing something here
let's say if I click something so I want
to set that value here let's see how we
are going to do that so to do this one
we'll take another handle click method
so that I'm going to create this will be
handle
click so this method I'm going to
receive in this
component all right and here what we can
do
simply uh we will basically take a on
click
here and you'll pass this handle click
here all right so this is what we can do
now here if I now format this let's save
it let's go here let's quickly create
this method so we'll do function handle
click we get
event all right and now what we can do
let me just log this e do Target do
inner
text uh sorry let's make this an event
okay so now let's see what is happening
now if I now go back and let me first
refresh
this so I'll type something let's click
here okay I think we are getting error
in a text of
undefined sorry this will be
Target so now let's click here so you're
getting this St and you can see that we
are getting the value here now this is
pretty simp simple what we can do you
can make this Set uh set so drop down
this will be false we don't want to so
and then we want to set the search param
which will be this event. target. inner
text so copy this and also we'll make
the set filtered users as empty that's
it now let's save it now let's
see Let me refresh this so do te now
click here we getting the value all
right I now see this is working fine if
I click here you're getting this one if
I remove one again remove remove we are
getting two remove all of this we'll do
m a click marel and this is coming
fine and you can see that the
functionality is working fine I'll see
one thing that I haven't done any CSS in
this particular project because I think
there is no point because here for this
particular project from this point of
view they will not ask you to do much
CSS like this is kind of a functionality
wise project so even if you done till
this part that will be more than enough
so what we have done we have basically
called the API and based on that we
stored the data in somewhere and then
from that data we are filtering and we
are s now if they told you to do CSS I
think for now till these many project
that you have done I think you do have
much idea you'll be able to do it by
yourself so I think for now for this
particular project this is fine let's
move on to the next one all right so I
think I don't have to explain this one
that why we are doing this I know that
you all know that Tik Tac to is one of
the most asked interview questions in
product based companies and most of the
times they will say that you can't use
any framework but that also we going to
do in next videos when we will be
implementing all of this in simple vanes
but sometime companies like Amazon or
atasan they will tell you that okay you
can use any framework that you like so
obviously we will be able to implement
this this one so here we'll show that
the user that will be winning and if no
one is winning this is a draw we'll be
able to restart and let's say how it
will work so let's say if I do here you
can see winner is O and if I let's say
if I do here for
X so you can see that winner is X please
restart the game and this also will be
implementing each and everything from
scratch so let's see how we are going to
do this one all right everyone so let's
get start working on this uh tic TCT to
uh so what we'll do let's create a
component first sorry the folder first
so TI Tac to so inside this we'll create
our index.
jsx and we'll do styles.
CSS all right so here we'll do export
default
function ttac
to so the first thing is that what we
are going to do we need to basically
create the board now as I already
mentioned in the introductory video of
this particular like this is a very very
important questions that you actually
will get in your interview most of the
times like companies like Amazon Adobe
Microsoft even Atlas and also ask uh
this question so you should prepare it
very carefully and here actually you
have to explain each and everything what
you are
doing now here the first thing is let's
return our div so here I'll give a class
name of uh TI
tcto
container all right and here we need to
C create our rows so because we are
having three rows so if you see here how
this logic will works we're having 0 1 2
right let's say 3 4 uh 3 4 5 and then
let's say 6 7 and 8 So based on that you
have to create these three rows so we
having one row then we'll create two and
three and I'll give this one as name as
row let's copy this and we'll paste it
here same here let's format this
let me just comment it
out all right so you're having three
rows now for each and every row will be
having three squares so one will be for
this one this one this one same for row
second three and then last row three so
here uh what we can do we can simply
create another component we can create
in this file only and we'll give this
one name as
Square all right and for now uh we'll
simply return a button Buton here and we
are going to render some value all right
so this value it will basically receive
from this parent component which is this
component so it will receive a value for
now we'll just we don't have any value
but we are uh going to implement that so
here inside of this uh we will be
basically creating our each and every
Square so what we can do simply we can
call this
Square this component here so this
component that we are having and then we
can paste it three times same we can do
it for
here and then we can do it for here so
total we are having total 9
squares all right now first let's uh
create the CSS first so first what we
are going to do uh first we'll take our
uh let me just copy the class name so we
are having this
one so we'll do tick TCT to container
and then we'll do after so we'll do
clear both
uh we'll do content as
empty and we'll do a display of
table all right then inside this we are
having each and every squats so let me
just go here let's give a class name
here so we give a class name of square
uh sorry this will be U so this is our
each and every individual
squares so let's go here and then we'll
do dot Square so here for we'll do a
border of 1 PX solid
red then we'll do a float of
left we'll do a font size of 40 PX we'll
do a height of 100
PX uh what else we'll do padding of 0
PX we'll do text align as Center and
we'll do width as 100
PX that's
it also Let's uh use some margins we'll
do a margin in left sorry margin right
of Min -1 PX and we'll do a margin top
of Min -1
PX all right that's it and also let's
use a cursor
pointer so now let me just import it so
we do import styles.
CSS and then we are going to use this
one here so let me just comment it out
so we'll use another component so this
will be our Tic Tac tool
and here I'll import Tic Tac to let's
save it and let's see what is happening
here so if I now go back all right so
you can see that it's breaking that is
fine we have to give some styling here
so what we can do if I go here so you're
having this one each and every door so
here we can give a display of flex and
we'll do Flex direction as column and
that's it this will work all right so
you can see the each and every row you
are having
and let's give a justify content Cent
sorry not justify content we have to
give the Align item as Center and we can
give a margin top of for example 100
PX so let me copy this so this is our
container so we'll go to our
container and we'll just paste it
here let's see awesome so we having here
so I think for now this will be more
than enough for the styling part but now
here the main thing is that you have to
basically uh explain the functionality
in the interview that what you are doing
and how why you are doing that so let's
start uh one by one so the first thing
is that you can see how it will work so
this game is basically whenever you'll
click on any of the squares so first if
I am uh giving the cross first so next
time you have to give a zero so this is
how it will work zero or O whatever you
work you can say so it will be like
toggling again if I click it will be
cross again it will be zero
so that means we have to first decide
that uh from which we want to start
either we can start with a cross or we
can start with a zero and also for each
and every squares there will be some
space or some State we need to take so
that we can fill that letter whenever
we'll be clicking we have to let's say
if I click here the first one with cross
so I have to set a square value for this
particular Square uh for this particular
element in the state so that means we
for now we need two state so one will be
our
squares and this will be set
squares I think I'm doing some spelling
wrong q a r s so this will be UA and
here what we can do we can do a u state
of so we'll take array of nine because
we are having nine uh uh Square
basically and we are going to fill this
one with empty string that means
currently we have empty so if I now show
you what is happening in this so it show
you square so you'll understand I think
something is wrong here let me just
check what is
happening I think we can remove this one
let me just
check sorry it is not taking what is
happening oh see this is the reason so I
think we don't need to give this one we
can remove this part from here now let's
see
yes so this is fine that is the reason
okay so now you see if I go to console
we are having 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 89 9 with
empty now let's say if I click here that
means I clicked on the Zero index for
example so I have to fill this one with
that if I click cross it will be cross
here and then next let's say I clicked
on this one so this is 0 1 2 3 4 with
zero so four element will be uh a zero
like that so like that you have to fill
all the nine elements if there is is a
winner so simply return the winner and
there will be a restart button if all
the elements are filled and no one wins
that means it's a draw so for this one
what we can do we can take another state
and this will be const we do is X turn
that means if it is X turn or it's a o
turn Set uh do set is X turn and this
will be used state of true so that means
first time we'll do start with
X all right now next what we are going
to do uh here you can see that we have
to
basically take a on click each and every
time we'll be clicking so here first
I'll receive a on click so it will
receive on click which will be here on
click so this will be on click which
will be this on click that will be
receiving and then you have to pass the
on click
everywhere
and here I'll take a handle click method
and for first one I have to pass
zero so this will be zero second one I
have to pass one so this will be one
sorry this will be one this will be
two then we are having these
three and at the end we having this
three so this will be three this will be
four this will be
five this will be six 7
and this will be eight so for each and
every Square we are having kind of
identifier or basically the index so now
we going to create our function handle
click all right so here it will receive
the gate current
Square so here what we will simply do
we'll take this square that we are
having or let's do one thing let's copy
this copy squares so that will not
directly mutate the uh
state which will be uh these
squares and here we'll do simply copy
squares of this gate current Square so
we'll check that if it is X turn so
we'll render X or else it will be o I
hope you're getting so we check if it is
X turn so we cross a X or else this will
be a o and then what you need to do
first you have to basically uh reverse
this so if it is X means now it is false
because this will be not o turn if it is
O turn then again it will be true so do
set is xter will be not equal to is ex
turn I hope you're getting this and then
you have to set the squares which will
be this copy squares that's it now what
you need to do you have to pass the
value here you can see we are getting
this
value so this we can simply pass so here
we'll take a value and this value will
be what we can do we can simply pass so
it will be squares of
zero so copy this
paste it
here if you want you can also make this
on Dynamic you can create a simple
function and then you can pass these
values dynamically so this is 0 1 2 then
it will be three
5 6 7 and 8 now let's save it and let's
see what is happening so see if I click
here coming X again if I click here now
this is o x o x o now you see one thing
will happen see I clicked all of this
now let's see if I click here again see
it is getting changed to O So that means
we need to check if this square is
already full or means already there is a
value so we no need to change the value
we have to return and also another thing
we need to check and that
is uh that we are going to do that if
there is a winner or basically if there
is a draw then also we don't want to
render anything so first we'll simply
check here that that if this copy
squares of this gate current index uh
sorry G current square if there is a
value so we'll simply return from
here all right so now let's see what is
happening let's save it so now I refresh
this so we render some value zero and
now see if I click here again nothing is
happening because we don't want to
change the value here and this is as
expected correct so this is working fine
now now what we need to do so this
handle click part we actually got now we
have to calculate the winner that how we
are going to calculate so now you see
one thing that how winner is calculated
so if all of this actually pattern is
true so I'll show you so first I'll
create another function so this will be
function get winner something like that
and here I'll pass this squares uh it
will get the
squares as argument so how we have to do
we have to basically first take the
winning
patterns so winning patterns will be
this 012 I'll show you
why if all three are X or O So this this
and this one so this is one pattern then
we are having 3 4 5 6 7 8 then we having
03 6 means this one horizontally 147 258
then we are also having this one
diagonally 048 and 642 so these all will
be winning patternss and these also you
have to explain in your interview or
whatever you are doing 3 4 5 then we are
having 6 7
8 uh then we are having
25 uh 8 I think 258
258 then we are having
048 then we are having two sorry 2 4 6
and also we are having 03 6 and we are
having 1 4 7 so we having Total 1 2 3 4
5 6 7
8 that's it so these all will be your
winning patterns so now what we'll do
we'll simply take a fall Loop let I = to
0 I less than winning patterns. length
and
i++ so now we can simply check first
we'll dist structure this three values
so for each and every one will be a
value so this is let's say a value B
value and C value or let's take this one
as like X Y and Z so this will be
winning patterns of I now we'll simply
check if the squares of
X and and squares of X is equal to equal
to squares of Y and then
squares of X is equal to equal to
squares of Zed
so what we are doing here so that means
we are checking if this the value that
we are having here let's say we are
having X here so this is x value and
here also we are having X so that mean
this is equal to this and also here also
we having X that mean this also equal to
this so all three are of either X or
either y sorry either o or either X so
that means this is a winning pattern so
this is exactly what we are doing here
if x is equal y or xal to Z so that
means we are having a winner so we going
to return this squares of X that's it
else we we will simply return here uh
let's do something like
this after this we are going to return
return null sorry what I'm doing so this
will be return return
null so this will basically calculate uh
the winner that's it so now what we
going to do we'll simply take a use
effect okay
and here I'll keep this squares and the
e extern as a dependency now another
thing we need to check here if there is
a winner that means if this is true so
we don't want to change anything so that
means we don't want to change any value
if there is a winner so here also we
need to give this condition that if
there is a winner so what we can do
simply you can pass this uh gate winner
of this copy squares if this is is true
orse or else if there is a value that
means we want to return return all right
now we have taken the use effect so here
what we are going to do I'll take
another state here to maintain the state
uh status so we'll take a
status and this will be set status and
this will be US state of we'll keep this
one as
empty so here uh we'll check that
if there is a winner or that means first
we'll do the not one so if there is not
a winner so look get
winner of these
squares that means if there is a no
winner and and if squares do every sorry
squares. every if every square is full
that means it's a draw because see in
this position you can see X is a winner
or this part because these three are
same these three are same but let's say
there is a different scenario for
example we give x 0 x we're having zero
then x 0
x 0 and x so you can see here we don't
have any winner correct and but all the
squares are full so that means this is a
draw in this scenario so this is what we
are doing that if every item is not
empty if item is not equal toal to empty
so we'll do something like set status
and we'll render here this is a
draw this is a draw please uh please
restart so do please restart the
game all right else if there is a winner
so if this get winner of this square if
this is true so we'll do set
status sorry we'll do set
status so set status will
be so here we'll do
winner is sorry this will be winner is
so we'll just render this gate
winner of
squares because here we are returning
that value all right else if there is no
winner that means the game is not a draw
and also there is a no winner so either
it will be a x turn or Y turn so here
we'll do set
status so this will be so we'll show
like next player uh next
player is uh so here we'll render if it
is X turn so it will be X or it will be
o and I think we are done so now let's
see if I want to render here we'll take
H1 and we'll render the
status let's see what is happening now
so you can see next PL is X click here o
click here
o x o now notice what will happen if I
click here winner is X you're not able
to click or do anything here
correct so it's that means that if there
is a winner you don't want to do so we
can restart the game so here also you
can do something like winner is this
please uh
restart the
game all right now we will have a button
simple and we'll keep this one as
restart so we'll do on click we'll do
handle
restart so here we'll create method this
will be handle restart so what we need
to do on the restart first we have to
make this set is xter is true and then
we'll do set squares so again we'll uh
make this array dot array of nine do
fill with empty that's it now let's save
it let's click on next player is X click
here click
here winner is O please restart the game
not be able to restart now I'll do
x o x x sorry I'm doing let me restart
again 0 x 0 x
x zero now if I click here let's see
what is the issue here
so you're doing Square dot not equal mty
see we are doing set Square this will be
set status now let's
see okay so we'll do x o x o
x
o
x o and now if I click again so this is
a draw please restart the game I'll not
be able to click anything restart if I
do X
x o y winner ISO if I do for X let's
see winner is X let me check another
time if it's a
draw so this is a draw yeah I think
that's all for this particular project I
hope that this will definitely help you
and also I break down each and every
step why I'm doing that so this is the
same that you can implement in your
project or wherever you want to
implement the same so that's all for
this particular project let's move on to
the next one all right now this is a
another new uh like I'm not sure whether
you know this particular uh project and
that is called the feature flag so how
this basically works so let's say you
are creating a production level
application where you're having so many
application and for a particular year of
time let's say in Christmas you will
show some special component in your
website so instead of changing the code
directly how it will work so you will be
basically calling a API from from a real
AP obviously and then you'll be
basically getting the list of key value
pairs that which features you want to
enable and which features you want to
disable for that particular time and
whatever Flags you are getting as enable
from the API those only you want to
render so you see that obviously we
don't have any real API but the
implementation will be exactly same so
for this one we are going to use text so
here you can see that we'll be having
some features let's say I want to enable
the light and dark theme I want to
enable the Tic Tac tool I want to enable
the random color generator accordion and
Tree View and the tabs So based on that
it will automatically render all of
these and the functionality will
definitely work for each and every
separate component so you can see that
all right so this is exactly what we are
going to build now most of the times
like this is obviously not a very simple
one uh like if you're giving an
interview and they will give you like 30
minutes of time you'll not be able to
implement that F but let's say there are
more than 1 hour or two hours of time so
they might ask you these particular
questions and most of the times they
will again ask you this one to implement
in vanilla JS simply but you will be
able to sometimes they will allow you to
implement in reactjs also so let's see
how we are going to implement this uh so
this is not a simple one this is kind
you can say like this is a middle level
uh project that we'll be implementing
all right everyone so let's start
working on the feature flag
implementation now this is a very very
important questions that you might get
faced in your interview so as I already
discussed that what exactly we are going
to do so let's quickly start
implementing so what I'm going to do uh
inside this uh components folder let's
create another folder and sorry I think
we have to give here so inside
components we'll give this one name as
feature
flag now for this one what we are going
to do we will be basically using a
context now in a real life project when
you will be basically creating this
feature most of the times you need some
kind of Global Management something like
Redux or context whatever you are using
like just and some other uh State
Management library that doesn't matter
but at the end the concept will be
exactly same so inside this what I'm
going to do I'll create a folder and
I'll give this on name as context sorry
this will be a folder and this will be
context and inside this I'm create
index.
jsx all right now this is inside our
context now for this particular feature
flag we need also our index.
jsx and also we need a data because for
this one we will be using a dummy data
for now because most of the times in
interview also you will get this dummy
data and I'll discuss why so now the
first thing is that we'll start with
this data now how it will work let's say
you are having some feature in your
application for example if I give some
very common example like let's say dark
and uh light and dark toggle
functionality in your uh application you
are having various kind of charts or
some kind of like let's say you are
having a banner and that Banner you want
to display in some particular time of
your year let's say Christmas uh
Christmas Banner so what will happen we
using this feature flag you will be
basically calling a feature flag API and
then that API will give you the response
and in that response you will be having
that what are the features that you want
to enable and what are the features that
you want want to disable so if you do
this kind of thing what will happen you
don't have to manually change anything
in the code based on your API response
you will be able to understand that okay
I need to enable the Christmas Banner so
we'll be basically getting the data from
the API all right so let's see how we
are going to implement
this all right so for now you can see
that we are already having so many
components let's say we want to enable
our light and dark mode and also we want
to enable this QR code whatever we want
to enable so for this let's see we're
getting a dummy response so this will be
our dummy API response now obviously
this response you'll be getting from
your API for now we'll be using a dummy
API response doesn't matter you just
have to call the API and you have to
save the data now here what I'm going to
do I'll show something like so light and
dark mode so this is each and every
actually is the key and this is the
value that you want to show this feature
in your website or not let's we having
dark and light and dark mode then we are
having so Tick Tac to
board this is also true we'll take five
uh what else we can take we'll take this
uh random color
so random
color
generator this will be true and let's
take another two we'll take so as
accordian we'll make this one as let's
say false and also let's make this one
also
false and let's take another last one
which one we can take we'll take this
tree view so Tre View and this will be
let's say true so this is the key value
pairs that you will be receiving from
your API now I will be basically
creating a function so let's make this
on a function fetch uh or let's do
feature
Flags data service
call so this will return return up new
promise sorry this will be a promise so
we'll take
resolve
reject and what I'm going to do for now
because we are already having a dumy AP
response I'll check if the dumy AP
response is present so I'll just do a
set timeout sorry we'll do set
timeout and we'll resolve this dummy API
response that we are having will give a
time of
500 milliseconds else we'll just uh
reject and we'll show something like
some error
occurred
please try
again that's
it and let's do export default of this
feature flag data service
called all right so this is the let's
say AP response you are having now we
will go to our context and let's create
our context so here I'm going to first
we have to create the context so here
I'll create a context so this will be
export const and I'll give this one as
feature Flags context which will be
create context of
null now let's create our state so we'll
do export default function this will be
feature flag
Global
state so this will receive the children
of
components and here you are going to
return this feature flag context do
provider and we're going to get the
children here for now we also have to
pass a value so we'll pass a empty
object all right so this is all about
the context that we need
so now what we basically need to do so
in this context we will be calling the
API and then we will be passing that uh
how many flags that are enabled so let's
say this true all all the trues are
enabled and all the false are disabled
so if this is enabled so I I want to
show this one in my UI all right so
let's quickly do one thing let's quickly
create our component so this is our main
component which will be export default
function this is our
feature Flags something like
that and here I want to just return
div and let's return return H1 and this
will be your feature
flags all
right now generally whenever we will use
any kind of context we should always use
this one in our index but for now this
is fine because we want to individually
use this one in this particular
component only but later if you're doing
in the global level always wrap this
index .js or basically this app inside
your uh this uh this app you have to
wrap inside this feature
flag all right so now let's go to app.js
and I'm going to comment out this part
let's take another comment and this will
be our feature
flag
implementation so here I'm going to
import our first thing what we need to
do we have to import our feature flag
Global State because we have to wrap
this component in inside our uh context
so this will be our main uh context
wrapper and this feature flag will be
our component I hope you're
getting so now let's format and save
this all right so we are getting feature
Flags so now what we need to do first we
will call the API so we'll go to our
context we'll take two state so one will
uh one will be
loading and set
loading which will be US state of false
and if you see for each and every
project I'm always taking this loading
State and it is always a good practice
to Showcase your user that whenever you
doing some asynchronous activity you
should always show some kind of loading
St so that it will be very very easy to
understand for them and also I'm going
to take the enabled flags that will be
received from the API and this will be
set enabled flag
TS and we'll give this one as use state
of
null now let's take a empty object all
right now what we'll do we'll simply
take a use
effect and here on page load we're going
to do here
Fage uh
feature
Flags so this this will be as sync
method so here I'm going to do async
function
fet feature
Flags so here I'm going to do a try
catch
block so here I'm just uh do a log for
now and also let's throw some
error all this error sorry so here what
do we'll do const
response which will be AIT this will be
feature flag data service call now here
you need to do the main
your
original service
call all right now here you will be
getting the response so if I know log
this response let's see what we are
getting let's format this let's save it
so we getting object and inside this we
getting all the keys now based on these
Keys you have to basically render the
components here so now what you can do
you can do here set enabled Flags this
will be equal to
response and here we are going to pass
this enabled Flags so this will be our
value that's it now this is a very very
simple so so if I now go here so we'll
basically render a components so we'll
take const
components to
render which will be array and inside
this we'll take our key now you'll see
this key is basically this key that we
are having so having five
keys so I'll paste it here so this will
be our first one now for this one I have
to use the component so this this will
be our light and dark mode I hope you're
getting then you'll copy this and paste
it five
times we'll do so Tic Tac board so this
will be our Tic Tac to then we are
having so random
color this will be our random color then
we are having so
accordion this will be our accordion and
at then we are having the tree View
so this will be our uh sorry this will
be our tree
view that's it now let me remove
this now what we need to do so we will
basically get the enable flags from the
API so the first thing is that we'll
destructure this one from use
context of we are having this feature
flag context so this will give you this
enable flags that you are passing here
so this state also you don't manage the
loading state so let me just do a
loading state of
true and here we'll make the set loading
as
false if there are any error we'll also
set loading as
false so you have to do it here before
this and here we'll pass the
loading so these two we are going to
receive from our context
so we'll paste it here so now uh we'll
basically so if there are any loading so
we simply return here
div or let's make this one as
H1 so this will be
loading uh
data
please
wait let's save it let's see what is
happening it will be very fast I think
you'll not be able to see see this all
right so this is fine so now what we
need to do we have to basically check
that how many flags are enabled based on
that we have to check based on this key
we will render that particular component
so what we can do we can simply do here
component to render do map and this will
be our component
item and here we'll simply check we'll
create a function here so let's quickly
create this function so this will
function check enabled
flags and here it will receive the G
current uh sorry this will be G current
key so here we'll simply return this
enabled flags of this get current key so
now what this is object so if we are
getting a current key of let's say sort
sort review so it will check that if
this sort review is true or false if it
is true so render it or else not so now
we'll do check enable flags of component
item.
key
if this is true so we'll do component
item dot component we want to render or
else this will be
null now see what will happen if I now
save this now go back see now we getting
all the components here so first we are
getting Tic Tac to I think this is the
first
one sorry I think we having so and light
and because this is false this is
correct then we are having this one and
this all definitely will
work you can see everything is
working and I think this Tre view is not
not working the reason is I think we
have to pass the data so here we have to
pass the
data data what is the name let me just
check so this is menus so we have to
pass the
menus which will be our menus from
treeview that is the reason let me just
save it now let's see okay now this is
coming now see what will happen now
let's say uh in your API response now
this so accordion is also coming true
and this so dark mode is also coming
true now if I now save this now see we
getting all of these so we getting this
one we also getting tic Taco random
color generator and here you are also
getting the accordion all right I think
there are some styling issue but that is
fine because it is mismatching I think
multiple component style because of the
naming but at the end functionality is
working so you can see that everything
is working
fine yep now let's say if you want to
add a new component so obviously this
key needs to be updated and based on
that you have to also have to reender
this component ORS this will not work
for example let's say we want to
render the which one we'll do I'm not
sure we'll do tab tabs one so we add
another key here so we'll do so
tabs and here we'll do
component and this will be our tab
test and here I'll add these so
tabs as true if I now save it now let's
see so it's scroll down you can see we
are getting the tabs component also all
right so this is basically the concept
behind this feature flag implementation
obviously sometimes they will tell you
not to use any kind of framework you
have to do it in vanilla JS but as I
already mentioned that in later videos I
will be creating all of these projects
in vanila JS also so that's all for this
particular project let's move on to the
next one all right so next three
projects will be three custom Hooks and
one will be the use fet so you can see
that so for this one we'll be creating a
custom hook where you will be like able
to pass a URL customizable and all the
options and based on that you'll be
getting the data next will be uh like
this one so which is basically outside
click so here you can see that we are
having some data and if I click outside
that data is basically hidden so this
concept you can also Implement any kind
of model so let's say uh in interview
they'll ask you that okay you create a
model and on outside click you have to
close the model so this is basically the
same hook that we are going to create
and at the end we'll be creating this
use window resize hook so if I let's say
try to resize this one so you see that
this width will be basically and the
height will be changed so this is
another one that we are going to build
so we'll be creating most uh mainly
three hook one is use f use on click
outside and then use window resize or
you can also say this one as use
responsive all right everyone so let's
start implementing the first custom hook
and that is use fet although this is not
the first custom hook I think we have
already implemented another one and that
is use local storage while implementing
the that light and dark component but
this is also very very important I think
I already disc discuss multiple times
whenever you'll give any interview most
of the times they will ask you like
create any any custom hook that you know
now one of the most popular one is use
fetch that basically is used to fetch
any kind of data from API URL and that
has to be customizable so that we are
going to create and also you'll be
creating two more one will be use on
click outside so let's see you are
having a model and on click of outside
you want to close the model or anything
and the third will be the use responsive
or use window size whatever you want to
tell so let's start with our first one
so I'll just close everything else and
also let me just comment out this
one all right so we having first custom
hook and that is use
fetch
custom
hook so let me just close everything
else so here I'll create another folder
and this will be my use fetch so here I
want to create two file one will be my
use fetch hook that will be my index.
jsx and second one will be the testing
so I'll give this one as test.
jsx all right so now whenever we'll
Implement any custom the first question
will be a to quy like what are the
requirements what are the parameters
that you need to pass what are the state
that you need to manage and lot of other
things so here let's say in this use fet
hook you will be receiving for now we'll
keep this one very very simple Le we'll
just receive some URL and also let's say
you want to receive some options and you
want to me you want to manage a loading
state that is absolutely mandatory and
also you have to maintain a error state
so let's see how we are going to do that
so the first thing is that we have we do
export default function we have to give
this on name as use so this is how a
hooks name works I think you already
aware sorry so we'll give this one as a
use fet this will receive a URL and also
this will receive some optional uh
options all right so now here as I
already told you to manage three states
so one will be our data so this will be
data set data and this will be use state
of
null then we are having a loading state
so you give loading or let's say pending
whatever you give this on pending we
have given so much loading loading
everywhere so we'll give this one as
false and also we'll take another state
and that will be our error
State uh we'll do error set error and
this is also will be used state of null
all right so now what we need to do
basically we are getting this URL so
this URL will be our dependency So based
on this URL we need to page the data so
here what you can do simply create a use
effect
and then you give this URL as a
dependency and here we are going to
create a method so this will be our Fage
data all right so now here we will
create our function so this will be as
Inc function Fage
data so here the first thing is that
we'll take a
try and we'll take a catch so this will
be error so we'll just uh render the set
error that this will take template
literals and we'll pass this error and
then we'll show
some we'll show some error
ORD all
right and obviously we have to make the
Set uh pending as
false that's it now let's copy this and
here we are going to make also this one
as
true now here we'll do const
response this will be AIT
fet so fet will take the URL and then we
can pass this option that we are having
here that's
it so here now we we can check if this
response do okay is false so we'll uh
basically throw a new error
and we'll take this response for now and
we have to do uh the dot response.
status text all right and then here
we'll do const result which will be AIT
response.
Json so this will give you the result
and after that we are going to just call
the set data this is actually simple as
how we have usually do a API call result
and we are going to make the set error
uh sorry set error as
null and also we'll do set pending as
false that's it so this will now just do
the automatic fetching call and now as
simple as that we just have to return
the data the error and the pending State
that's it so that means this all the
data you are returning from this
uh your custom hook this custom hook now
you will be able to use throughout the
application it doesn't matter all right
obviously there are lot of things that
you can do like you can manage this one
on some button click like anything like
on some on change event on some call
back like so many things that you can do
but for now let's keep this one very
simple so now let's say we want to use
this one in this uh test component so
I'll just quickly create this component
so this will be export
default function and this will be use f
hook
test all right so here let's keep this
one very very simple so we just R A
div and we'll give this on H1 and this
will be our use
fet
hook now here first thing is that we
have to take the
uh output from the hook but how we are
going to get that before that we have to
pass this input right until unless we
pass the URL it doesn't work so that is
the reason we'll do const then we are
having data error so basically we
destructuring and the pending state so
this we are going to get it from use
Fage now you see it will take URL now as
for uh I remember I think we are using
some URL in this scroll indicator I
think we can use the same
uh let me just
check uh I think we're using somewh
dummy
Json yes so here we can copy
this and then we can pass this
one and this will pass this one as empty
object that is fine all right so that
means we are passing this input to this
hook and based on that we are returning
the data error and the pending let's see
what is happening here now so we un log
our error data and pending let's save it
let's go to our app.js and here I'm
going to render use f hook test now
let's save
it all
right now let's go to our
inspect
so we getting null so that means there
is no error first time this is false
pending then it is true now we getting
the data so you can see that we getting
the products here so this is the things
that we need to render so now this is
very simple so we can just simply go to
our test
component and here we can simply check
if the pending is true so we'll
basically render some h2 tag H3 that
pending so we'll do pending
please
wait or else this will be null and then
here we can basically check if the data
and and data.
products and and data. products. length
if this is true so we'll do data.
products. map this will be product
item and here I'll simply return some P
for now and I'll return return product
item.
title and we also give some key which
will be product item.
key if there is nothing so we'll just
render
null find now format this let me just
remove this one let's save it let's see
what is happening awesome so now we
getting the data here if I now refresh
this pending please wait and then we are
having the data so this is you have to
basically how you need to do now there
is another thing that you can do you can
see that we are explicit
uh now here another thing we can do you
can see that we are explicitly using
this data do products if you want you
can basically mention that what key you
want from this data and based on that
also you will be able to uh change this
functionality here but for interview
purpose this is more than enough that
you can do but one thing I'll suggest to
do and that is this method that you are
having try to implement the same method
on button click so let's say you having
a button in this component and whenever
you will click on this button you want
to call the same uh hook and based on
that you want to get the data another
thing I forgot so if there are any error
so we'll render this A3 and we'll render
this error here or else this will be
null that's it all right so I think
that's all for this particular project
let's move on to the next one so in the
next one we'll be creating a another two
more hooks uh one will be used on click
outside and one will be use window size
so let's start working on those all
right everyone so let's Implement our
second hook and this will be used on
click outside something like that so
let's say you are having some content
and whenever you will be clicking
outside of that content you have to hide
or basically you have to remove that
particular content from the from the
screen or basically the Dom so here uh
what we are going to do so most of the
times you'll face these uh questions in
the interview that you are having a
model and then let's say on click of
outside of that particular model content
you want to hide that model how you're
going to do
that okay so here I'll create another
one and this will be use outside
click and let's create our index.
jsx and then we are having test. jsx so
the first thing is that we'll create
this test component so this will be
export default
function so this will be function this
will be use
onclick
outside
teste and here let's say uh what we're
going to do is simply return some
div sorry we'll return a div and here
I'm going to first uh take a state and
this will be like so content now here
I'm doing a simple content it doesn't
matter if in the interview they're
telling you that you have to create a
model simply create a model and apply
the exactly same logic it doesn't
matter and here we'll do set so content
so here we are having used state of
false so now we are going to check if
this so content is
true so I want to do something or else
I'll rer a
button and here I'll do
so
content all
right and here we'll take on click and
we'll simply make this set sorry this
will be set so content we'll do set so
content
as uh we'll make this one as true now
here in this content uh let's say we are
having a
H1 uh this is a random content all
right and then we'll take a paragraph
please
click outside of
this to close
this it won't
close if you
click inside of this content something
like
that so this is the content now in place
of this one if you want to render a
model you can do that let's save it
let's go to our app.js and here I'm
going to create another content uh
component so this will be use onclick
outside hook
test all right so here we are having use
out on click outside test let's save
this let's go so click here we are
getting this one now what will happen
this is the content so each and every
content will have a reference so that
ref that we are going to use all right
so what will happen whenever I'll click
on the outside so here anywhere I want
to hide this and again I want to show
the button and this will be a general
concept so you are going to create a
model which will take a reference and
Handler function and based on that it
will basically detect that if we are
clicking inside of the ref of that
particular content so it will on close
if we are clicking outside then
obviously it will close so let's see how
we are going to implement that so go to
our hook and here I'll give this one
name as export default
function and this will be use
outside
click so as I already told you this will
receive a reference and also it will
receive a Handler function all right now
here what you're going to do you'll
simply take a use
effect and we're going to pass this
Handler and the ref as a dependency
because based on this ra only we are
going to do certain functionality all
right now here this is very very
important we need to create a function
which will be something like uh listener
we can give so this will be a listener
that we are going to create which will
give you a
event now what we are going to check if
so each and every reference so for
example each and every Dom element will
have a reference and that reference will
give you a current property so that I'm
going to show you so we are going to
check if it is not equal to this ref do
current or else if this ref sorry if
this ref. current.
contents this event.
target so we going to return all right
so here we'll simply
return or else what we are going to do
we'll call this Handler that we are
passing and we'll pass this event here
so this
event and now what we going to do we
have to add a listener to this so what
we can do simply we can take our
document sorry we can take document. add
event listeners so here we'll do mouse
down and we're going to pass this
listener that we have created same we
have to do it for document do add event
listener and we'll do a touch
start and we'll pass the same listener
all
right that's it now what will happen
this will do the functionality it will
basically check based on this current
ref property which will give you this
current property from this ref but here
one very very important thing whenever
this component will unmount so in the
call back we are going to remove this uh
event listeners we'll do document do
remove listener and we'll do the mouse
down and we'll remove this listener from
here and same we'll do for document.
remove event listener we'll do touch
start and we are going to remove this
listener that's it let's save it so now
this you need to check it here so how we
are going to do that so the first thing
very very important let me close this
so first thing is that we have to create
a ref so we do a ref which we are going
to do using use re I'm sure that you
already have some idea and this ra you
need to pass it to a Dom element now
because we are checking this one based
on this particular content so you're
going to pass this ra here I hope you're
getting so now this ra will give you ra
do current property now because this is
a custom hook hooks are always should be
called on the top of the top of this
particular function so we need to
basically and also hooks you can't call
directly inside a function so you have
to call on the top level always so you
can directly call here use outside click
all right now what will receive it will
receive a ref correct and then it will
receive a Handler now what Handler you
want to do so here let me just move it
here this is fine so here we can simply
do this whenever I'll click outside so
I'll make the set so content as false I
hope you're getting so what will happen
it will basically check based on this
ref and if this ra is not in the current
Target or basically here that logic we
are
doing then it will basically remove or
basically make this Handler as false
which is at the end that dispatch
function that we are using here if I now
save this let's go back let's click here
nothing is happening if I click outside
this is closing you can see
that and if I click any of here it's
working fine if I click here it's
closing so this is basically the whole
logic how you need to do that now this
is everything is basically based on this
R wherever you are passing this R this
part you have to be very very careful if
you want you can pass any component
inside of this and it will beave uh in
the same way so I think that's all for
this particular project now in the next
video we are going to do another
important custom hook and that is called
the uh use window size or use responsive
and that is also very very useful hook
that you can use in your uh project
whenever you'll be doing any kind of
large scale project so let's Implement
that particular hook in the next part
all right everyone so let's Implement
our third and the last hook that we are
going to create and that will be use
window resize or you can also name this
one or use this one as a use responsive
so let's say the scenario will be like
this so you are creating a global
application where uh you want to check
the responsiveness of this particular
page d dally using a particular reusable
hook so what you can do basically you
can create this hook and you can use
this in various components directly
which will give you the width and height
and based on that you can do based on
that you can do certain
operations so let's do one thing let's
quickly create another component inside
this and I'll give this one name as use
window resize you can name whatever you
like again we are going to create two
file inside of this one will be index.
jsx and one will be
test.
jsx now let me just close everything
else so here this will be the hook so
let's quickly create the component so
this will be function and we'll give
this one as we use window
resize now this will not receive any
parameters because at the end we need to
use a add even listener and that will be
resized and based on that we just need a
simple state which will hold the width
and height of that particular uh page so
here we are going to take this uh State
we'll give this name as window size and
this will be use window
size as I already mentioned this is
another very very important hook you
might get ask in your interview and here
you you will basically mention that I
will have a width which will be zero and
then I'll be having a height which will
be a zero initially all right now again
here what you need to do
here you need to take use layout effect
now what is the difference between use
layout effect and use effect use effect
will only load when all the Dom elements
will be rendered in your browser but use
layout effect will be called before that
so that is the reason we'll take a use
layout
effect
and here we are going to you can see
that this fire synchronously after all
the Dom
mutations but here it is almost
identical to use effect
so here you can see that uh what is
telling that it will FL ringly before
the browser has a chance to paint so
paint is one of the process whenever
browser will render all the elements and
after that it will do the paint so
before that only this use effect use
layout effect will be called actually it
is preferred to standard use effect you
can also use use effect but there is
nothing wrong using this use layout
effect in this particular scenario so
here what we are going to do we will
simply create a method so which will be
our handle
resize all right so now here we need to
add a event listener so we do window.
add event listener and we need to take
this
resize and we'll pass this
handle uh resize this function that we
will be creating so this is now when the
component will unmount so now we'll just
return and then we'll just need need to
remove this even listener we'll do
resize and then call this method
here all right so now let's create this
method so this will be function handle
resize and here what we are going to do
is simply do set window resize and here
we'll do width which will be window dot
inner
width and then we'll do height which
will be window do inner height that's it
so this will automatically set the
current width and height of this
window or basically the screen that you
are accessing and then simply return
this window size that's it all right so
now what we are going to do we need to
use this in our component so you create
a component so do export default
function and do use window
resize
test and here let's simply return a div
we'll give a H1 and this is a use
window resize
hook and now here we'll take a p
and we'll show here something like width
is so here we'll render the
width and then we'll take another
p and we'll do height is
height now from where you will be
basically getting so we'll get this
window
size from use window
resize now here you will be able to
extract
width comma
height from this window size and that's
it now what you can do simply based on
this width and height you can do certain
of and you can write some CSS anything
you can do let's save it let's go to our
app.js I'll just comment it out and
let's give another comment here and this
will be
use window resize hook
test and here we are going to do use
window resize
test now let's save it and let's see
what is
happening so let's go here so you can
see that we are getting width is this
height is this now let's try
to resize so you can see width is
changing and if I just do something like
this so we'll notice WID is changing
here and if I decrease height is also
getting changed all right so this is
working fine so this is another very
important react hook that you might get
faced in your uh interview also like
this is a very helpful hook that you can
also use for usability purposes whenever
you'll be creating a very big
application so I think that's all for
this particular project let's move on to
the next one all right so in this
project you can see that we'll be
creating the scroll to top and bottom
feature so we will be basically fetching
the list of data from API and there will
be two button one is scroll to bottom
and then scroll to top if I click here
it will scroll to the top and if I click
here it will scroll to the bottom so
this is another very small uh kind of
for snippet that we are going to
implement so let's see how we are going
to do this one all right so let's start
working on the scroll to top and bottom
uh component so let's create another
component inside this I'll do
scroll to
top and
bottom so here I'll create index. jsx
now let's say uh you are fetching some
data from API and there is a button on
top of the page which says that scroll
to bottom and at the same time you'll be
having some kind of button or any any
kind of Icon at the bottom of the page
on on click of that you you want to
basically go to the top of the page so
let's see how we are going to implement
that so first let me just quickly create
this component so this will be a very
simple project but although I think it's
a very good idea or basically very good
thing to know this this kind of concept
if like they will ask you that how you
will maintain scroll feature in your
website so that it will be very easy for
you to answer in your interview so let's
see how you're going to do that so we'll
do this on a scroll to top and
bottom all right now here let's say
we're fetching some data so I'll have
some data here or let's do one thing
another very interesting thing that we
can do and that is we have already
created a custom hook that is used Fetch
and we can use the same logic here to
get the data instead of calling the same
API again and again because we have
already we have already called this API
multiple times so you can copy this
thing and then we can paste it here now
I'll just import it that's it so this
will basically give me data now what I'm
going to do I'll return a
div I'll First Take H1 and I'll do
scroll to
top and
bottom
feature and here what we can do we'll
give another A3 tag and I'll do this is
the top
section and then we'll be having a
button and this will be scroll to bottom
so that means on click of that we want
to go to the bottom of the page and here
I want to render the data so I'll take a
UL here
simple and we can do here data and end
data. length this is true or else this
will be null so what we can do we can
simply do data. map we are having item
and we can render lii and because we
calling the product so I'm pretty sure I
think this will have data do products
sorry so this will be data dot
products and this will be also
same so here it will basically Ranger
item.
title all
right here we'll show so if loading is
sorry if bending is true so we just
return some H1 and we'll so
loading please
wait all right and if there are any
error so we'll also render something
like return H1 and we show error
Ur please try
again all right so after this what we
going to do so let's say we will be
having another button here and this will
be
scroll to
top that's it so now let's format this
and here also another thing what we can
do we'll take another A3 and we'll
render this is the
bottom of
the
page let's go to our app.js and let's
render this
component so this will be scroll to top
and
bottom all right let's save it let's see
what we are
getting all so we getting data do map is
not a function sorry this will be data.
products now let's
see all right so here also you can give
some style for now this is fine we'll
give a style and we'll do Le
style as
none all right so we are getting the top
section then we are getting uh this
sorry this is our top section then a
button and then we getting the data we
can also do one thing uh let's give
a limit
of 100
here so let's see if we are getting 100
dat or not yeah this is fine okay so now
on click of this we we want to basically
go to the top of the page and on click
of this we want to go to the bottom of
the page so how we are going to do
that so first let's take a on click so
we'll do handle
scroll to
top so we'll create a method so this
will function let me just copy
this that's it so now this will be
pretty easy what you going to do simply
do window. scroll
to all right and here you can basically
mention the options which will be the
scroll options so here you can mention
the top so if you want to go to the at
most top you can give the top top as
zero correct if you want to give 100 so
that will definitely work that is fine
and left will be also zero now another
option that you can give that is called
behavior and that is a behavior that we
will be giving this one as
smooth I think there are some other
options also you can use Auto instant
and smooth so this is I think fine let's
save it and let's see what is
happening all right now we'll go here
let's click here
see it's going to the
top all
right okay now I want to go to the
bottom so how we are going to do that
now to go to the bottom we need a
reference so because we need to tell
that what is the bottom of the page so
for this one what we can do so let's
take a d here this is just to uh give
you the example so I'll take a reference
and this will be our bottom reference
and here I'll be creating this so let's
create this const bottom ref this will
be used R of
null now we are having this button here
so this is the button so you need to
create another on click so Lo on click
this will be handle scroll to
bottom so let's copy this and let's
create this
method so now to do do this one what you
can do we need to basically I already
mentioned in the previous uh lectures
that this reference will give you a
current property and that basically you
can use so here we can simply do this
bottom ref do current and here it will
give you this
scroll into view all right so this is
the property and here you can use this
Behavior which will be
smooth all right now let's form this and
let's save it now let's see what is
happening if I click here it's going to
the bottom you can see that if I click
here it's going to the
top and this is working
fine all right now this is one thing now
let's say you want to go to a certain
section of this particular uh thing not
here I'll give you a different um
example for that all right so in this
project what we are going to do we will
be basically able to scroll to a
particular section so so let's say we
having first second third fourth and
fifth and let's say we want to scroll to
a particular section so if I click here
you can see that it's going to the third
card so based on reference we will be
basically getting the uh top content of
this particular card if we want to
change this one to Fourth it will scroll
to this particular section and if I
scroll to this fifth card it will scroll
to this particular fifth card so we are
going to see how we are going to
implement this one so the reason I'm
doing this one because once you'll
complete this scroll to top and bottom
functionality they might ask you that
okay let's say now you are doing top and
bottom and let's say there are multiple
section in your application in your web
page and you want to go to a particular
uh page uh for if I give you a real time
uh like more realistic uh example uh you
are having a website and then there is a
home about Services testimonial footer
section and let's say they they will
tell you that whenever you will click
the about it it should go to the about
section when you click to the services
it will go to the services when you
click on footer it should go to the the
footer so in this case this concept we
will be able to use so let's see how we
are going to do this one so let's create
another file here and this will be
scroll
to
section do jsx so how this will work so
let me just quickly create this
component so that it will be easy to
understand so this will be export fun
default
function this will be scroll to
section
and here I'll return something let me
just give a div and H1 so this is
basically scroll to a
particular
section so here I'll create some data
all right so create some dummy data for
now so what we going to
do so here uh let's give a label for
this one so this is our first card or
anything all right and we'll give a
color of
red let's copy
this and
also uh what we can do we can also give
a height or let's do one thing let's
create a style
here so we'll give a width of
100% height
of uh 600 PX and so for this one I'm
going to give a background
of
uh red now let's copy this and I'm going
to paste it 1 2 3 4 and five so this
will be my fifth
card and for this one we'll do this one
as
black so this will be my
fourth this one will do
green this one will do blue this is my
third and for this one what we can do we
do this one as
gray and this one will be
second all right so let's see what
having this data so first let me just
render this so we are having this H1 and
after this I'll be having a button and
this will be click something like uh
what we going do we do click to scroll
all right and then here I'm going to
render this data do map so this is a
data item and here I'm going to return a
div and then I'm just take a p or let's
take A3 and render this data item dot
level and here I'll take the style which
will be data
item dot
style all right so now first let's save
it and let's go to our
app.js let me just comment it out or
let's make another comment here so this
will be scroll to a
particular uh
particular section all right so this is
let me just import it so this will be
scroll to
section let me just comment it out let's
save it and let's see what we getting
all right so we getting first card
second third fourth and fifth so fifth
one I think we not able to see let me
just change this color what we can do uh
we'll give some different color for this
one uh so let's give this one as
orange okay so now let's say you want to
scroll to this fourth card for this one
so how we going to do that so for this
one you are to create again the the ref
so here I'll create a ref so let's say
I'll create a ref for now I'm giving
this one name as ref you can use any
name you want so this will be use ref
all right and then let's say here in
this div I'll give a ref which will be
if this data item or let's take index so
index so check if the index is equal to
equal to three that means this is the
fourth item and want to give this ra as
this ra or else this will be null all
right so now let's save it and here I'll
give on
click so this will be handle scroll
to
section and then you have to again
create the
function and then here what you need to
do first you have to basically get the
current position so we'll do uh let
we'll do let po position which will be
our ref do current and now this will
basically give you one property which is
get bounding client get bling bounding
client and this is
wed and this will give you a top
property now here what you can to do you
simply do window. scroll
to and here you will basically pass I
think we already discussed that you have
to pass the stop so which will be this
PO that you are having and then you'll
do a behavior which will be smooth
sorry H that's it so that means you are
targeting this particular uh ref which
is basically the card number four and
then you are basically getting this gate
bounding cent. top which is the current
of and then if I now save it and let's
go here let's click here so it's going
to the fourth card you can see that if I
change change this index to let's say
four that means now it will go to the
fifth card all right so this is the
advantage so how you will be able to
basically go to a particular section all
right so this is now going to the
third all right now you can see it's
going to the fifth card if I click here
again this is going to the fifth if I
let's make this one two so now it should
go to the third Let me refresh this if I
click here it's going to the third card
so this is another very important thing
that you should know how you can
basically scroll to top bottom and also
to a particular section so that's all
for this particular project let's move
on to the next one all right everyone so
this will be a very very simple project
so this will be a weather application
now this is a very very popular
interview questions and the main reason
behind is that here actually you don't
have any routing or some any other
functionality so we will be having this
search functionality obviously and if
you type something based on that we'll
be calling the AP
and the data will be updated so this is
the main uh main thing that what we are
doing here nothing else obviously we'll
be creating some reusable component and
based on that we'll be try we'll try to
implement this particular project so
let's start working on this particular
uh project that will be weather
application so the first thing is that
what we are going to do here so let me
uh what I've done I just created a
simple react project here and then uh
I'm in this app.js now if you're
watching this for the first time or you
don't have any knowledge on react then I
will suggest that please watch some of
the very basic videos on reactj so that
you'll get some idea and then you can
start uh this video if you already have
some idea then I think you are good to
go so the first thing what we are going
to do we'll just remove everything from
this app and then now here let's create
our first uh folder so I'll create one
component folder here so let's give this
on name as components so in the weather
application as I already showed you that
we'll be having one simple search bar
and then whenever we'll search or input
any city name and based on that we'll be
getting the weather info of that
particular City so you're going to
having basically two components one will
be a search component and second one
will be basically our weather
component now inside this we are going
to create our index. jsx same I'll
create here index.
jsx all right so here let's quickly
create this component so this will be
export default function and let's give
this our name as
weather now let's return some simple div
and this is our main weather component
what we are going to do will be
importing this component in our app.js
so here we'll simply import our weather
component so this is our first step so
you're getting weather here now
similarly we are going to create our
search component here so this will be
export default function
search and here I'm going to return
return search now this search component
we are going to use in this weather
component all right so let's say here
I'm having this weather so I'm going to
now use this one this search component
here later we are going to change uh the
structure so now we are having search
and weather so first let's start with
this search components will be having a
search bar and for this one this project
is our very basic project so for this
one we are going to we will be basically
use Simple CSS we'll not use any other
third party utilities like Tailwind or
material UI all right so now let's go to
our search component now here what I'm
going to do for now I'll give a class
name here now later we will be writing
all the uh all the Styles in this app.
CSS so this will be our main app. CSS
and you can see that this is basically
imported in our main app.js file so here
what I'm going to do I give this on name
as let's give this one as search
engine and
here we will simply return one
input so here I'll give a type as
text uh let's give a class name CT
search then we are having placeholder so
this will be enter city name
then we will be having a name so name
what we can give we can give this one as
search we'll also we be having a value
so value will be basically be receiving
from our parent component as a prop so
this is our first prop and let's give
this our name as search all right and
then we'll be having a on change now for
on change what we are going to do we'll
be having a event and again we are going
to receive a prop from our pent
component which will be basically a
wether or app.js doesn't matter so here
what I'll do I'll do set search as this
even do Target dot value so now these
two are the props that we are going to
receive so the first thing will be
search and then this will be set search
all right so this is all about our input
if I now save this we will be having one
very simple input this is fine and after
this what we going to do we will
basically take a button so this will be
our button and let's give this on name
as search weather something like
that and here I'll give a class name and
or I think this is fine let's give a
class name of for example search
button all right now here in this button
we will also receive another props and
this will be submit search something
like that or let's give this on name as
handle
search all right now this is another
prop that we are going to receive from
our parent
component so this is very simple uh
structure that we need now let's do one
thing let's quickly create our uh Styles
so the first thing what I'm going to do
let's remove everything let's take our
body and here I'll give margin as zero
and padding as zero then uh we'll be
having our search engine so this is our
class name so copy this so this will be
a search engine here I'll give you width
as
100% we'll give display as
Flex we'll give justifying content as
space around we'll give align items as
Center we'll give margin bottom as
30px and we'll give margin top as
10px all
right now next thing we are having the
input so we'll having search engine then
we having input I think we also have a
class name here so you can and directly
use this class name Also let's remove
this one we basically don't need so here
what I'm going to do so the first thing
is that let's take a width here we give
this one
70% we'll take a height of 45 PX we'll
take a border of one PX
solid then we'll take a border
radius uh let's take this one as 8
PX all right we'll take a padding of 2
PX x 15
PX we'll take a font size of 16
PX uh we'll do outline as
none background color will'll do
white and we're going to use a color of
this
one all right this is fine now similarly
I think we don't need this class name
also so you can remove this one so what
we can do we can simply take dot search
engine of button so you're targeting the
button so here the first thing we'll do
border is
none we'll do border radius as
8px uh what else we'll do background
color as
black we'll do color as
white we'll do font size as 20 PX we'll
do outline none we'll do cursor as
pointer and also do padding as uh 12 PX
15 PX let's see how this will look so
now let's save this save this one also
and now let's
see all right so now this is fine I
think there are some let me just check
we can basically increase some of
the uh some of the padding here
basically so 47 This Is 50 so what we
can do we can make this one as
13 okay and also let's do this one as
search so we'll make this one as
13 all right so this is done so now next
uh we will be basically start working on
the functionality first so what we need
to do here because we need to pass this
Prof from the parent component which is
basically our weather so because we are
using this search component in this
weather component so we need to take all
the uh State here so the first state we
need to take that is to handle the
search and this will be our set search
and this will be U state of empty so
this is our initial value and here we
need to pass this so we'll pass this
search as
search also we pass this set search as
set search and another one we need to
pass and that is handle search because
this way we are going to handle on click
on of this
button so here what I'm going to do so
let's do one
thing we'll make this one as a as sync
method because we need to call the API
on click of this button and this will be
handle search all right and here we are
going to pass this
one like this so this is done all right
now next thing what we need to do
basically we need to take two more State
one is to so loading state so whenever
we will be typing something here and
click on this search we want to show
some kind of loader until unless we'll
get the data from the API so that is the
reason we are going to take another
state here and let's give this our name
as loading and set
loading and this will be use state of
false and at the end we also need to
take our weather data so this will be
our weather data set weather data and
this will be US state of
null all right so now everything is
almost done so what we need to do
basically on click of this button we
need to call the API so for this one we
are going to use this open weather map
API let me just show you that which
endpoint we are going to use all right
so you can see that we are going to use
this open weather map uh this API this
is a very nice API that you can use it
will give you lot of uh API end points
that you basically will be able to
integrate in your application for now we
are going to keep it very simple so what
you need to do first you need to create
a uh account and then once you'll do
that you
basically have to get your own API keys
please don't use my own obviously I'll
push my code in GitHub but don't uh use
like my own API key please create your
own so you have to go here and then you
will be able to basically see the API
key all right so this is our API key
that I will be using
and for AP end point what we are going
to do
basically you'll basically get lot of
options uh so let's see if I now go here
so we can basically use the same end
point but here instead of this lat and
Lawn what we are going to do we'll be
passing this queries this query will be
basically our city name and then you
have to pass the app ID which will be
your API key all right now how we are
going to do that so the first thing is
that uh what we need to do we will be
creating one uh sorry one method here
and this will be as sync function f
weather
data all right now here let's take a
triy block so in
catch we'll just log this
error and here what I'm going to do I do
const response and this will be AIT
Fage
and here we we are going to use the same
one so let me just copy this one we need
to basically change some of the things
so here the first thing is that what we
need to do we basically don't need this
one so what we will basically use we'll
use this query parameter and this quy
parameter is uh our search value here so
this is our search or basically the CT
name and this API key uh I'm going to
use my own so I'll go here and then
let's go to our let me just go to my API
keys so I'll just copy
this and I'll paste it
here that's it so this is
done all right so now what we can do
simply we'll do const data equal to AIT
response do Json and then I'm going to
log the data here and we'll see what
what we are getting
now this search is basically the city
name that we will be typing so now let's
say if I now type here something let's
say uh
Mumbai click on this search nothing is
happening the reason is we need to
basically call this method here so what
we going do we can simply do Fetch with
the data now this will receive a query
or the param let's make this one as
param
so this param we are going to pass it
here and this param is basically nothing
but our search data all right now let's
save it and now let's click on this
search see how first we getting the
result so we getting all the result
based on this so this is our city name
if I now change this one to
Bangalore and now let's click on search
so now we are getting based on bangaluru
so now you will be basically getting the
obviously this is happening very very
fast first still what we are going to do
we will be swing some kind of loader
until unless we're getting the data back
and that is pretty simple what we can do
simply uh here before calling the API
we'll make this set loading as true all
right and then once we'll get the data
so we'll do if data is true then we'll
do set loading as
false and we'll do set weather data as
this data
that's it and if something goes wrong
then we we will basically make this one
as false in the catch block that's it so
now let's see what is happening with
this
loading so now if I now go back now
refresh this
page will be getting false now let's
click on something let's say daily then
I click on search true and then false so
for sometime it is coming true so it is
in the loading phase then we are getting
the data so that is the reason it is uh
false again so this is done now another
thing what we need to do and that is on
page load also we need to get some kind
of data so now what I'm going to do for
now we'll give some static city name
that will obviously whenever you load
the page it will give you the data based
on that City so to achieve that what we
can do you can simply take use effect
now this is a dependency that will run
on the page load if we pass empty
dependency here and then what we can do
we can simply call this Fetch with the
data and here I'm going to pass this on
as Bangalore so that means every time we
load this page it will basically face
the data based on this Bangalore City
now here we can if I now log this wether
data now let's go back you can see that
we are getting now based on bangaluru so
each and every time load this page it
will give you the data based on that so
this is done so now next thing what we
need to do now we need to basically
create our weather component so the
first thing uh here uh we'll do
something like this if loading is true
so we'll show some kind of message that
the data is in loading Fage so so
something like loading or else we going
to write our jsx so here we'll take a
div all right now inside this we'll take
another
div
and we'll give a class name let's make
this our name as uh city
name and here I'm going to take a h2 tag
now here what we'll do we'll basically
check if this wether data is present so
we are going to render the name so I
think we are having this name here so
this is the name and also you're going
to render the continum so continum will
be weather. SS do country all right so
here I'll do this is name then comma
we'll take a span here and here I'm
going to check if this weather data true
do sis dot uh
country that's
it now let's save it let's see what is
happening so you're getting bang Lulu
and this is the uh okay this is this
message that we need to
remove now let's type here London and
let's search so now we are getting
London GB and then also if you notice we
also getting the loading uh for very
small amount of time so this is fine now
next thing what we will do so after this
we'll take another D here and here we'll
give a class name of
date and here uh we'll take a
span and we are going to create a
utility function and this will be G
current date all right so let's quickly
create this one so for this one what we
can do uh let's create one function this
will be function gate current
date sorry this will be date so here
we'll do simply return new date and then
we'll do two local date string we are
going to pass en us and we have to
basically pass some of the properties so
we can pass weekday as long then we have
to pass month we'll pass this one as
long and day we are going to do as
numeric all right and here also
same I think we are using some different
name so this will be get current date
all right so now let's save it so now
we'll be getting our current date so
this is fine now next thing what we are
going to do we are going to render this
temperature so we'll be getting this one
from weather. m.
temperature all right so here what we
can do so after this we'll take another
div sorry this will be div and
here so we are going to render this will
be
weather data dot
Main do
temp all
right now after this we'll take another
paragraph and this will be our
description so let's give this one as
description so description will be
getting
from uh I think we are having so here
weather and then this is our description
so what we can do we can simply check
something like if weather data and
then with the data of zero then with the
data of 0
dot
description or else this will be
empty all right now let's see what we
getting let me just save
it I
think let me just change this one to
London search
all right we are not getting anything
here all right so the pro problem is
basically here we have to basically
check dot weather of zero so this will
be weather data and and weather data dot
weather and
and weather data do weather of
zero and this will be wether data of
with the zero do description now this
should come all right so now this is
coming so now next thing what we'll do
we'll take another div here so after
this P we'll take another
div all right so here we'll give a class
name so we'll give this one as weather
info and here uh what we can do we can
simply take one
div and inside this we'll take another
div and we'll take a p here and let's uh
display the speed here so speed we will
be able to
see so you have to go to
wind weather. wind. speeed all right and
also we have to basically render the
humidity so I think humidity will get
from here from the mean so what you can
do you can simply give a class name so
you'll give a class name of wind and
we'll do here weather info do
wind do
speed and here we'll take another p and
we'll make this one as wind
speed all right and now let's copy
this and we'll paste it here
again and here we'll make this one as
humidity and this will be weather do
Main
dot uh this will be
humidity all right and this will
be
humidity and I think this is fine now
let's save
this so you're getting all the data here
all right this is wind speed and this is
humidity now you have to style this so
now let's go to our uh CSS file so the
first thing what we'll do is start with
our main app uh class which is basically
this one so here we'll do dot app and
here we'll do text align as Center we'll
do margin as 50px
auto0 we'll do width as
90% we'll do Max width as 700 PX we'll
do border radius as 20
PX uh we'll do height as 470
PX we'll do padding as 20 PX 15
PX and we'll do background as this one
so this will be RGB 0a 255 comma
166 let's save it let's see awesome so
now this is looking nice so now
let's uh start with our weather uh comp
component so the first thing we'll start
with this city name so we'll do this one
as dot CT
name so we'll do margin bottom as
10px next we'll do uh we also have a
loading class here so let me just take
another loading
here so this will be our DOT
loading and here we are going to do this
on a font size as
60px all right and we'll do font weight
as Bolder and then also we do color as
black this is done now next we'll do our
date so for date we'll do font size as
18 PX we do font weight as 500 and we'll
do font
style as
EIC so now let's save this let's see how
this is looking all right so this is
fine now next what else I think we also
have C date this is done we also have to
take this temperature so we'll do class
temperature we'll do temp
only all right so here we'll go here and
we'll do do imp so we'll do font size as
64 PX
we'll do color as
black we'll do font weight as bold and
we'll do text align as
Center let's see all right now next uh
we are having weather description let me
just
check I think we having only description
so this will be do description so here
we'll do color as
black all right font size will do how
much 22
PX font weight
500 margin top 0 PX and margin bottom
20px let's
see all right and after that uh what
else we are having weather info which is
our main rapper class okay so we'll do
do weather
info so here we'll do display as
Flex we'll do justify content space
evenly we'll do align items as
Center we'll do margin top as 20
PX padding as 0 PX
20px we'll do font
size uh as 20px we do font
weight bold and also we do text
align Center all
right now we'll do uh
let's do one thing uh let's go here
let's take some class name for this also
this will be
column something like
that and also for this
one so we'll do dot
column and we'll do uh display Flex
align items
Center we do uh what else we'll do line
height of 1
PX let's save it let's
see all right I think this is looking
nice so this is
fine now let's refresh
this so now the first thing is that
we'll give some name here uh let's say
Mumbai let's search so getting based on
Mumbai for sometime we are also getting
the loading state if I give
Bangalore so we getting based on
bangaluru if I give something else let's
say what else New
York we are getting New York so
everything is working fine so I think
that's all for this particular project
and this is a very very small project
obviously but obviously you will learn a
lot of things the first thing you learn
that how you can create components very
basic level how you can use the
components the child components in the
parent component and then import the
same and also how to use the use State
and also obviously the API call so
that's all all for this particular
project now in the next project we will
be basically creating a RP application
now that will also will be not very
advanc level project but obviously that
will be harder than this one so see you
in the next project good luck all right
everyone so this will be our second
mid-level project so this will be food
recipe application in this project Al
we'll also learn how you can integrate
react router Dom so you'll be able to
search some recipes and based on that
you'll be basically getting the data
from API and then you'll be having the
details page also and here you'll be
able to add this one and in this page
this will be updated here so you can see
that this is updated if I try to add
something else so it will go to the
homepage I'll add here and let's add
this one so you can see that this is
updated let's go to
homepage and let's see if I try to add
here this will be updated so this is
another uh thing that we are going to
another very simple project that we are
going to build so so mainly uh the
reason is because what we are trying to
do here here we are not only obviously
we will be getting the data from API but
here we are having multiple pages so
this will also give you some idea how
you can work with Dynamic routes how you
can Implement react router Dom so this
is the main idea or basically the main
objective to implement this particular
application so let's start working on on
this full recipe application all right
everyone so let's start with our uh
second project and this will be
basically recipe application so I
already created one uh project and for
this one we are going to use delin CSS
and also uh for this particular
application as you already discussed
that will be having basically multiple
pages so we need to implement routing so
for this one we are going to install
react router Dom so I'll do npm install
react router
Dom also uh we have to basically install
tawin CSS now tawin CSS is basically
utility CSS framework and here basically
what you have to do you just have to
basically write some predefined classes
that tnd team already created and based
on that it will basically automatically
apply those Styles in that particular
HTML element if you have already used
this one uh previously then it is nice
if not then also it is fine it is very
very easy to use so let's see how we are
going to basically use this TCS so the
first thing is that you have to create a
react project that I already have done
now next thing uh you have to install
this T Inc as a DA dependency so that is
the reason it is showing here minus D so
I'll just copy this one and then here
let's uh paste it so now this will
basically install this one as a de
dependency and after that what you need
to do you have to basically init uh this
uh Tailwind CSS so it will basically
create a configuration file so this is
the configuration so now I'll copy this
second now I'll run this one and you can
see that it will create a uh file here
so this is our tawin configuration file
now whatever configuration that you will
be writing based on uh this Tailwind you
will be writing here so you will be
basically able to extend some of the
theme you'll be able to add uh plugins
and also you have to pass the content
that which content you want to to
basically access for this particular
application now because we are using the
react so react generally accepts you can
see that it is JS jsx TS if it is a
typescript project or TSX so this one
you have to basically pass so I'll copy
this one and then I'll pass it
here all right so that means now twin
config will understand okay we are using
uh this extension which can be either JS
or jsx TS or TSX let me minimize this
and at the end of this what you need to
do you to use this base utility in our
main index. CSS file which is basically
our root CSS file so I'll just copy
this and then I'll go to our index. CSS
and then just paste it here all right so
now what it will do it will basically
apply all the base uh classes components
and the utilities that whatever we are
having related to this tement and you
are good to
go all right so that's all now next
thing what we are going to do first we
will be basically implement the routing
now basically you'll be having three uh
pages so the first or landing page will
be where we'll be searching the recipe
name and we'll be basically getting the
list of recipes and on click of that it
will go to the recipe Details page and
also on click of uh that particular
recipe we will be able to add that
recipe into our favorite section all
right so now let's do one thing to
implement the routing the first thing
what we need to do as we already uh
install the react router Dom so react
router Dom will give you a main wrapper
that you need to basically wrap your app
component inside the reper so that you
will be able to consume all the react
router Dom react router functionalities
so for this one what you need to do
first you have to import something from
react router n and this component is nam
as browser router now this is basically
a router for uh used for use uh browsers
and basically this will be work as a
wrapper for this particular application
and you have to do it or else it will
basically give you error so now what
I'll do I'll just wrap uh this browser
router and then place this app inside
this browser router that's
it all right now next thing what we are
going to do we will basically uh let's
do one thing let's create our pages so
I'll create another folder here and
let's give this on name as pages so here
I'll create three more folder one will
be our home and then one will be our
details all right and one will be our
favorites all right now here let's
create our index. jsx so this will be
our export default function this will be
home and here I'm going to return here
div and this will be our home let's copy
this or let's copy this one only and
then I'll place it here and also here so
now this will be our
favorites and this will be our
details and this will be our details all
right so we are having basically three
pages now so now what we'll do we'll go
to our main app.js and and here we need
to basically implement the routing all
right so the first thing is that what we
can do we have to basically import uh
the main routes wrapper now because we
are using the route uh react router Dom
version six I believe so you can see
that this is
6.19 previously we are using this one as
a switch the component that I'm going to
use but now they have basically change
some of the functionalities so the first
thing is that we have to import that
wrapper from uh react router Dom and
this name as
routes all right you can see that this
is basically a container which will Nest
all the route elements this is the first
step also you need the to represent the
each and every individual route or
basically each and every Pages we need
route component also all right now let's
remove all of this from
here now what I'm going to do here let's
uh we already having this D let's remove
this class we don't
need and inside this now I'm going to
use one
div now here we are going to use the
tailin
classes so here we'll give this one as
mean height of
screen we'll give a padding of
six we'll give a BG of white we'll give
text Gray 600 and also give text as
large now inside this we will be having
our nap component now this will be a
common component so what I'm going to do
inside this Source I'll create one
folder and this will be our components
and here let's create our nabar all
right so this will be index. jsx so this
will be our naar component or basically
header component so here I'll do export
default function and this is our naber
all right now let's return here this div
and this will be our Napp
so napar component will be common for
all the pages so that is the reason we
are going to Simply import this napar
component here now after this uh
whatever content we'll be having that
will basically differ Bas on different
pages right so home will be having
different content favorite will be
having different and same for details so
to switch from one page to another page
the first thing what you need to do you
have to basically use this routes
wrapper and inside this you have to use
each and every individual
uh route so here I'll use three route
because we are having three pages one is
home favorites and details so I'll copy
this one and paste it three times now
here you have to pass some of the props
so the first thing you have to pass the
path so this will be our SL path and
here you have to pass the
element so here I'm going to import our
home component so you're having home
component let me check the name so this
is home only
all
right now same goes for this one so let
me just copy this one so this will be
our favorites component so this is
basically the path name and here this
will be our
favorites okay we are not getting any
let me just
check so we have to import this one
so this will be our
favorites from favorites and also we'll
be having our
details from our Details page that's it
so this is our favorites and next we'll
be having a details now details is
basically a dynamic page that means for
each and every recipe item the item id
will be different so for this one how we
are going to do that so we'll do
something like this we'll do here let's
say recipe item SL and to denote a
dynamic value in uh in this path name
what you need to do you to use this
colon and then you have to pass the ID
so that means this is basically denoting
that this value can be a dynamic it can
be anything 1 2 3 4 5 6 whatever all
right and here again we are going to use
the element so here I'm going to use
this details
component and that's it so this is all
about the uh um routing structure that
we need so if I now go back and you can
see that now we are getting home because
we are currently in the slash route all
right because we have given the slash
here for home if I now go to SL
favorites so let's go to slash favorites
so you're getting favorites here if I
now go to slash let's say recip item
slash one so that means this is a
dynamic value so now now this would go
to The Details page all right now if I
not check this one to let's say four
you'll be getting the same result
because this value can be anything so
this is a dynamic Details page so that's
all about the routing functionality that
we need now next thing what we going to
do first we'll implement this NAB
because nabard will be a common
component and after that we'll be start
working on the API integration all right
so let's start working on the uh nabar
component so the first thing let me just
close everything so what we'll do we'll
remove this one from here and we'll
return a nav
element and here I'll use this class
name now I'm not going to explain each
and every class Name by the name of it
you will be able to basically know if
you have some basic idea on CSS so we
are going to use flex this will be
justify between item
Center py that means padding top and
bottom of eight we'll use a container
class MX
Auto Flex call
for large we'll do Flex
row all right we'll do gap of five and
for large you'll do gap of
zero all right now inside this I'm going
to take H2 and let's give a name like
food recipe now anything you can give
here whatever you like now here I'll use
a class name so we do text 2 XL and font
semi
bold let's format and save this let's
see okay now after this uh I'm going to
take one form here and here I'm going to
take a
input now here type uh this will be
text then we'll give a name so let's
give this name of
search then we are having placeholder so
we'll give it
enter items something like
that and then I'll give a class name
here so we'll do here BG of white divide
by 75 we'll do p of 3 PX of 8 we'll do
rounded full outline none for large
we'll do W of 96 we'll do Shadow
large we'll do
Shadow red
100 we'll do
Focus
Shadow
red 200 all
right this is fine now next what I'm
going to do so you also need here value
and um onchange property but for now
this is fine but let's save it now let's
see how this is
looking all right so now this is fine
now next thing what we are going to do
so after this form we take another uh
here
e and here I'm going to use sorry this
will be e here I'll use a class name of
flex gap of
five now inside this I'll take
Ai and here I'm going to use the nav
link from react router Dom now the first
I need home and here we need to pass the
two property so here I'll pass a two
property I want to go to the slash route
and here I'll use a class name so Lo
text as black for hover sorry we need to
do text as black for hover we are going
to do text uh gray 700 and we'll do
duration of 300 all right this is
fine now next thing uh let's copy this a
from here and I'll use the same one
because we also need another section and
that will be our favorite so I'll use
her favorites and this will go to/
favorites
section also what we can do we can uh
use nav link here also so let me just
use the same here so this will also go
to the food
recipe
okay
now let's format this let's save it
let's see what we getting all right so
you're getting middle we are having
input home and favorites if I click here
it is going to home if I click here it
is going to favorites if I click here it
is going to the homepage and this is
very simple uh nabar now as I already
told you multiple times when I created
this uh video this full video is
basically created in such way that
now as I already told you multiple times
before that the main objective of
creating this particular video is for
the reactj beginner developers so that
you you guys who don't have much
experience on reactj so that you'll be
able to Gras all this concept very
easily that is the reason whatever
project that I have chosen in this full
course or basically full video this
projects will be very very simple all
right now don't expect too much
complicated CSS or very large amount of
Cs is because the prime objective of
this particular video is to learn how
you can apply react Concepts and create
multiple different kind of projects with
a minimal uh styling or basically
minimum minimal use of CSS all right so
that is the reason we are not going to
use much
CSS so this is all about the nap section
that we need in the next video what we
need to do we have to handle this input
and then whenever I'll enter something
we have to basically call the API and
based on that we'll be getting the list
of recipes here so let's work on this uh
particular functionality in the next
part all right everyone so now let's
start uh handling this input form so for
this one what we're going to do so there
are two ways we can manage the state
either we can create a context or we can
basically manage uh in this app.js and
then we have to basically pass uh all of
these as a prop to each and every
individual component all right so let's
do one thing let's create our first
context so in this um project only or
basically most of the projects we are
going to create a context and that that
is basically more cleaner way to manage
your state so what I'll do I inside this
Source I'll create another folder and
let's give this on name as context and
here I'll create index. jsx now the
first thing is that what you need to do
first you have to create the context and
then you have to basically provide the
context and then you have to consume the
context or basically state from the
context first I'll do I'll create the
context so this will be export const
let's give this one name as Global
context and this will be create context
and here you have to basically give the
default value or basically the initial
value which will be null all right now
what I'll do I'll just do here export
default uh this will be export default
function this will be our Global State
now this Global state will receive the
children now children is basically all
the nested components that you are
having in this particular
application so this will be our children
and here what we need to return We to
basically return Global context now this
context will give you this provider now
this provider will basically provide the
state and then you have to basically
consume the state from this context and
here you have to basically pass the
children now this is very very easy to
do all right now how you will be able to
access this so in a root component you
have to basically Wrap This Global State
inside your app component as simple as
that so let's go to our index.js and
here what we can do we can simply import
uh Global state here and you have to
paste it here so that means what you are
doing basically here you are um uh sorry
you are basically accessing this app
inside This Global state so whatever
state you are managing from this context
you will be able to access in this app
component Now app component is basically
at the is the combination of all the Ned
components that you are having all right
now here what I'm going to do first I'll
create our first it and this will be our
search
panm and this will be set
search Parn and this will be use state
of empty all right but how you are going
to pass this state to your context so
what you need to do you have to copy
this both so this is aate variable in
the uh set State method this provider
will take a value property and this will
be object and here you will be able to
basically pass this uh value or
basically the state in in this context
so now what we need to do we have to
basically go to a na
because here we are having this input
all right now here let's say you are to
basically give the value and the on
change so what you need to do to
basically consume this from your context
in this component so what we need to do
first we have to basically
take use context hook now this basically
will accept a context object and this
will basically return the current
context value and from there you will be
able to basically get the state values
or basically the methods so I'll take
use context and here you have to
basically pass the context so in our
case the context is basically This
Global context that we have created so
here we'll do Global context now here
now what we need to access you will be
able to access all of these so now let's
say I want to access both search for and
the set search for so I'll copy this and
I'll pass it here so that means what we
are doing from this Global context using
this hook we are accessing this uh
parameters now what we can do we can
simply pass the value property which
will be our search PM and on change here
I'll take event and here what we can do
we'll simply do set search Pam equal to
event. target. value and this is
done now let's see if I now log this
search param
here sorry so if I log this search P I'm
here let's see what we getting so I'll
go
back now let's go to our console let's
I'll type something here my name so you
can see that we are getting the updated
name here all right so now what we need
to do we are getting the uh whatever
user is typing here so if I now click
enter I need to basically call the API
and based on the app to basically list
the list of recipes based on what user
has entered here so let's do that in the
next part all right so now what we need
to do on submit of this form we have to
basically get this search param value
and then based on that you have to call
the
API all right so now what we can do uh
let's do one thing let's take one on
submit here and this will be handle
submit now this one we are going to
basically receive from this context only
now let's save it now what we'll do
we'll basically create this method here
so this will be asnc function handle
submit and here we are going to
basically pass this handle submit
method now here what we'll do we'll
basically take a try block here we'll do
catch
and we'll just log this error here so
here what we're going to do this will be
const response AIT F and here we have to
basically call this uh URL so here what
we'll do we basically copy this path and
then you'll paste it here now here uh
along with this you have to basically
pass the search value now this search
value will be basically I hope for now
we'll be getting this is basically this
search F whatever we are entering that's
it now this will be const data this will
be AIT race. Json now let's log this uh
data here let's see what we are
getting all right now let's save it now
here what we'll do we'll basically type
something like banana and let's hit
enter all right another thing we need to
do we have to basically take our event
here and and we'll do here event.
prevent uh
default all right so now let's see so
now here we'll type for uh Apple hit
enter and we getting the data here so
you can see that we are getting success
status data and inside this we're
getting recipes awesome so now what we
need to do to basically take a state and
then you have to save this recipes and
we have to basically render the list of
recipes in this component so let let's
do that in the next part all right so
now let's do one thing uh here we will
take another state so the first thing
we'll uh take our loading State also I
think this also we have done in the
previous uh projects so we'll basically
check until unless the API is getting
loaded so we'll show some kind of loader
so this will be use state of false and
we'll take another state here and this
will be our recipe
list set recipe list and this will be uh
used Straight of Mt now what we are
going to do we will basically check here
uh that if data
dot so what we are getting so we are
getting here let me just check we having
data do data do recipes so if data dot
data dot
recipes so we are going to basically uh
do here this data do data do is also
you're going to make the set loading as
false and also we'll do set search param
as empty so you're going to basically
empty this search uh or reset this
values whatever we are typing here
that's it if there are any kind of error
so what we'll do we'll do the same thing
we'll reset this one and also make the
set loading as false all right now this
is done now next thing what we'll do uh
so first let's see what exactly we are
getting in this so if I now log this
loading and recip list let's
see so we'll be getting empty for now
but let's type something here let's hit
enter and we getting here you can see
the 22 results all right so now what we
need to do to basically render this list
of
recipes what we'll do first thing we
will will pass this uh
loading and also this recipe list
here all right now let's save it so now
this recip list will will be receiving
in our home component so we'll go to
this home component here now we'll
understand the advantage of using
context so from any component you will
be able to basically manage the state
globally now here what we'll do we'll
basically take our recip list so we'll
do uh use context and this this will be
of global context all right uh so let me
just import it I think we can go to this
component and let's copy this and paste
it
here
okay so here we'll receive our recipe
list and also receive our loading all
right that's it now here what we are
going to do uh we'll take a class name
so we'll do a class name we'll do py of
8 we'll do container we do MX of Auto
we'll do Flex Flex WP justify Center and
we'll do gap of
10 all right now inside this uh what we
do we'll basically check if this recip
list and and recip list do length
greater than Z zero so we going to
render or else this will be
null and here uh what we will do
basically we will just map it and we'll
create another recipe component so
inside this uh component I'll create
another folder and this will be our
recipe uh recipe list something like
that all right so here will be index.
jsx and this will be export
default function this will be recipe
list and here I'll return here div or
let's make this one as recipe item not
recip
list so this will be recip item and here
I'll return recipe item now here what we
will do recipe list. map so here I'm
going to just render this recipe item
component and I'll pass this item as a
prop to this
component so we'll copy this and this we
are going to receive it
here another thing what we can do we can
basically check if loading is true so
you're going to return something like
div and this will be
loading please
wait that's
it all right now here uh instead of
showing null we can do another thing uh
if that is no recipe that means if the
length is zero so show something like
nothing uh nothing to show please search
something or something like that so
we'll take another paragraph here we'll
do nothing to
so please
search something and here I'll use a
class name so we'll do
large text for Xcel do
text Excel will do text
Center we'll do text black and we'll do
font
Bolder extra
Bolder all right now let's save it let's
see what is happening now awesome so now
we're getting nothing to so please
search something if I now search
something so you're getting 1 2 3 4 how
many items are there that we are getting
if I saw Apple so getting more items if
I saw something else let's say m go we
are getting the data here so now we have
to basically start working on this
creating the structure so that means
this is working fine all right so now
let's do one thing uh let's go to this
uh recipe item component now here what
we'll do we'll keep it very simple so
you're receiving single recipe here so
let's take a class name so we'll do this
one as
Flex Flex call W8 we'll do overflow
hidden
we'll do p of five we do BG white ided
by 75 we'll do sadow Xcel we'll do gap
of five we'll do border uh we'll do
border
two uh we'll do
rounded uh we'll do rounded to XEL we'll
do border
white all right let me just remove this
now inside this we'll take another
div we'll take a class name we'll do
height of 40 we'll do Flex justify
Center L overflow hidden item Center and
we'll do rounded
Excel all right now here I'm going to
take a image so we are going to render
The Source here so this will be our item
this item that we are receiving dot we
this will give give us item uh sorry
image URL also we going to use all this
will be our
recip item and class name will do block
and W uh
full that's it let's save it let's see
what we
getting awesome so you're getting the
result here you can see
that now next thing uh what we can do
sof this uh we'll take another div here
uh inside this will take a span sorry
this will be
span and here I'm going to render this
item dot
publisher and here we are going to use a
class name so Lo text as Lo
text uh how much
700 is fine and we'll do font medium
let's save it let's see
see I think we have done something
[Music]
wrong okay this is
wrong okay now next uh what we'll do uh
we'll take another A3 and here I'm going
to render item dot
title all right and here we'll use a
class name we'll do font bold
uh we'll do text 2
XEL we'll do
tranet text
black that's it and after this we are
going to import link from RE router Dom
and here we'll be showing something like
recipe
details and here we'll basically have to
give two now here it is very important
now where it should go it should go to
the dynamic uh page that we have created
so how we are going to do this we'll do/
recipe item slash and here we have to
basically pass the ID of this item so
this will be item.
ID all right and here we are going to
use this class name so we'll use uh text
SM P of three and padding PX of 8 we'll
do rounded
large uh we'll do
uppercase we'll do font
medium we'll do
tracking wider we'll do inline block
we'll do sadow
medium we'll do BG black and we'll do
text as
white that's it let's save it let's see
all right this is fine let's take a
margin top of
five awesome so this is looking very
nice and if you notice if I now click
here it will go to the dynamic P so
let's say click here see now it is going
to this page and this is the ID if I now
go back click here this is now different
ID if you noticed if I click here this
is now different and now type something
here so you're getting related to Apple
all right and
uh uh let's say search for mango so now
we're getting related to mango so this
is working fine now what we need to do
basically on click of this whenever
we'll go to this Details page we have to
get this ID and once we'll receive this
ID based on this ID you have to again
call the API and then you have to
basically render the details here so
let's do that in the next part all right
so let's start uh working on this
Details page so how we are going to do
so on click of this first it is going to
The Details page so let's go to this
Details page now what we need to do we
basically need to extract this ID from
this
URL how we are going to do that so for
this one we will be importing one Hook
from De router
Dom all right so let's go here so now
let's do one thing here I'll take const
params equal to use params now this
params will basically give you sorry
will give you all the details if I now
log this params
here let's see what is happening if I
now go back let's refresh this
page
now I'll open console let's search
something all right now if I click here
see we are getting ID now this ID is
basically the Val the par name and the
this is the value now from where this is
coming this is coming from this ID name
that you have given here this is the
dynamic value so now this is pretty
simple so what you can do you can take
use effect here and then we can
basically call the API but before that
let's do another thing so we go to our
context and I'll take another state here
so this will be const recipe
details dat data set recipe details uh
data and this will be equal to UST state
of
null now I'll copy
this and then we'll pass it
here let's format this
now go to our Details page and here
first we are going to import this one
from our context so this will use
context of global context all right so
now we'll do use
effect and
here uh what we'll do we will basically
uh create a method here so let's create
aing method Asing function
get
recipe
details and here here we will create
this one so this will be const response
equal to
AIT F and we are going to use the same
URL that we are using there will be some
difference so let me first copy this
sorry copy this paste it here so only
difference will be after recipes we have
to basically pass the ID so here we'll
do recipes slash and here we to pass the
ID this ID will be basically this params
do ID so you remember we are getting
this params do ID so what we'll do we
can simply destructure this ID from this
params and then we'll basically pass
this ID here and this is done now we'll
do const data equal to AIT response.
Json and now let's log this data here
and let's see what you're getting now
let's save it so you're getting some
error params is not defined fine so let
me remove
this so now if I now go
back uh let's search for
something and now let's say if I click
here all right we are not getting
anything I think the reason is because
what we can do we can basically give
this ID as a dependency here now this
would work oh sorry my bad we have to uh
basically invoke this method sorry now I
think this should work awesome so now
this is working although if you give
this ID as a dependency then also it
should work but on if you give empt
dependency also this would work fine I
now let's say go back uh let's say try
for this one so you're getting the data
here all right so now this is pretty
simple so what we can do we can
basically check here if this data do
data is true so we do set recip details
data is equal to data Dot
data that's it all right so now we have
to basically uh render the uh jsx
structure so now the first thing what we
can
do
here let me just cut
it so we return one
div let's take a class name so here I'll
do
container this will be MX
Auto py of 10 look
grid grid calls of one for large you'll
do
grid Columns of two and we do gap of
10 now inside this we'll take a div
we'll take a class name we'll do this
one as row start two for large we'll do
row start
Auto and here we are going to basically
render the image so we'll do another
div we'll give a class class name so
we'll do height of
96 we'll do overflow as hidden we'll do
rounded Excel and we'll do as
group now inside this we'll take
image so we do source which will be
our recipe details data do image
URL and here we are going to take a
class last name so we'll do W full
height full we'll do object cover block
we'll do here uh we'll do a take a group
hover and we'll do a scale of
105 and we'll do a duration of
300 let's save
it let's see what is happen happening
let me just refresh
this all right we are not getting
anything let me just log it here let's
see what is happening
here so what we are getting in this
recip details data all right so we have
dot recip here okay now I got it so what
we need to do we have to do dot here dot
recipe now this would
work awesome now you can see that this
scaling is also happening and if I now
go back search for
something and let's say if I click here
so now getting the different data if I
click this one we getting the updated
data here all
right this is fine now next uh what we
are going to do so after this we'll take
another div here we'll take a class name
we'll do Flex uh we'll do Flex column
and gap of
three here we'll do a
span and here we'll do recipe details
data do
recipe dot
publisher all right and let's use the
same styles that we are using here so
for this one also we'll use the same
let's copy
this and we'll paste it
here and also we'll do the same thing
for this this one also the title so
we'll copy this one and after that we'll
paste the same
here let's save it let's see what we
getting all right so we have to change
this on item is not defined so we'll
just replace this
one okay so you're getting the name uh
this is fine now next uh what we are
going to do here uh let's take another
div
here
so this is our main
div okay after this or let's take it
here so we'll take another div
here and here we'll take a
button and this will be our save as
favorites okay and here we'll take a
class name so we'll do a p of
three ex off I think for this one also
you'll use the same class name let
me uh let me write it down we'll do
rounded large I'm very lazy of writing
this much CSS to be honest text SM then
we are having upper case
font
medium then we are having
tracking
wider we'll do a margin top of three
we'll do inline
block
we'll do sadow as medium we'll do BG
black and we'll do text as uh
White that's
it all
right now let's save
it for let's see first how this is
looking okay so you're having save as
favorites this is fine now what else we
can do so we can also render the
ingredients so after this div
let's take another div
here so here I'll take a span and we'll
do
ingredients all
right so here let's take a class name we
do text 2 XL font semi
bold all right text
black now after this span we'll take
e we take take a class name and here
we'll do Flex Flex column gap of three
and here we are going to basically
render the ingredients so this will be
recipe uh details dot recipe dot uh here
to do ingredients
ingredients do map this will be
ingredient and here I'm going to render
AI
all
right now inside this we'll take a span
here and let's render the
ingredient dot
quantity sorry this will be
Dot and then we'll give a space and this
will be
ingredient uh dot unit all
right and after this span we'll take
another span here and we'll render
ingredient dot
description all right let's format
this uh what else for this one also we
use the same class name so we copy this
one and we'll use here and also here
sorry what I have done sorry not here to
do it here
let's
see okay so now we are getting all of
this that these all are the ingredients
this uh you will be able to save as
favorites if I now go back uh let's say
I'll click on this one so now we're
getting the updated data if I click this
one we are getting the data
here let's see if I search for
mango and let's click here so now we're
getting related to Mango and this is
working fine so now next thing what we
need to do on click of this basically we
have to store this in our favorite
section so that one we going to do in
the next part all right so let's start
working on this favorite functionality
so the first thing is that what we are
going to do we'll go to our context and
then we'll take another state here and
this will be our favorites favorite list
favorites
list and set
favorite list and this will be us state
of Mt
ARR now let's copy
this uh or let's do one thing we can do
another thing
here we can create a method here and
this will be handle add to
favorite and this will basically receive
the current
item
okay so if I now log this here let's see
what is happening so I'll just copy this
sorry I'll just copy this method handle
add to favorite and I'll pass in our
context now we'll go to our Details page
and here you can see that we are having
this save as faites this is the button
so here on click of this we will
basically call this method so now we'll
do on click and here we'll basically
invoke this method and we'll pass this
recipe item details. recip as a
parameter which is basically our current
item
I hope you're getting if I now save this
now let's go
back now let's go to console if I now
click here see now we getting the
current data here right now here we'll
be able to get the ID and based on that
we'll be able to see whether this item
is already added in the favorites or not
as simple as that so now we can go to
our context and now what I'll do the
first thing is that uh we'll do copy uh
favorite uh favorites list and this will
be our
favorites now we'll do we'll check the
index so we'll do here copy favorite
list do find index and we'll do item if
this item. ID is equal toal to get
current item. ID that means whether the
item is already present in this array or
not if index is
minus1 that means the item is not
present so we'll do copy favorite list.
post and we'll PST this current item
else what we need to do we'll do copy
favorites and then we'll just splice
this index that means we'll remove if
the item is already present and at the
end we'll just do set favorite list
equal to copy favorite list now let's
log this favorite list and let's see
what we are
getting so now if I now go back here so
we are getting empty click here so one
item is there if I now again click you
can see now this is empty again so that
means this is now removed okay so now
what we can do we can pass this favorite
list in our context so this is the first
step and we are already having this
favorite component so what we going do
in this home component the structure
that whatever we are having this will be
similar exact similar to here so what we
can do we can simply copy this whole
part from here
and then you can simply paste it here
now there are some changes we need to do
so the first thing is that this will be
favorites list instead of recipe list
loading is not
required and here this will be favorite
list and here we will show nothing to
added uh nothing is
added nothing is added in
favorites that's it and this is done if
I now save this so you're getting some
error recipe item is not defined let me
just import this one so now this is fine
again we are getting some error Global
context is not defined and use context
is not defined okay so now let's say if
I now click here let's go to our
favorites we are getting one favorite
here let's go to our home all right wait
because we not storing this one in any
store or basically in database that is
the reason but this is fine now let's
click on here click on save to favorites
go to favorites we are getting two let's
go to home go
here click here go to favorites we are
getting
three all right let's click on this
one click
here and you can see that we are getting
this one for items now one thing we need
to do basically if I now click here we
have to because this is already added so
so if you see banana cookies is already
added so it show here remove from
favorites so how we are going to do that
so let's copy this favorite list and
then uh what we can do go to our
details so first thing we'll basically
take from here and then we'll go to our
button and here basically what we'll
do we'll simply check that uh what we
can do so we do here
favorites all right
um dot so we'll do find
index and here we'll do item so we do
item do ID is equal to equal to this uh
recipe Item recipe. ID so that means if
that this is already present or not if
this is not equal to equal to minus1 so
that means this is already present so
this will be remove from
favorites or this will be add two
favorites that's it so now let's format
this and here we can do something like
if this
length now do length is greater than
zero let's save it let's see what is
happening so now getting removed from
favorites because banana cookies is
already present now let's go to our home
so let's click on this Banana Foster
so now this is coming add to favorites
if I now click here now remove to
favorites go to here Banana Foster if I
now go
back let's click here add to favorite if
I now go back this is now removed all
right so now obviously this is not like
a very big project but this will give
you a idea that how you can work with
routing how you can create multiple
Pages how you can create context and
manage Global State and also lot of
other functionality also obviously what
we can do we can see use very easily
basically store this one in in a
database so that on page refresh this uh
doesn't like if I now refresh this page
obviously this data will not be there
but this is fine because this is a
static website this will definitely help
you to understand lot of things now
let's do one thing let's go to our home
another thing whenever we type something
here let's navigate to the homepage so
this is one very important thing that uh
come to my mind so what we can do simply
uh something like let's go to our uh
where we can go
context so here uh we'll do const
navigate equal to use
navigate and whenever we'll enter here
we'll navigate to the
homepage so this is another important
thing so now let's say if I type
something here
Apple let's go to our Reb details add to
favorites go to favorites now let's say
type something here banana so it's going
back to this page all right now click
here add to
favorite let's go here click
here uh search for
mango click
here this is coming now let's click this
one all right let's go back one
more so now this is
added if I now go back remove this one
this is now removed all right so that's
all for this particular video now see
you in my next video now in the next
video we are going to create many more
uh very interesting project see you in
my next video till then good luck and
peace hey everyone so let's start
working on our shopping cart application
so in this application the only
difference will be here we are going to
use Redux toolkit so this is the
speciality of this particular project so
this is very very simple as you can see
we will be fetching the data from the
API where we'll be getting the list of
products from fake store API then on
click of this this will be added to cart
now if I go to cart obviously this will
be added and this amount will be updated
now you may think that this is a very
simple project but actually for a
beginners or if you think about from
interview perspective this is not a
simple project if they give you two
hours to code this one you have to do it
in that time so let's if I go here and
then add this one also so you can see
that this is updated if I try to remove
this will be updated so for this one I
have chosen Tailwind CSS and Redux
toolkit for this particular project so
that in case you face or basically
interfere will ask you that whether you
have worked with Redux or not so this
project will definitely going to help
you so let's start working on this
particular project all right everyone so
let's start working on our shopping cut
project so first thing you can see that
I already created one project here so
here first we will be basically
installing all the dependencies that we
need and also we need to install
Tailwind CSS because that one we are
going to use for our
styling so first we'll start with tellin
CSS so to install what you need to do
you have to basically install as a dep
dependency so you're going to copy this
and then we'll paste it
here so once this will be installed then
we have to basically in it and then we
have to give some the some of the
configuration that you need for this
particular project all right so this is
done now let's init this one so if I do
npx in it so it will basically create a
uh file here for the
configuration and then what we need to
do basically we have to give this
content that we are using because we
using react so this will be either JS
jsx TS or TSX so you'll copy
this and let's go here and then we'll
paste inside this content and the last
step will be we have to import this base
Utilities in the index. CSS so go to the
index. CSS and we are going to paste it
here that's it so this is all the
configuration that we need for the
Tailwind SES and now coming to the uh
packages so we are going to use Redux
toolkit so the first thing we need to
install Redux
j/
toolkit all right next we need react
Redux we need react
icons we also need react router
Dom and also you're going to use another
one that will be react loader
spinner so this is basically to S any
kind of uh loading State and I think
that's
it all right so
now let it uh be installing so now we'll
do one thing let's quickly create all
the components and the pages that we
need
so first I'll be creating a Pages folder
and then I'll be creating a components
folder and then I'll be creating another
folder and this will be our store so
store is basically our Redux store so
here we will be creating all the slice
and our main configuration for the
store all right now what else we need so
inside this page we basically need two
pages so one will be homepage and one
will be a cart page so in the homepage
we'll be getting the list of I think I
already showed you in the demo we'll be
getting the list of products and in the
cart page we'll be showing how many
products we have added in the cart so
I'll be creating two pages here so I'll
create home.
jsx and then I'll be creating card.
jsx so let's quickly create the
components uh sorry the pages first and
then we'll be uh first uh uh
implementing the react router Dom or
basically the
routing so let me just close everything
so here let's create this cart
component so function this will be our
cart and we are going to return some div
for now and this will be our
card let's save it let's create our
homepage so this will be export default
function this will be
home and we are going to return here div
and this will be our
homepage all right right now we need to
import this one in our app.js now
because we need to switch from one page
to another page so we definitely need
react router D basically routing
functionality so the first thing first
thing what we need to do you have to
import the browser router here and let's
do one thing let's remove this react.
strict mode this we don't
need and here I'm going to import
browser router from react router Dom and
then I'm going to paste it this this app
here that's it now let's go to our
app.js now let me just remove everything
from
here let's remove this class name also
now here what we need we basically need
the routes so we'll import routes from
react rout them so this will work as a
switch all right now here what we are
going to do the first thing is that we
will be having a common napar component
so let's say I'll be having a nap bar
here so this will be my napar
and then inside this we need to create
all the routes so for now we are having
only two pages so we'll create two route
so we'll import
route and here I'll give
exact and here I'm going to use a path
which will be slash and I'll be passing
element which will be basically our
component this is our home
component so let's copy
this and here we need card and this will
go to to the card
page let's save it now let's remove this
logo so now let's go to this page so you
can see that we're getting naar home if
I try to go to/
card so going to the cart page and abar
is basically common for both the uh
pages so this is working fine so now
what will be our next step so next step
will be let's implement this napar
component first or basically the header
component so we go here so you're having
this reusable components so inside this
component I'll be creating a folder so
let's create the folder and let's give
this on name as we'll give this one name
as a header only and inside this I'll
create index.
jsx all right so now let's quickly
create this so this will be export
default function
header now let's return a
div so this will be D
leave all right inside this so let's
take a uh we'll do another thing we'll
take a nav
here and we'll give a class name here so
we'll give
Flex items Center
justify between height of 20 we give Max
W 6xl and MX of
Auto inside this we are importing link
from react router
Dom and here in this link component we
have to give a two property so it will
go to the slash or basically the
homepage on click of this inside this
I'll take another div let's take a class
name we'll take a margin left of
five and inside this I'll take H1 and
let's give this one name as react
Redux shopping
card and here I'm going to use a class
name so we'll give text uh red 900 font
bold we'll give text transparent L to
text Excel we do for SM we'll do
text uh 2
XEL for MD we'll do text 3 XEL we'll do
cursor
pointer and we'll do
tracking wide uh tracking wider or let's
make this one
wide let's format this let's save it now
we are going to import this header
component in our
app.js so here we'll import this
header let's save
it let's see what is happening all right
so we are getting this one so here what
we can do we can also I think this is
fine for now uh now after this link so
let's go to our header component so
we'll take another
div and here we'll take a class name
we'll make this on
Flex uh we'll do
list I think this is not required we'll
do item
Center we do space X of uh let's make
this one six we do text Gray
800 all right and we'll do font semi
Boldt inside this we'll take another
link so this will again will be
two
slash and here what we'll do we'll take
a paragraph and we'll make this one as
home or let's do one thing let's make
this one as a
ul and we'll do this one as
Ali and here we are going to do a class
name uh we will do so for this one I
think we need list
none for this lii uh we will do a cursor
pointer and I think that's fine so we
having one home next we will take we'll
copy this and we paste it here this will
be SL
card and
here what we can do we'll simply render
this card here let's save this and let's
see what is
happening so we giving uh getting here
this is
fine but for this one also I think we
can have to give
list none all right so there was some
error actually the Tailwind was actually
not applying so I just restart the
project so it's now coming fine but I
think we are not able to see this text
so I think the reason is we have given
text
transparent uh we don't have to give uh
let me just remove this one from here we
already using this text
here H okay so now this is fine so now
next thing what we going to do so now if
I click here you can see that it's going
to the cart page if I click here going
to the
homepage and if I click here also it's
going to the homepage so now we have to
start working on the home component so
to First list uh the list of products or
whatever that we want to fetch and then
after that we'll be start working on the
Redux tool kit part so let's get started
so the first thing is that let's go to
our
homepage and or or else we can do
another
thing or I think for now this is fine uh
let's keep this one simple so we'll take
uh two State here so one will be our
products and another one will be set
products and this will be used state of
empty array and then we'll be having our
pending state or let's make this on
loading set
loading which will be used state of
false and we'll take use
effect and
here we are going to fet the list of
products we'll do fet list of
products so this will be syc function
Fage list of
products this will be const response AIT
Fage and here we are going to use this
URL which will be fake store API so this
is f store
api. com/
products here we'll be having data
again the same thing which will be have
it race.
Json all right now before this one let's
make this set loading as
true and
here we will do if this data is true so
we'll do set loading as
false and we'll do set product as this
data that's it all right so now the
first thing is that let's remove this
part from here so we'll check if this
loading is true so you want to basically
render some kind of uh loader so I think
for this one we have already installed
this react uh loading spinner so that
component only we are going to use so
let's do one thing let's take a div here
or else let's make this one null for now
leter change this and here we'll do
class name which will be mean height
screen
we do W full
Flex justify
Center and item
Center here I going to import these
circles from react loader spinner you
can go to the official website and you
can also check but this is pretty simple
you just have to import the spinner that
you want to use you to give a height
property I'll give this one
120 uh sorry let's make this one like
this then we having width I'll take one
20 we'll take a color we'll do
RGB 127 comma 29 comma
29 then what else we need we'll do
visible as
true all right so now let's save it
let's see what is
happening awesome so you can see that we
are getting this
one loader and it's working fine so now
next thing what we are going to do we
have to basically render the list of
products so for this one let's create
another component inside this and I'll
give this one name as
product
tile and we'll do index.
jsx so here let's create export default
function this will be our product tile
which will receive the
product single product basically from
the pattern component and here for now
I'm going to return a simple div and
let's uh return product item uh we'll do
this one single product
item awesome so now here if loading is
false that means we got the data so
we'll do a
div and here we'll first do a class name
we'll do mean
height of uh let's make this one as a 80
VH we'll do grid we'll do SM grid calls
of two for MD we'll do grid Columns of
three we'll do space X of
five space y of
10 for large we are going to do grid
Columns of
4 we'll do Max
W 6 XL we'll do MX Auto and we'll do
padding of
three all right inside this we are going
to check if these products that means
these products that we are having from
the API and and products. length if this
is true we are going to render the
products or else we'll render null so
here I'll do products. map so this is
our product item and now what we need to
return we need to Simply return this
product tile component and here we need
to pass this product which will be this
product item as simple as that so now
format this let's save it let's see what
is happening so you can see that we are
getting single product item I don't know
why this is going on top this part we
need to check okay fine first let's see
what is happening first let's quickly
start working on this component then
we'll see if there are any issue in the
CSS all right so let's go here here so
we go to a product
tile all right so now the first thing is
that let's remove this we'll take
another
div and here we'll take a class
name what we'll do here we'll do this on
Groove Flex Flex column we'll do item
Center we'll do border of two we'll do
border red 900 we'll do Gap of three
padding of four height of uh how much
let's make this 360
PX margin top of 10 margin left of five
and we'll do rounded
Excel inside this we'll take another div
and here we'll do a class name we'll do
height of
180px now here we are going to render
image which we will get from this
product all right so in this Source we
are going to pass this
product do image we'll do
alt uh which will be product.
title we'll do a class name we'll do
this one as object
cover height of full and width of
full let's format this let's save it
let's see what is happening
okay this is
fine this part we need to check why this
is coming on top this is weird all right
so let's fix this one I think this is
coming because of this uh let me go here
I think this is because of this space
issue here let me just remove this I
think this is not
required okay so now this is fine so now
let's uh add some title and also a
button for add to card and then remove
item so we'll go to this page so after
this image let's do this div and after
this we'll take another div here let's
take a H1 and we'll just render this
product
dot title and here we'll give a class
name so we'll do sorry we'll do class
name for this
H1 so we'll do width of 40 we do trunet
uh what else we'll do margin top of
three do text Gray 8 uh 700 we'll do
font bold and we'll do text
large let's save this let's
see awesome now next uh so after this uh
we'll take another
div and we'll make this on class name as
Flex we'll do item as Center we'll do
justify between W full and we'll do Mt
of five that means margin top all right
now here basically we need to show if
the product is already added in the card
so we show remove item or else we'll
show add to card but because we now
haven't created any functionality
something like that so for now we'll
just add one
button and we'll do add to
cut and also let's take a class name for
this button so we'll do BG red
950 uh we'll do text of white we'll do
border
of two we'll do border uh no sorry this
is fine we'll do a
rounded
large we'll do font semi bold for this
one or let's make this one bold only and
then we'll do padding of
food let's save it let's
see
okay this is fine all right so now uh
let's do another thing we'll do justify
Center instead of
between okay so now this is fine all
right so now we have render we'll go to
card we'll come back here so data is
coming so now let's start working on the
Redux part so the main idea of this
particular project is to that so that
you guys have some idea on how to
integrate Redux to because I think for
now these many projects that we have
done so we know how to phase data and
also how you can integrate Redux uh
sorry reactor out Dom and Implement
routing functionality so it this project
basically will give you very basic idea
of Redux tool kit and now the reason why
you should always start with the very
basic because even if the project is
complicated you will be able to easily
do that so that's the reason your basic
has to be very very clear now to start
working on the Redux part the first
thing is that Redux is basically a
global store management uh sorry Global
State Management Library something like
context so you'll keep your state in one
place so that you will be able to use
this uh State anywhere you want
basically so that is the main idea of
this so the first thing is that what we
need to do now in the Redux the concept
is basically you will be creating slices
for each and every each and every
component or Pages you can say let's say
we are having a cart here so we are
going to create a cart slices which will
consist of the accents and the reducer
and your state basically and now we have
integrated this sorry we have installed
this react Redux uh package so that will
basically connect your react application
with Redux store and then using
different hooks you will be able to
basically extract those States from your
Redux store so here I'm going to create
our
index.js sorry this will be
index.js and here I'm going to create
the store but before that you have to
create the slices so I'll create here
slice this and inside this uh I'll
create another uh let's do one thing
let's give a name of card slice. JS all
right now how we are going to create the
slice so the first thing is that so the
process is like first you have to import
the create slice method then you have to
basically your
initialize the initial
state
so which you will be basically
manipulating and then you will be
getting the updated State back then
you'll be creating your slice using this
create slice you have to give a
name you will be creating uh you have to
basically mention the initial
State and you'll be creating all the
accents here and at the end you have to
import those accents and those accent
you will be using in your component so
first let's import something
from uh Redux toolkit and this is called
create
slice all right so you can see that this
you have to basically
use which will generate the accents
Creator and accents types that
correspond correspond to reducer and
your state now I'll be creating my cart
slice so here you have to take this
create slice
and then you to basically give a name so
I'll give a name of
card you to mention the initial State
you can see that it will take anyal
state so we'll be creating this one in a
minute and now after this you have to
create your reducers so for now this is
fine and now let's create our initial
state so we'll do const initial state
which will be empty so this initial
State you using here all right now what
we going to do we will be simply
also here you have to give the reducers
which will be object and here you'll be
creating all the accents so for now this
is fine so now what we going to do we
just do export default then you're
having this cart sl.
reducer that's it all right let's format
this let's save it so now we have to
basically create our Global store just
like we usually create Global uh global
Global context so we go to our index.js
and here we have to create this store
now you obviously will be able to
combine multiple slices for now we are
having only one slice that is fine let's
say we having 100 slice so you will be
able to import all the slices in your
Global State and that will combine and
create a one single uh state so the
first thing is that to create this one
you have to import something
from Redux j/ toolkit which is called
configure store all right you can see
that now here we are going to create so
we do const
store which will be configured
store and this will basically take a
reducer property and here you will be
able to combine multiple reducers and
this is very very important so now let's
say you are giving a name so I'll give a
cart as a name so I want to import the
cart reducer
now you'll see here in this card slice I
uh default exported this reducer so I
will be able to import this cart
reducer
from the slices SLC slice so this will
be my cart reducer let's see you are
having a 100 reducer here so you will be
importing your next reducer let's say
some dummy
reducer from some dummy
slice and then you have to give the name
here dummy which will be your dummy
reducer something like that so like that
it will basically combine all of these
for now we don't have so we'll remove
this one and at the end we are going to
do export default this
store all right so this is fine so now
how you will be able to combine this one
or basically use these features of Redux
in your react project so the answer is
in your index.js if you remember just
like we import Global context here you
have to import this store in this
component and you have to basically pass
it in the root level so that you will be
able to access all the properties from
here but how you are going to do that so
to do this one you have to import some
component from your react Redux so here
basically this react Redux will comes
into picture which will combine your
react and Redux both together
and now I'll do basically cut it from
here and this will take a store property
which will be your store just now we
have created basically this store here
and that's it so now let's save it so
now this will basically generate your
store now what we want to do we want to
basically create a functionality that I
on click of this I want to add this
product uh and then I want to store this
product data in my cart slice
so let's see how we are going to do that
so now to do this one we will be
creating method inside this reducer so
here so here let's say I want to create
add property or let's say do add to
cart all right and this will be a method
now this will take a state and also it
will take accent and now what we want to
do we will simply do state which is your
current state dopus and I want to add
this accent. payload that I'll be
passing from this component so this is
your one add to cut functionality now
how you are going to access this to
access this one you just have to export
it so we do export con and here this
will be cart
slice dot accents so this is your one of
the accents that you are exporting add
to cut so now what you need to do I hope
you're getting so this method now you
have to call and then you have to
basically on click of this button you
have to push this data in this array
which is your initial State and this
will basically give you the updated
State
back now let's go to our this product.
GS component that you have created
product tile now here I'll be creating a
method so this will be my function and
this will be handle add to
cart all
right now this is the single product
that we are having but how you are going
to call this method so now this is the
point how you're going to call this
method from this component so here this
uh Hook from this react Redux will comes
into picture so this react Redux will
give you this particular hook that is a
dispatch hook so you have to first
import this one from react Redux and
this is called use dispatch so this will
dispatch a certain acction which will go
go to this slice it will check that okay
I called this action and it will do the
certain functionality here I hope you're
getting so now what you need to do first
you have to initialize this
one so use
dispatch now you have to
basically so you can see that this will
basically dispatch a acction all right
dispatch function so here you call this
dispatch and you call this add to card
from the card slice and then you have to
basically pass this payload so you can
see that it will take a payload and this
can be of any type for now you have to
pass this product because this is the
current product I want to
add that's it now this handle add to
cart I will give on click of this
button as simple as that now so let's
save it let's go to cart slice and let's
log this section
here and let's see what is happening
sorry what is
happening let's go to console I'll add
this one you're getting a type so this
is the type cart SL add to cart because
this is the accent name and in the
payload you're getting this information
if I click here you are getting this one
and then you are getting the current
product all right so now this will
basically update your state so we have
added this one to our state but how we
you are going to access it so to access
this one you have to basically use a use
selector hook so that is also from react
Redux so you selector will basically
give you the updated state from your
Redux store all right so let's see how
we are going to do that so to do this
one first thing is that we'll go to our
cart. JS file here and now uh so this is
the component let me just so here first
thing what if you need to do so the
first is basically we have to import the
state updated state to get the state
what we need to do first I'll show you
what we getting in the updated state so
you'll use this use selector from react
Redux which will basically give you the
updated state so here we'll get the
state and let me just log this state
here if I now save this now let's say
I'll add this one let's go to our card
so you can see that we are getting three
Arrow of three now because this okay one
is getting added two time that is fine
but you can see that we are getting add
of three and the data is updated and if
you notice here we are getting a card
here because this is the name of the um
slides that we have given here so what
we can do we can simply destructure this
cart from our state so we can simply do
here cart so that means we are getting
this one from our state so if I now log
this cart we'll see that we'll be
getting a arrow of three if I now go to
home and let's say if I I do add to cart
here and let's go to our cart now you're
getting four so this is getting
updated all right so now here what we
going to do we'll take another state and
that will be to combine all the total so
we'll do total
card set total
C this will be US state
of
zero and here we'll take use
effect
and here we'll keep this cart as a
dependency and we'll do set total cart
which will be simply cart do
reduce and this will be our current and
we'll simply add this account plus if
you go here you'll see that we getting
this price so we'll do uh uh accumulator
plus current dot price all right and we
can give this zero as initial value
that's it so now let's see what we
getting the total
cut so we getting fors 110 if I go back
here let's
add this one go to cart so you can see
that this is updated
now awesome so now we need to
basically uh start working on this cart
page but before that another very
important thing we need to do and that
is if this cut is already added this
item so we don't have to show add to cut
we'll be showing remove to cut and then
we we will not be able to basically add
it again we have to remove this so first
let's complete this functionality then
at the end we'll be uh working on the
card page so we will go to the product.
JS so let's go here which is our product
tile and here you can see that we doing
handle add to cut so the first thing is
that we will be first getting the list
of cart items so again we'll do const
we'll get cart and we'll get it from use
selector all right and now what we are
going to do we will basically check so
let's come here so we'll check if this
cart do sum that means if some of the
item are actually
present and here we will do this item do
ID is equal toal to current item which
is our product. ID that means this item
is already added so you don't have to
add it so here will basically show this
one as remove from cart or else this
will be add to cart so this is one thing
same if this is true so if this is true
so we don't have to do handle add to cut
we will basically do here handle
remove from
card or else this will be handle add to
cut and now let's create this function
so we do function and remove from
cart and then we'll uh do log and this
will be removed now let's see what is
happening if I go
back now let me first refresh
this okay so now here if I do here so
you can see that we're getting removed
from card but if I try to add again so
it is getting removed so not adding
anymore I'll go to cart only one item is
added if I do add to cut and go back
only two item and this is working fine
so now let's start working on this
remove from cart functionality so this
will be pretty simple so first we'll go
to our cart slice and again you have to
create another method just like you'll
do it in the context so we'll do remove
from cart which will take a state and
again also the accent and here we are
going to return state. filter which is
your basically current state and then we
are going to do item. ID is not equal to
equal to accent do
payload that means we are basically
filtering the current item on remove so
now what we need to do simply we can go
to our product tile so here we again do
dispatch and then we'll do remove from
card sorry we also have to basically
import it here export it so now let's go
here so we do remove from
card now what you need to pass you need
to pass a current ID so this will be
product. ID that's it so
now let's save
it so now let's add this one so go here
only one item go
back now click here again add to cut if
I now go back so this is empty and this
is working fine so now we have done till
this part so now let's start working on
our card
page so first we'll go to our card.
jsx let's close everything else and
here we'll first check if this
card and and card. length if this is
true so we are going to render so we'll
take a
div or else here we'll show like your
card is empty some something like that
so we'll show a div and we'll uh let's
give a class name here
first now let's make this one
div we do a class
name and here we are going to
use we'll do a mean height
of uh how much you do 8
VH we'll make this one
as Flex we'll do Flex column we'll do
item as Center and we'll do justify
Center all right inside this we will
take a H1 and render your card is
empty and here we'll add a class
name which will be text Gray
800 we'll do font
bold we'll do text Excel margin bottom
of
two that's it and then after this we'll
take a link
here so we'll do
import link
from react router Dom so you import
link so this will be two it will go to
homepage and here I'm going to import uh
sorry use a
button so we'll do sop
now and let's use the same style that we
are using here so this one copy this
sorry copy
this and we'll paste it
here let's save it let's see what is
happening awesome so if I click here
it's going back if I add this one and
let's go back so now we have to render
the list of cart items all right so
first we'll go back here all right so
here now we are going to render the list
of cart items so we'll take a class name
here
also and uh this one will
do mean height
of
VH we'll do grid we'll do for MD we'll
do
grid column of two we'll do Max
W 6 XL and we'll do MX
of
Auto all right now inside this we'll
take another
div we'll take a class
name so we'll do Flex Flex column we'll
do justify Center we do
items uh we'll do items what we can do
we'll do
items
Center and we'll do padding of
three now inside this we're going to
render the cart items we do card. map
this is our
card
item now we are going to return the cart
tile so here I'll create another
component and this will be our cart tile
let's create our index.
JX so this will be export default
unction this is our cart tile which will
receive the cart
item and here I'm going to return a div
and this will be our card
item so here I'm going to import this
cart tile which will take the cart item
which will be this cart item here this
one that's it all right so after this
div
so let's do one thing uh here let me cut
it so after this div we'll take another
div
here all right so here what we'll do
we'll take another div we'll take a
class name and we'll do Flex Flex column
we'll do justify Center we do items end
do p of five do space y of five and
margin top of
14 inside this we'll take a H1 and this
will be your
card
summary all right so let's take a class
name here so this will be font
bold uh we'll do text large and we'll do
text red
800 all right after this we'll take a
paragraph
inside this we'll take a span and this
will be our total
items and here we'll take a class
name so what we can do we do a text Gray
of 800 and font
bold all right and here we'll do take
another
span and this will be our
cart cart.
length all right
so after this
B uh we'll take another
paragraph and then we'll take another
spand let me just copy this from here
only so this will be our total
amount which will be this total amount
that we have
created sorry total
card and I think that's it so now let's
format and save this let's see how what
is happening
here all right so this is coming below
but that is fine that we are going to
check first let me just quickly create
this so let's go to our
home let's add this one let's go to cart
we're getting two let's add this one
let's go here we're getting three so now
let's quickly start working on this cart
item or basically cart tile so here I
remove
this so here we'll take a div we'll take
a class name we'll do Flex
item Center padding of five we'll do
justify between background red we'll
make this one as let's make 500 margin
top of two margin bottom of two and
we'll do rounded
Excel inside this we'll take another P
sorry div we'll take a class name we'll
make this one Flex padding of
three and we'll take a image here let's
take a source which will be cart item
dot this will be our
image we'll take a class name we'll do
height of
28 rounded
large and ALT of uh let's make this one
card item do
title all right inside this we'll take
another
div let's make a class name we'll do mL
of 10 we'll do self start we'll do space
y of five inside this we'll take a H1
and we'll render our cart item dot
Title Here Also we'll take a class name
so we do text Excel we'll do text
white and we'll do font
bold uh let's format
this all right so this is fine now after
this we'll render the price we'll take a
paragraph and we'll do
here sorry cart item do
price so we'll take a class name here
also we'll do text
white and font extra
bold awesome then after this we'll take
another
div or let's do one thing inside this
div we'll go to our product tile and I'm
going to copy copy this button from here
paste it here now on click I do handle
remove from
cart and this will be remove from cart
because here we will not be able to add
because this is in the cart page so this
will be removed from
cart and let me copy this and create
this function
here that's it so now let's format this
and let's save it let's see what is
happening
okay this is fine let me just check what
is happening
here okay I think here we can take a
display of flex
yes sorry this is in which one let me
check okay so we'll go to our card
page let me do class name of flex
here let me reduce this little
bit sorry not this one so we go here I
think here can make this one as 60 let's
see how this is looking you'll make with
as 200 PX let's make this one 300
sorry yeah so here what we can do we'll
take a class
name and and we'll do sorry we have we
have done mean height here not width so
we'll do a width of 300
PX so let's
see also this one we have to
make
Center to do justify content
Center so this this
is I
think so here I think we can make
justify
Center okay let's go to soop now let's
try to add this one let's go to
cut okay so now this is added here now
we have to also work on this remove from
cut so now this will be pretty simple we
can go to C tile now the first thing is
that we have to do dispatch
which will be our use
dispatch now I think you'll be able to
do it so just call this dispatch and
then you have to do remove from cart
from our cart slice and then you'll call
this cart item. ID so this ID you need
to pass that's it now let's save it now
let's see what is happening if I now see
now this is empty if I go here add 1 2 3
4 and five go to cart
so you can see that this is updated
total item is f don't worry about the
CSS this is fine we just have to check
the functionality whether this is
working or not so now I'll remove this
one from here so amount is updated
remove this one updated remove this one
this one if I remove here cart is empty
so now I think that's all for this
particular video I hope that you
understand how we need to basically use
Redux toolkit how to create the accents
how you can create a global store and
how to create the redu
how you can use use dispatch and use
selector hook to connect your react and
Redux project so I think that's all for
this particular project now let's move
on to the next one now next one will be
our last project and that is a monack
Blog application so we'll be creating
very simple blog application there will
be very very less CSS I'm again
explaining uh sorry mentioning this one
so the main functionality will be how
you can interact with a uh mongodb
database and how you can create a full
stack project from scratch so let's
start working on that particular project
all right everyone so let's start with
our expense tracker so here you can see
that for this particular project we are
going to use chakra UI as our CSS
utility framework you can say so we'll
be having simple onepage application and
on the left side you'll be able to see
the balance and then you'll be having
the expense and the income so and click
of this model will uh open and here you
will be able to add a income or expense
so let's I'll add a income and I need to
give the amount I'll choose income I'll
add this one so you can see that the
balance is now updated so this is a
chart that we are going to use for this
one we are going to use react Apex
charts and then if I add a expense so
let's say I add a 500 this will be
expense if I add this one so this is
updated here this is now updated so here
you'll be able to see that how much is
the balance so this will be very simple
project the main idea is behind that so
that you'll be able to use chakra UI if
you want to use particularly in your uh
like any project that you are currently
working or let's say you are giving an
interviewer and there is a requirement
that they want to know that whether you
will be able to use any CSS third party
packages or not so this is the main idea
so let's start working on this
particular project all right everyone so
let's start working on our expense
tracker project so for this one we are
going to use chakra UI uh so the reason
is because we are using different
different CSS uh packages uh in this
whole video so that you'll get idea of
each and everything if in case you are
facing these things in your interview so
the first thing is that you have to
install this one I already installed a
simple react project so I'm not not
wasting any time but by doing all of
this from scratch I I hope you're
getting this thing so first thing is
that we'll do uh let me just paste it
apart from this you also need react
icons and for this one we also need a
chart so we will be using this react
Apex charts so this is another another
package that we need to install and I
think this would be more than
enough all right so the first thing is
that if you go to this official Doc so
here first you have to create this
provider so again this provider is kind
of like whenever you'll create a context
and you'll wrap your application in your
context so that you'll be getting all
the uh Global state in your child
component so this is exactly similar uh
like
that all right so I think it's still
installing before that let's quickly
create all the components that we
need so we'll create a
folder now the first component we need
and that is a main
component uh we also need a chart
component then we also basically need
the view component where we'll be
showing all the expense and the income
so this will be our
view uh or let's give this one as a
expense view uh something like that
expense
view uh what else we need we also need a
overview
component or let's make this on
summary summary component and also you
need a add
transactions
component all right I think this is done
now let's go to our source and if you
see that we basically need to create our
base theme for our chakra UI so in the
theme what we need to do this will be
very very simple so we going to import
something
[Music]
from chrai react and this is called
extend theme now here we will be
basically creating so we do const theme
which will be this extend theme and here
I will be passing one that will be our
initial color
mode which will be
light and also you need to pass another
one which will be use system color mode
and this will be
true and at the end we'll do export
default
theme so this will basically create a
simple theme now to use as I already
told you we have to basically go to our
main index.js component I'll remove this
uh strict
mode here and then first I'm going to
import the provider and that is called
the chakra
provider and you have to wrap your app
inside of this and then here you have to
basically pass the theme which will be
our
theme that's it so this is the very
basic structure we need now because we
are having so many components and we
have to interact with so many different
components again for this project also
we are going to use a context for our
Global State Management if you want you
can also use Redux toolkit because we
also have done Redux toolkit in one of
the projects so you have some idea so
I'll create our index. jsx
and here first let me quickly create the
component so we do export
const as I already told you like uh
context is one of my favorite uh
features in react so I really really
like using
this and here we'll do export default
function Global so we'll do Global
state then I'm going to return this will
be Global context. provider and I'm
going to pass the children that's it now
let's save it now we'll go to index.js
again and again I'm going to WRA this
context so we can wrap it here only so
we'll do Global
State
sorry and then we'll just wrap it here
let's save this so this is fine now
let's go to our
app.js and we will be first creating all
the basic structure that we need and
after that we'll be start working on the
functionality and thank God in this
project will not be doing any kind of
API call anything this will be very
simple one so here I'm going to remove
all of these and I remove this one also
now because we are using chakra UI so
we'll try to use most of the components
uh inbu components from Chakra react
package only so the first uh we will
start with
container and inside this I'm going to
use a BG so here I'm use this color so
this thing I already have actually don't
think that I actually know all of this I
already have this one I already created
this project separately so I'm just
taking reference from there
only all right and then we are having
we'll give a Max
W so here we can basically pass
container dot
3XL then we'll take a height so height
is basically the minimum height which is
100 VH we'll take and we'll pass a
padding of zero all
right that's it now inside this we'll
take a
flex we'll make the height as full
and inside this we'll take a
box and here we are going to import the
main component so let's go here let's
quickly create something so do index.
jsx and here I'll be having export
default function
Main and let's return something for now
we return a de I'm going to remove this
one later and this is main so here I'm
going to import main component
and in this box we'll give a height of
full we'll give a flex
of five and we'll do a see I'm not uh
like explaining each and everything it
will definitely take a lot of time so
here I'll just divide this one with
20%
30%
20% uh I will do 50% % and we'll do 60%
if you over here also you'll get all
the uh properties basically so this is
the WID property and it is the
responsive value that you'll be able to
give for each and every resolution so
let's save it so now let's see what we
getting
here so you're getting main here this is
fine so now let's close everything else
and we'll go to our main component and
I'll create the structure here so I'll
remove this one let's import a
flex and here I'm going to give a text
align I'll give this one as
Center we'll do a flex Direction now
this is actually almost similar to tnd
SES
also we'll give a PR of five and we'll
do a PL of
five inside this we'll take another Flex
we'll do align
items uh we'll do this one as
Center we'll do justify
content uh we'll do space between and
we'll do Mt of
12 here we are going to import another
Inu component that is heading from
Chakra UI and here we'll pass simply
expense
tracker and here we'll do a color of
uh let's make this one uh
blue blue.
400 and we'll do display now again these
all are actually the responsive value
you have to go to the official Doc to
know about more so here we'll make this
one the first we'll do none then we'll
do
block then we'll do
block
block and we'll do block
so now let's format this let's save it
let's see what we getting now if you see
if I just
inspect let's go to very see for a small
device it's display none so if I go
to
here so you can see that we're getting
display none for this one display none
if I go for larger device it is uh the
display block so this is what we are
doing here for different different
resolution
all right now after this heading we'll
take another
Flex here we'll do uh align
items we'll do this one as
Center and here we're going to use a
button so for this one we'll do this one
as add new
transaction and here we'll need to pass
some of the properties so the first is
the BG so here also we do
blue uh let's make this one as
500 we'll do a color
of
black uh we'll do mL of
four uh what
else I think first let's see what is
happening here let's save
it okay you can see on H this is
changing but although this is looking
nice let's make this one uh we'll make
this one as
700 and we'll make this one as
white but if I keep this one white then
it will look odd actually we don't want
to add any hover property so let's make
this one as keep this one as all to Red
only let's
see no I think black was
good and we'll keep this on a little bit
yep yeah I think this is fine okay so we
having add new
transaction and then after this Flex
sorry here we are going to import our
overview component so here we'll do
overview and after this we'll take
another
flex and we'll be importing The View
component or expense view so let's first
create this overview component here so
we go to our overview where is that that
is our summary
so we'll do index.
jsx so we do export default function and
this will be our
summary and I'm going to return here
let's say H1 and this will be our
summary
component all right let's save it now
let's go to our expense
View and this will be our expense view
component so we will be basically using
this one for both expense and income but
we'll discuss that one later for now
this is
fine okay so now here we are going to
import the summary
component and inside this we'll be using
the expense view component two
times that's
it let's see what is happening okay so
here summary and then we are having
expense View
okay so now for this uh Flex we'll give
some style we make the wi as
full we'll do align items as Flex
start uh we'll do justify content as
space
evenly and we'll do a flex
Direction so for this one we'll make
this one as
column column
column for larger we'll do
row and
row okay so you can see that we'll be
having here and here and this is our
summary
component all right so now what we need
to do in the summary component in the
summary component we will be basically
having the balance and in the right side
we have to show the chart so let's let's
start working on that component
structure
first all right so let's create the uh
this component the summary component
structure first so we'll start with
first we'll import
box and here we'll give a padding of
six uh here we will give a border so
we'll do this on one PX
solid I'll also give border
color so we'll do this one as gray
100 we'll do overflow as
hidden we'll do border
radius as 10 and here we are going to
use a
background so we'll do background as
white all right now inside
this uh we'll also let's make the
display as
Flex
okay so now inside this we'll take a
flex and for this one we'll do width as
full we'll do justify content as
Center we'll do align items as
Center and here we'll do Flex
Direction and for this one we'll do a
base of column oh
sorry then for SM we'll do also
column for MD also we'll do column for
large and Xcel we'll do Row for large
we'll do row and for Excel also we'll do
row all right now inside this we'll take
another Flex
and here uh first we'll give some
properties we'll do Flex
one we'll do width as
full we'll do Flex direction as
column we'll do align items as
Center we'll do justify content as space
evenly we'll do margin sorry we'll do
margin left
of uh we'll do minus
20 and we'll do margin right of
two let me format this now inside this
we'll again import our heading
component and here we'll show the
balance so we'll show balance is let's
say
100 and here we'll give a size so we'll
do
MD uh we'll do margin bottom of four and
we'll do color as gray dot uh
600 let's save all of this let's see
what is happening so you can see that we
are getting balance
here all right so now after this uh what
we are going to do let's take another
Flex
here and here we are going to do justify
content as
space Lo space
evenly we'll do align
items as
Center we'll do BG of uh let's make gray
do
50 then we'll do width as for now let's
make this one as
full we'll do height
of 100
PX we'll do border as 1 PX
solid and we'll do border
color we'll make this one as gray do 100
awesome all right so now inside this uh
we'll take another
flex and here we are going to do Flex
direction as
column okay so now here we are going to
basically render our uh what is the
income and also what is the expense so
first we'll start with our income so for
this one we'll do heading and we will
basically render the income but for now
we'll some render some uh 100 static
value then we will take another
component which is
text and here this will be our total
income all right and here we're going to
use the color we'll do color as Gray
dot uh fire
600 and for this one also we'll do but
let's change this one we'll do
700 all right now next we'll copy the
same
thing and we'll paste it here the only
difference is this will be our
expense
okay so I think rest everything will be
same all right so now I think after
this okay after this we'll take another
box and here we are going to use a flex
of
one we'll do margin top of
10 we'll do
margin left of
minus 90
PX we'll do a margin right
of uh five
we'll do a width
of uh let's make this on 300 PX we'll do
height of also 300 PX we'll do display
as
Flex we'll do align items
Center and we'll do justify content also
center now inside this we want to
basically render our chart so we'll take
heading and we'll do this is our chart
later later we are going to change this
one okay so we having balance this is
our total income total expense and this
is our chart and this is our expense
view awesome so now uh what we can do we
can start working on our functionality
first and then so on click of this will
be opening a model and then whatever
data we'll be entering based on that you
have to render the chart this data also
will be dynamic and based on this here
also you have to render the data so
let's start working on this model first
all right everyone so let's start
working on this uh transaction form
component first so I'll create index.
jsx here so this will be export default
function this will be our sorry this
will be function this will be
transaction
form now definitely it will receive some
props but for now let's quickly create
the structure first so here uh this will
return model from Chakra UI and this
will take a e open prop so you can see
that this one but this one we're going
to uh fix it later here we'll take a
form and here we just uh import the
model
overlay all right now after this we'll
import
model
content and inside this we'll do model
header and this will be our add new
transaction something like
that all right now after this we'll
import model close
button and here this will be model body
see how easy it is to implement in this
uh chaki or Tailwind whatever you'll say
all the components are inbuilt same you
can do for material UI
also and here what you need to do
I will be importing form
control then we'll be having form level
and this will be our enter uh
description uh description yeah I think
that is
fine all right now after this we'll be
importing
input and here we will give a
placeholder so this will be enter
description we'll do enter
transaction uh
[Music]
transaction
description then uh what else we'll be
having a name so name we'll do
description we'll do type of text and
also you need the on change and the
value but for now this is fine so after
this form control we will take another
one so let me just copy this and we'll
paste it here and this will be enter
amount so this will be type will be
number name will give this one as
amount all right and this will be our
enter transaction
amount that's
it after this we need a radio
group all right and here we'll do a
margin top of
five inside this will be having
radio all
right this will be either it can be
expense or this can be income correct
let's do vice versa okay so income so
now here we have to give a name which
will be here
type and the same we have to give name
here also this will be type now this
will also take a colored
scheme so colored scheme will give this
one as
red and for this one we'll give color
scheme as or let's make the expenses red
and this one will do
blue all right and also to give the
value so for this one value will be
income and for this one value will be
expense
on change and everything we are going to
do later but for now this is
fine all right so now after model body
uh we'll import model
footer and here we'll take a two
button so one will be
cancel and then we'll take another
button and this will be
add all
right and I think this is fine uh let
let's give for this on a margin right of
four
okay and I think this is all the
structure we need now this transaction
form we have to import in our summary
component so here we are importing this
chart right so after this Flex we can
import the transaction form component
now here we have to pass some properties
so one will be a one close and then
second one will be is open or not so how
we are going to manage that so this one
we will be receive again from this uh
from the parent component so this will
be on close and is open now let's go to
our main and here chakra UI will give
you one hook that you can directly use
so this will be const is open comma on
open and then we are having on close and
this is is called use
disclosure all right so this value you
have to pass so now you can go to your
overview component or summary component
here we having ease open which will be
our ease open then we having on close
which will be our on
close all
right this is fine and now you can see
we are having this add new transaction
so on click of this button we have to
show the model so now we can simply take
on click and this will be on
open that's it so now let's go here and
then we are going to pass this on close
as this on close and E open will be e
open so these two again will receive in
this add transaction component so
receive on
close and is open so here you have to
pass e open as
is open then we having on close which
will be on close and then we having this
cancel button so here also you can give
on click this will be on
close let's save all of this let's see
what is happening here if I click here
awesome so you're getting here so this
is our income or expense you see cancel
if I click if I click here so this is
working
fine so now we will start working on the
functionality I think main structure is
completed but before that let's quickly
create the basic structure of this chart
uh this chart component that we'll be
creating now for this one I will not be
creating all the options from scratch I
already have some of the uh General
configuration I basically copied from
the official documentation and the same
I'm going to use although I'll explain
that what exactly we are doing there all
right everyone so let's start working on
the chart component so I'll create our
index. jsx here so this one will be very
very simple so we do export
default function transaction
chart
summary now obviously this will also
receive some data but for now we are
going to return and here what we'll do
we simply return uh sorry import chart
from react Apex charts and this will
return this chart component which will
take the options that we are going to
just now create it will also take the
series which is basically the data So
currently we are having this options you
can see that I already copied so now I
don't want to save this so we having
const options and then I'll just paste
it let me remove this so you can see
that we having level which is expense
and income and then we having two colors
let me just change this color to
Something Blue yeah I think this is fine
and then based on that we having some
properties which you'll be easily able
to understand the legend we don't want
to so data levels are for false then we
are having some options these are the
fields let me use the same field here
also that's it now here I'm going to use
the same options series because we are
having only two levels that means there
will be only two data one will be ex
expense and one will be income so let's
say I'm having expense of 100 and income
of 500 so this is our static data type
we have to give this will be a pie chart
width I'll give one
100% and height I'll give
100% now let's do one thing let's take
this
expense and the income from the parent
component so by default it will be let
say
100 and this is also will be 100 and
here I'm going to use this one as income
let's say and this will be my
expense all right I'll go to summary
component and here we are using this
chart component so we just inut this
transaction chart
summary and I'll just pass the expense
as let's say uh
100 and I'll pass income as also
1,000 now let's see what is happening if
I now save this awesome so now you can
see that we are getting the data here so
that means this is working fine now what
will happen whatever dynamically data we
want to pass that data we need to
basically
uh update here so you can see that
income is now 100 and expense is 1,000
why is that okay let me just
check okay I think we have done opposite
so to make this one as
income and this will be
expense also same we'll do opposite here
also and let me copy this
and we'll use the same
here okay income and then expenses
100 all right so now we'll go to our
context now it's time to implement the
functionality so now we need couple of
uh State basically in the context let me
close everything so the first one we
need and that is the form
values which is basically our form that
we are having here this form all right
so here we'll do const and this will be
your form data set form data this will
be use
state so use state of here we'll pass
the type as
expense and we'll do amount as zero and
we'll do description as empty
we also need the value and we'll do set
value which will be U state of expense
by
default all right so these two we need
also we need to track the expense value
total expense value and the total income
value so weing here total
expense set
total uh expense which will be used at
of zero and then we are having const
total
income set
total income which will be US state of
zero all right so this is we need and at
the end we have to track all the
transaction so we'll track all
transactions we'll do all
transactions and set all
transactions which will be used state of
Mt so many things we need so now this
all of these we have to pass in our
value so we start from form data set
form data total expense set total
expense total income set total income
value
set value all transactions and set all
transactions wow so many things so we
have passed all of this now first thing
we need to manage the form handling so
go to our add transaction here and then
we are going to import these things so
the first thing we need
const so we need the form values or the
form
data then we need the set form
data all right we also need the
value and we need the say
value and then I think for now this is
fine then we'll do use
context of global context all right so
now here let's create a method so we do
function handle form
change which will take the event and
here we'll simply do set form
data which will be our form data data
and then we'll do
event do
Target do value will be sorry not value
this will be
name and this will be equal to even.
Target
dot
value awesome so this is we need so now
we need to pass this one in this one so
this will be on
change so this will be handle form
change and so you can pass it
here that's
it all right now next we are having this
radio group so here we have to pass the
value so this value will be the value of
type of either it can be a expense or it
can be a uh income same we have to do on
change which will be set value all right
now here what we need to pass here we
need to pass the checked value correct
so checked value will be if the current
form data that we are having do type is
this is equal to equal to income so that
means this is now
checked or
else uh here we'll do this will be
expense let's save
this and I think this is fine so now
what we need to do we have to uh
basically submit this
so uh here we are already I think having
a form okay so we'll do on submit we'll
do handle
submit all right and here we'll do
button here we'll do button type
of uh
submit all
right and here we can do uh on click
we'll do on close for this one
also all right so now we have created a
method that will be on submit we have to
basically uh handle the current form
data so for this one what we can do we
can create another method here which
will do that so we do function handle
form
submit something like that and this
method will pass it
here then we are going to take it in our
context and we'll create
function uh this is handle
submit which will take the event so
first we'll do event dot prevent default
and then we'll call this handle form
submit and we'll pass the current form
data that we are having as simple as
that that's it so now let's see what is
happening in this context the method
that we have created so that means here
we'll be getting the uh form value or
basically the
current form data and let's log here
this form current form
data so go
here let's go to
console add something we'll do this on
the first 100 we'll do income click on
ADD so you're getting okay so we are
getting this one as type as expense okay
this is wrong so make this one as income
first okay so if I do here add something
give some value we'll do income add
income if I go here add something change
the value we do expense plad we are
getting still income so this part we
need to
check okay so I think I got the issue
the reason is because we haven't passed
any on change in this uh in this radio
so here also you need to pass on change
which will be our handle form change
same we need to pass it here also so now
I think this doesn't matter whether this
is expense or income let's see what is
happening now if I click here we add
something and let's make this on income
so we're getting income I'll add
something
again we'll do expense add here we
getting expense okay so now this is fine
so now what we need to do uh we have to
basically go to our context and here on
form submit we have to basically check
if the title and the sorry if the
description and and the amount is not
empty so you can basically check if the
current form data dot
description or if current form data do
amount empty then we are going to
Simply
return all right else we'll do set all
transaction which will basically get all
transaction the previous one and here
we'll basically pass the current form
data that we are having
and also you can pass a ID which will be
date do
now sorry date do
now okay now let's see what is happening
now find
now save it now let's log here all
transactions uh so let's add
first income we'll do income we'll do
1,000 we'll add here so you're getting
income 1,000 first income We'll add
we'll do
first expense we'll do 500 we'll do
expense add here reting two one is
income one is expense so this is working
fine so now what we can do basically we
can go to our main file and we have to
update these values dynamically so that
is this is now pretty simple so what we
can do we have to import import all of
this
now all right so now we'll go to our
main.js file and here we are going to
import the following things from our
context so we'll use
context of global
context so we need total expense to set
total expense total income and set total
income so we going to copy all of
this and then uh we will import it
here also we go back and then we are
going to import this all transactions
because this will consist of all the
data that we are having so now we'll
take this use effect sorry we'll take
use
effect and then we'll keep this all
transactions as a
dependency and we'll do let
income is Zer late expense is zero so
we'll do all transactions. for
each so this will be item so here we are
going to check if this item. type if
this is equal to equal to
income so in this case we will do income
sorry income will be equal to
income plus Loop Parts float
of item do income sorry item do amount
not income because we having amount or
else this will be expense so because
this is income so it will be income so
then we can copy
this and paste it here and this will be
expense equal to this will be expense
plus the amount and after this we're
going to do set total expense will be
expense and set total income will be
income that's it so now we will pass all
of these in our summary components we
pass total expense which will be total
expense we'll pass total income which
will be total
income all right so now let's go to our
summary
component so here we will receive this
total total expense and receive total
income all right now here we are having
this your
balance and here what we going do can
simply do something like that your total
income minus your total expense that is
your balance and then you're having this
total income so here we can render our
total income and here we can render our
total
expense let's save it let's let's see
what is happening okay so I'll just add
a new one and I'll do this one as let's
say
second amount 250 income I'll add here
so you can see this is getting changed
add here we'll do
expense again two we'll do 6 365 expense
add this is getting changed all right so
the same we have to update here
so now we can again go to our main.js
file and in this chart basically we have
to pass the data so I think in the uh in
the chart we are
passing sorry in the summary component
only we are having chart component where
is that where we are having chart
component okay transaction chart summary
I think that is the one so here we'll
pass the total expense and here we'll
pass the total income
okay now you can see that this is
getting changed awesome so now we just
have to render this view okay so now
let's start working on this list view
component so we go to this
view so here we will basically receive
some data but first let's
uh create the component structure first
so we'll do
box so here we'll do a flex of
one we'll do width we'll keep this on
full for
now we'll do background as
white uh we'll do a margin right of
four we'll do margin top of
10 we'll do a padding of
five we'll do PB of sorry we'll do a PB
of four
we'll do a border
of one PX
solid we'll do a border color of we'll
do gray do 100 and we'll do border
radius of
12 inside this we'll take a
flex uh we'll do align items and justify
content so we'll do justify content as
space between
and we'll do align items as
Center awesome now here I'm going to
render a heading
component and we'll basically get the
type here so we'll get the type so we'll
check if the type is equal to equal to
income so we'll render income or else
will render
expense and here Al Al uh use a size of
mid and we'll use a color of let's use
red.
700 all right now after this Flex we'll
be getting the data from the parent
components we'll receive the data here
so we'll do data do map this will be our
item and here we'll simply return a flex
all
right so the first thing is that we're
having a background color so background
color will check if the type that we are
receiving if this is equal to equal to
xense so we going to do red do 50 or
else we'll do blue
dot uh 50 all right we'll do a margin
top of
four we'll do justify content uh do
space
between do align items as
Center we'll do
border uh 1 PX
solid soorry we have to do inser
this again we'll do border
color so we'll copy this
and we'll make this one
100 that's it we'll do padding of
four and we'll do a border radius of
8 inside this we'll take another
flex and let's make the Align
items as Center and justify content as
Center and inside this we'll render a
text
component and we'll basically render the
item do
description all right and here we'll do
a margin left
of sorry here we'll do margin left of
three we will do a font weight of
bold and we'll do a color
of gray do
600 awesome now after this we will take
another text
component and we'll just render the item
do
amount that's it so now we'll go to our
overview
component sorry not overview we have to
go to the main.js component and here we
are having this expense View and here
you have to basically pass the data so
the first you to pass the data so data
will be all transactions that we are
having here do
filter then we'll do item and here we'll
pass item. type let's say we want to
pass if this is
expense I think data is not defined
we're having okay text is not defined
okay let me fix that and here we are
going to pass the type and for this one
type will be expense
let me copy
this and here we'll be making this one
as income and this one will be doing
income okay now we'll go to
our expense View and we are going to
import this text component from CH UI
let's save
this
awesome now we are getting all of this
so add a new one third
income of this
month 5,000 income add we're getting
here now let's add another one another
expense enter amount of let's say
652 expense add all three are getting
updated and the data is coming fine all
right so that's all for this particular
project now let's move on to the next
one next project will be a last project
of this particular video so we will be
basically implementing the uh Monte blog
application from scratch so let's start
working on that particular project all
right everyone so I think we are almost
at the end of this particular video so
this is the last project that we are
going to build and this will be a full
stack M blog app so the main idea behind
this project is that so that you will be
able to create a mon stack project from
scratch so we are going to use mongodb
and express for this one and for client
side react obviously so you can see that
we'll be having simply two pages one
will be home and add a new blog and this
data will be stored in a database now
the reason you may ask that why we are
creating a monack project now sometimes
you'll see there are some particular uh
companies like uh I'll not say the name
but obviously there are some companies
who will give you some Hands-On coding
so they will give you one uh simple
project to build and they they probably
will give you like two to 5 days of time
and in that time you have to basically
build that project and then you have to
give it to them so in that scenario
sometimes you might face that they will
give you to create a full stack M
application but it will be very simple
so let's see how this functionality will
work so here we'll be having add blog so
you can see that we are not using any
styling because throughout this uh
particular video we have used styling in
most of the places so let's say I want
to add a new blog so I'll add a new blog
added and so this will be new blog
description I'll add this one so now
this is updated if I now refresh this
obviously this will be updated if I go
here uh
another blog
added let's copy this add this one now
let's say I want to edit this one so
I'll go here and I'll do this is
edited so I'll edit so this is now
edited and if I not try to delete this
this is deleted if I refresh this
obviously you'll be getting the updated
data deleted and if I delete this one no
blogs are added so this will be a very
simple application and I'm pretty sure
that this project will also help you a
lot so let's start working on this
particular project all right everyone so
let's start uh working on our uh full
stack or basically mon stack blog
application so the first thing I want to
show that what I've done you can see
that I created a simple mongod project
and the same we are going to use and
also I created another folder and inside
this I have a client folder so inside
this client folder nothing but we are
having a simple will create react app
project so here now we will be basically
start with our implementing the server
or basically backend first so each and
everything we are going to do from
scratch so the first thing what we need
to do first we'll be creating a folder
and I'll give this one name as server so
this will be uh this will consist of all
the backends project that we will be
basically having
here all right next thing what we are
going to do now I'll just open this one
in
terminal and we will be doing first npm
in it so this will basically create the
package dojon that we need so I'll give
any name for now this is fine later
we'll change this
one we'll do yes so now this will in
create a package.json now what are the
packages that we need now we are we will
be using mongod we need mongus we also
needs nodon to run the server uh like
concurrently and also we need uh Express
and also you need course so mainly these
four will be more than enough so we
going to use npm install this will be
course we need Express we also need
mongus and also we need node one to run
our
server now let's install all of this now
after this what we need to do we will be
changing some of the things here and
then we'll be first creating our main
index.js from where we will be serving
our main uh index file or basically the
root file
so here uh what we are going to do so
you can see that we are having this main
which is index.js so we don't have any
index.js for now so let's create one so
we'll do
index.js all right now inside this
package. jsn we'll create a script which
will be start script and because we
already install node one and here you
need to basically give the file name so
we'll be doing
index.js because that is the file name
so now this is done now next thing what
we need to do first we will be basically
Crea creting the very basic server setup
so here let me close this one so first
we will need Express so we'll do
require and we need
Express next uh we also need the DB
connection but we haven't done this one
so later we will be adding those we also
need cords so we'll do require this will
be
cords all
right now what we going to do create our
app so we are going to just invoke this
Express and then this app will use this
course all right and also we going to do
app.use which will be
express.
Json that's it now here uh we'll do our
main app.use main API route which will
be/ API this will give you a call back
which will give you request
response and now here we'll just do
race. send and we'll just do your hello
or I'll do hello world something like
that and after that we need to do app.
listen now here you can basically
mention a port name but for now I'll
just pass this one as 5,000 this will
also give you a call
back and here I just going to log
console.log and we'll do app is running
at
5,000 and I think that is all the very
basic structure that we need now to run
this one what we can do we can simply do
npm start now let's see what is
happening so you can see that it is okay
so there are some error you're getting
that some module is not found so this
one we need to check so it's not getting
the module CS okay let me just create
open a new one or let me just check
whether we have installed CS or not
sorry see we we haven't installed CS
that is the
reason let me just uh create open
another one so here we'll install npm
install
CS all right now let me I'll remove this
one later this is not record so we
installed now CS now let's go here so
now let's see if we run this one what is
happening so we do npm
start all right so app is running at
5,000 so this is working fine so now we
are going to uh do the DB connection so
inside This Server I'll create another
folder and I'll give this one M as DV
and inside this I'll create
index.js so for this one I think we have
already uh created our mongodb project
and the same we are going to use so
you'll go here and the first thing is
that if you you can see that here you'll
get this connect and then you'll be
getting this connect mongod for vs code
sorry and here you have to basically
you'll get this connection URL that you
need to copy and then here the first
thing is that we need
mongus so we'll do
require
mongus now here we'll set mongus do set
and here we'll set uh strict query as
false
and then we'll do mongus do connect and
you have to basically pass this URL I
just copied and then I have to you have
to basically give the password here so
I'll just give my password you can
create your own and then you can use the
same now this will give you a promise so
we'll do dot then and here what we can
do we can simply log
console. log and we'll do connected
mongodb
all right if there are any error sorry
if there are any error so we'll just log
this error so let's save
it all right so now what we can do we
can go to our main
index.js and here we'll simply do
require and we need to basically go to/
DB and it will automatically take from
the uh that connection so it will
automatically take this DV connection
that we have done here all right I think
that's it so now if you go here you can
see app is running at 5,000 and we
getting connected mongodb so which is
basically coming coming from here all
right now let's see how we are going to
approach this one so mainly we will be
having three things one will be a model
so model is basically where you will be
defining your model then you'll be
having a route route all the routes will
be defined and those routes you are
going to use in your index.js and for
each and every route let's say we you
will be adding a blog or we'll be
fetching list of blogs or we'll be
deleting a blog or updating for each and
every blog we'll be having a controller
so that means we are having the
following folders so we'll be having a
controller uh we will be having
model and also we'll be having
route all right now the first thing is
that we'll start with this model so
inside this model I'll create a folder
and let's give this one name as
blog
.js all right so now the first thing is
that what we need we need mongus so
we'll do mongus which will be
require
mongus and now here we'll Define our
schema sorry this will be const schema
which will be mongus do
schema here we'll create our blog
schema so this will be new
schema and here you have to basically
pass all the properties that you want to
use so let's we'll be having a
title so here we'll be having a type of
we can directly pass or let's do like
this only so we do type of
string and I think that is fine next
what we will be having we'll be having a
description which will also will be a
type of
string and then we'll be having a
date so date will be type of
date and here we'll pass a default
property so default will be our date do
now all right so this now if you want
you can also add some more properties
Also let's say you'll be having a image
so you can also add a image property uh
for example let's say you want to face
the image from some database and then
you want to sorry some let's say you
want to store some in storage the image
for example fireb or some a WS cloud and
then you want to face the URL and that
URL you want to store here so that also
you can do now what we can do we can
simply do module. exports and here I'll
do mongus sorry this will be
mongus what you doing mongus do model
and here basically you to give the name
so I'll give this one name as blog and
then you to pass the blog schema just
now we have created this one as simple
as that so this will create this will
basically create your
model all right now next thing what we
need we basically need this controller
and in this controller we will be having
all the things that we will be basically
doing so let's say inside this I'll
create our uh we'll do blog
controller.js all right so let me just
close everything now so the first thing
is that we need our
mongus which will be
require Mong
goes and also we need the blog schema so
we'll do
blog we'll do
require and we'll go to our model SL
blog all right now what are the things
we need we need basically these many
controllers first we need fet list of
blogs then we need add a new
blog we also need delete a Blog
and also we need update a
Blog so basically these all the
controllers that we
need so first uh let's start with
this uh this F list of blogs so we do
const Lage list of blogs this will be a
sync method definitely and here you will
be basically getting our request and
response now inside this what we are
going to do first we'll take a variable
and we'll do blog uh we do blog list
something like that now we'll be having
a tri block and a cat block so in the
cat block we'll simply log the
error and in the tri block what we are
going to do we'll do blog list is equal
to AIT now you can see that this is the
schema that sorry this is the model so
we do just blog. find so this find is a
method so this will basically give you
all the all the documents that you are
having so you can see that it will list
all the documents that match the this
particular
filter that's
it now after this here we can basically
do something like this if there are not
blog list so that means no blog is
present so we'll simply do a
return and we'll do race
dot
status and here we'll do
404 and we'll do do Json and we'll pass
a message something like no
blogs found all right and at the end we
are going to return sorry we going to
return so we'll do race do status of 200
do Json and here we are going to
basically pass this log
list that's
it so now this all about will give you
all the list of blogs that you are
having so first what we have done we are
finding all the blogs then we checking
if there are no blogs that means there
is no blog is currently present or else
we'll return all the blog list whatever
we are
having all right so next method we are
going to create and that will be to add
a new block
so let's create another one and this
will be add new blog this is also will
be a sync method here we'll get request
and
response all right so the first thing is
that we will be basically receiving our
uh title and the description and that
will be from this so this you can see
that we are having title and description
in the model that means whenever we'll
be typing something in our front end we
need to basically extract those inputs
whatever user is typing how we are going
to do that so we'll simply do title and
description and this we are going to
basically take it from request.
body all
right next we'll create our date so this
will be our current
date and here I'll simply do new
date now let's create our blog so this
is our new newly created blog this will
be new and you can see that we are
having this blog which is our model so
this is the model that we are
having so here uh what we are going to
do we will be
basically just saving this one so we'll
pass this
title we'll pass
description and also we pass let me just
check so we having this date so you're
having this date so date will be this
current date that we are having here I
hope you're getting so now we'll do a
try block and we'll do a it and we'll do
uh so we are having this newly created
blog dot save so save is a method that
you can use if there are any error so
we'll just catch this
error all right and then after this
we'll take another pry
catch here I'm going to return if there
are any kind of Errors we'll do race.
send it will be a 500 and we'll just
render Json and we'll pass a message
which will be this error and in this Tri
block what we going to do create our
session so this will be our a
Mongols do start
session
and then we'll do session do start
transaction and we'll do
AIT we having
blog. save sorry we are having newly uh
sorry newly created
blog dot
save and here I'm going to pass this
session and then we'll do session do
commit transaction
now at the end if everything goes
correct so we are going to return we
return race.
status of
200.
Json and we'll basically pass here this
newly created blog that we just
created awesome so this is all about our
add a new blog that we need next we are
having delete a Blog all right so let's
create another method so this will be
delete a Blog and this will be async
request
response and here we'll do const ID now
the reason we need ID because we will be
always uh deleting a particular blog
correct so for that one we need that ID
of that particular blog and that we will
be receiving from the params so I will
uh discuss that part later but for now
let's create so we'll get it from
request. params
doid and then we'll do try and we'll do
basically const find current blog and
this will be
a we are having
blog dot find by ID and delete and here
basically what you need to do to pass
the ID that you want to delete that's it
now here after this if there is this
blog is not found actually so we
basically need to send some message like
we'll do return race.
status we'll pass a 404 and we'll do a
Json off we'll pass a message of blog
not
found all
right and here also you'll do a
catch sorry we'll do a error so we are
going to log this error not sure why
this autocomplete is very slow in The
View code I'm not sure need to check uh
so we'll do a status of
500 do Json and we'll pass your
message
unable to
delete
please uh try again something like that
and here if we are not getting so means
we are returning this one this is fine
but if we are deleting that means that
is successful so we going to return
raise do
status of 200.
Json and we'll pass a message and that
will be something like
successfully
deleted and I think that's it so this is
what exactly you need to delete a
particular blog we are first getting the
ID that you want to
delete and then we are deleting this by
this method we have to pass that
particular ID this is very very
important and if uh we are not getting
the blog so we return that blog not
found if it is successful we will return
successfully deleted and if there are
any errors we return the unable to
delete now at the end we need another
one and that will be to update a Blog so
Lon update a Blog this also will be a
sync method here we'll get request
response now there is a third parameter
also you can pass here that is next but
for now this is fine this is more than
enough now here also you need the that
you want to update so here also you get
ID which will be request. params do
ID so here we'll get our title comma
description and here you will be
receiving from our
request.
body now after
this uh what we can do uh we can
basically take like current blog to
update something like that then we'll
take a tri block and here we'll do
current blog to update and this will be
AIT now we have to take blog and here
again you have to do find by ID and
update and here what you need to pass
you to pass this ID that which blog you
want to update and you have to pass the
content so here I'm going to pass this
title and the description that I'm
having
here that's it all right if there are
any error so we log this
error and then we are going to return
race. send
500. Json
something something went wrong while
updating
please please try
again sorry you to give this oh oh sorry
sorry we have to give this one in
message okay what is happening here I
think we haven't given this one
see that's
it all right now here after this if it
is successful so so here it is fine so
here simply you can Che if this not
equal to current blog to update if we
are not getting means this is not
present we'll simply return race.
status uh we'll do 500 again and we'll
do a Json and do message and we'll do
unable to update awesome and at the end
we are going to
return race. send of 200. Jason and
we'll pass this current blog to
update that's it
so now we have created all the method
that we need so now we need to basically
export all of these so you can simply do
here module sorry we'll do here module.
exports and here you can simply pass
this uh fet list of blogs delete a Blog
update a Blog and add new blog so now
see the process is so we have created
the model we have created all the
controllers now we have to create the
route so whenever we will basically
calling these routes from our front end
so you have to basically need those
routes and there you have to basically
pass all the information that you need
so here I'll create we'll do something
like blog route. jsx sorry
JS and here you need the express now so
we do Express and this will be
require
Express and I'm going to create our blog
router
which will be
Express so this will give you this
router you can see and here now I'm
going to extract all of these from so we
do
require and I'll go to controller SL
blog controller so what are the things
we are having we are having G uh sorry
we are having fet list of blogs add a
new blog update a Blog and then delete a
Blog
awesome now at the end what we going to
do is simply call this blog router and
this will be dog and here you to
basically give that which path so you
can see that the path you want to call
so I want to call this on slash and this
will be our fet list of
blogs then we'll do blog router
doget and this will be SL add and here I
need to do add a new
Blog then I'll do blog router
dog here I'll do slash now here is the
catch so whenever we'll do update and
delete we basically need the current ID
so we'll pass a dynamic value because
this value will be dynamic and here I'll
pass a update a Blog something like that
and to make this a little bit unique we
can do something like update and then
here we'll do blog
router dot get sorry I'm doing too much
mistake for adding this one this will be
a post for this one this will be a put
and this will be a
delete so here we can do something like
delete SL again we have to pass the ID
and here we'll do uh delete a
block and that's
it this is done now at the end again you
have to do module. exports and you to
export this blog
router so we created the routes we we
have created the controller so now we
need to basically go to our index.js
here and you have to import this blog
router just now we have created so here
I'll do const blog
router and this will be
reord so here we'll go to our
router route blog route all right and
now what you can do simp
after this we'll do app.
use and here we'll call SL API SL
blogs and here I'm going to pass this
blog
router that's
it all right so this is our basically
our uh path in which we will be
accessing this blog router which will
consist of all of these routes and these
all of these route are basically the
controller is basically maintained by
this controller file so I think that's
all the back end we need and this is a
very simple project I already told you
now we will be start working on the
front end part but before that let's
quickly install the packages that we
need and another thing I want to mention
that is for this particular project also
we will be not doing any CSS because
again the prime objective of this
project is that if even if you get any
kind of like monst related project in
interview so you also Aid that whenever
you interview you get a limited amount
of time and they will not tell you to
create a full stack Twitter clone or
YouTube clone or insta Facebook or
something like that like let's food
delivery app they'll give you a very
simple problem and they will judge you
that whether you'll know the basics or
not so something very very I'm pretty
much sure that they will give you
something related to any to-do app any
blog list something like that F list of
data Crow application crude application
you can say sorry so where you'll be
able to create update delete and add any
new thing so the main objective is that
the thing we are doing here to give you
the basic understand understanding that
how you will be able to achieve that so
that is the reason we'll not use M CSS
so here the packages we need we'll need
uh react
icons and also you need react router Dom
and I think this will be more than
enough so now this packages we need now
we will be start working on the uh
client side now how we are going to do
that so we will be maintaining all of
the state using our uh context all right
so the first thing let's quickly create
our context so we go to our source and
inside this first I'm going to create
our context and inside this I'll create
index.
jsx all right so now let's create our
context so this will be export const
Global context and this will be create
context of null
now I'm going to do export default
function this will be our Global
State and here I'll be receiving the
children and I'm going to return Global
context. provider and I'm going to pass
the children here that's it so this is
the first step now I'll go to our
index.js I'll remove this strict
mode and I'm going to import Global
State and I'm going to W this app do app
component inside of
this all right now how we are going to
do that so first let's implement the
routing
functionality so we need two pages so
first I'll create Pages folder and
inside this we'll be having our
home and then will'll be our add
blog all
right so inside this we'll create our
index x.
jsx so let's quickly create so this will
be export default function and this will
be our
home and I'm going to return here
div and let's return H1 and this will be
our list of blog uh blogs blog lists
blog
list all right next we are having this
add blog so here I'll create index. jsx
and again I'll create this component so
this will export default function
add new
blog and I'm going to return again a div
and inside this I'll again take a H1 and
I'll do
add uh add a
Blog awesome now let's create another
folder inside of this and I'll give this
one name as components and I'll create
another one and that will be our header
and let's create our index.
GSX so this will be export default
function and this will be our
header all right and I'm going to return
here a
div so here we'll keep this one very
very simple I'm again explaining these
things uh I'll just simply keep one A3
and this will be our
blog uh we'll
do M blog
log
app and on the right side I'll take a
e and here I'll take two AI so one will
be our home and one will be our add a
new
one that's
it now let's do one thing let's create
our
style so let's create now this time
module CSS so we are going to use mod
CSS modules so this is also will give
you some idea
so I'll take this one as a
header and I'll do a display of
flex then we'll take header of A3 and
we'll do Flex of
one then we'll take
header of e I'll do display as Flex We
Do least style as none and we'll do gap
of
20px then we'll do do header. e.li we'll
do font size as 20 BX font weight as
bold and we'll do cursor as
pointer now let's go here now how we are
going to use this to use this we have to
import classes
from style. module. CSS and here I'll
give a class name now this will be
classes dot
rapper so this is the class name that
that we are having here sorry header not
rapper that's it now let's save it now
I'll go to app.js now we have to
basically implement the
routing so the first thing let me just
remove all of
this and here I'm going to import the
header component first and let's see
what we getting I think we are already
running this
application okay this is fine let give
uh give some uh what we can do we go
here and let's give
a padding
of uh
30px okay awesome and here I'll give a
font size of 40
PX and we'll do margin of
zero okay now on click of this you have
to change the pages but before that
let's implement the routing first so to
implement the routing again we have to
go to our
index.js and here I'm going to import
browser router I think let me just UT it
directly
from react router Dom and we'll do
browser
router awesome now I'll just cut it and
paste it
inside now let's go to our app.js and
here we are going to import routes from
react autodom I think I'm not explaining
because this also I've have done in the
previous project also now we need two
route and here I'll do a exact I'll give
a path of Slash and I'll give a element
for this one I'm going to use the
home then I'm going to copy this paste
it here this will be add
blog and and
here uh what we'll do we'll do add new
blog that's it so now let's save
this we'll go to our header and now here
I'm going to import
link we'll paste it two
times we'll cut it here one and here one
and here we'll give the two as slash and
for this one we'll give a two AS Slash
add
blog let's save this so now if I click
here this is changing and this is fine
so now let's quickly create this form
first because first we have to save the
data in our uh
database and then we'll be fetching the
list of data so we'll go to our add blog
component component I'll close
everything else the first thing is that
uh we'll do a class name here so first
let me just create our
styles. module.
CSS so we'll do a
wrapper and here also we'll do a padding
of I think how much we have done padding
here 30px so we do
30px and we'll import this on
here
and here I'll do a class
name which will be classes do
wrapper all
right now here I'll take a
div and inside this div I'll have a
input so let's give a name
of title
we'll give a placeholder of enter blog
title we also have to give the value uh
but for now this is fine ID will give a
title we'll give a type of
text after this we'll take a texture
here here also give a name of
description we'll give a placeholder of
enter
blog dis
description and what else we'll also
give ID of
description and we'll give a type
of yeah I think that is
fine now for this one we'll give a class
name we'll do this one as classes do
form
rapper so copy this we go here and we'll
do do this on display as Flex Flex
Direction column and gap of 15
PX okay for this one I'll also give a
width of 400
PX okay this is fine now what we can
do we can also take a button and this
will be add new
blog something like that let's
see so first let's quickly complete the
functionality and after that we'll be
doing little bit of styling here all
right all right so now let's go to our
context and then we'll create our state
so first will be our form data set form
data which will be equal to use state so
here we'll be having title which will be
empty and then we'll be having
description which will be
empty now let's copy
this and we'll go here we'll do value
and we'll pass this one so this is the
advantage of using Contex will be easily
able to manage straight
globally also context is like one of my
really favorite features of react so
here now what we need to do we'll just
um extract this from use context
of global context so now what we can do
we can simply take the value here which
will be form data do name sorry this
will form data. title and here value
will be form data do
description here we'll take a on change
which will be event so we do set form
data which will be our form
data and then here we'll do title which
will be even do target.
value that's it now same here we'll be
do on change we'll get the
event and here we'll do set form
data I think this is not required set
form data will be our form data and then
we'll do
description which will be event.
target.
value that's it
so now let's see what we are getting in
this form data so log this form
data let's go to console type something
here we're getting title and this is our
description
awesome all right so now what we need to
do on click of this button we'll call
the API and we have to save the data in
our database so we create a method this
will be our on click and this will be
handle save
blog to database I'm giving the name
like this so that it is easy to
understand all right everyone so now
let's uh start working on this method so
this will be obviously as sync method so
we do as sync
function and here let's do one thing uh
let me just open this on another
terminal and let's
install uh
AOS
so I think I think it will be done let
me just
check okay so now we'll
import Aus from
Aus and here we can simply do const
response this will be
AIT axos dopost and here now what we
need to do we have to basically call the
URL now here we'll be calling HTTP SL
Local Host now if we go to this
index.js here you can see that we are
having this/ API blocks so this is our
base URL and then here you have to
basically go to/ add because we'll be
adding so here we'll do uh Local Host
5,000 SL API SL blogs SL add and here we
need to pass the uh title which will be
our form data uh do title and then you
have to also pass the description which
will be form
data do description all right now here
this will basically will give me our
result which will be
AIT
response do data that's it now let's log
this result and let's see what we
getting
okay now let refresh this do
inspect we'll do
first
blog
added let's add this one so you're
getting newly created blog if I go to
network this is
successful and now we'll go here we'll
do browse
collection so getting blogs and and here
we are getting only one block so this is
working fine so now what we can do
simply we can check first let me import
one thing and that is called
navigation from
use I think uh that is called use
navigate so let me just import
it so import something
from react router Dom and this is called
use
navigate
all right so here we'll simply do if
result is true so first we'll make this
set form data as empty so title empty
and description as
empty and we'll do navigate to
homepage let's save it now let's see
what is happening so go here now let me
just refresh this
again so we'll do second
blog second
blog bad it's going to blog list page if
I refresh this it should have two data
now so you're getting two data and this
is working fine if I go to add blog and
you can see that the form is now
reseted so that is all about the add a
new blog functionality now let me just
go to the
homepage and here we will be basically
now fetching the list of blogs so for
this one I'll just close everything else
we go to
context and here I'll be taking another
one and this will be our blogs blog list
set blog list which will be used state
of array also we take a pending State
set pending which will be US state of
false so we are going to pass these
values so we pass blog list set blog
list pending and set
pending now we'll copy
this so we go to home first we'll
destructure all of
this from use context of global context
next so what we are going to do
basically will be simply fetching the
list of products sorry list of blogs so
here we need to take a use
effect which we will be calling on page
load and this will be Fage list of
blocks so again this will be aing method
so this will be function
Fage list of
blogs so this will be const response
and this will be
AIT axio let me import
it from
axio so here this will be
axio
dog so here again we'll do
HTTP Local
Host 5,000 SL API SL blogs so this is
the URL that we
need and and here we'll do const result
equal to AIT response. data now let's
see we log this result
here let's save it now let's go
here do console let's go to our homepage
we are getting two data and this is our
blog list so you can simply check
if
result
and and result. bloglist and then
result. blog list. length this is true
so we'll do set blog list is result do
blog
list and before calling the will do set
pending as
true and here we do set pending as
false all right now here we'll do simply
if loading sorry if the pending is true
so render H1 and we'll do
loading
blogs
please
wait or else we simply take a div
here and inside of this we're going to
render this blogs list do map this is
blog
item here we'll take a d
so the key will be the blog item.
ID and here we'll take a p and we'll
render blog item.
title and we'll take a p another one and
this will be blog item.
description let's save it and now let's
see what is happening so you're getting
two blogs correct let's go to our add
blog and another one third
blog third
blog add we are getting third blog if I
now refresh this we're getting all the
data here so this is all about the
fetching list of blocks now let's give
some little bit of styling and then
we'll be start working on the delete and
the update all right so now let's create
our style file here so this will be
styles. module.
CSS uh so here we'll give a class name
and this will be
classes do blog
list and we're going to
import classes
from style. module. CSS and here we'll
copy this and first thing we'll do this
one as display
as uh
grid do grid template columns
repeat uh 41
F and we'll do gap of 10
PX uh inside this we'll do dot blog list
of
div uh here we'll give a padding of 10
PX we give a border of one uh 1 PX solid
red let's see how this is looking okay
and also here we'll give a class name of
classes do uh
rapper so we copy
this so we'll do wrapper and we'll do
padding of
30px awesome so now if I go here come
back we are getting the data so now we
will give some uh button here one will
be delete and edit so let me just
quickly import it so we import some
something
from react icon slfa and I think it is
fa a
trash and then we having fa
edit and here we'll take a we'll just
render this fa edit and then fa tress
we'll give a size of
30 also here also give a size of
awesome so now uh first we'll start
working on this uh Delete functionality
so here we'll give on click and this
will be handle delete
blog so now we'll create create this
method so this will be as sync function
handle delete blog now this will
basically get current ID
definitely so here to get current ID
what you need to do you have to pass
this current ID which is this blog item.
ID so blog item.
ID so if I now log
this get current ID and let's see what
is
happening so if I click here we're
getting the ID and you can see
that awesome so now we just have to
Simply call the API so we do const
response this is AIT Aus do delete so
here we'll call the API now here what
catch is that so we'll do Local Host
5,000 SL API SL blogs now if I go
here so we are having delete and then
you have to pass the ID so you slash
delete slash and here you have to pass
this get current
ID all
right
and here we'll do const result which
will be equal to
AIT
response dot
data all right now one very important
Point whenever we will be deleting
something we have to refresh the page to
get the list of uh blogs again what we
can do we can simply call this API again
or else we can refresh the page I'll
show you both the both the things so
simply you can check here if this result
so uh let me check what we are passing
in the controller so if I delete
something we passing this message so
we'll check if this result. message is
true so we'll do F list of
blogs all right now let's save
it now let's see what is happening
refresh
this so we'll click this one awesome if
I click here deleted if I click here we
are getting loading please wait now this
is also we need to check this is the
reason so here we'll do else set pending
as
false so if I now refresh this okay we
are not getting any data but that is
fine uh we will do one
thing uh we'll check here if this blog
list
and and blog list. length is true or
else will render
A3 so no
blogs
added okay and I'll go to add
blog new one added so this new one
added add this one we are getting
delete okay here we need to check what
what is happening so go here we need to
check I'll just add random add new one
but
here if I
delete we are getting empty
but if I go here let me refresh this we
are not having any data but some of this
data is showing here okay so what we can
do let's do something like this so we do
const navigate and this will be
use
navigate okay let me import it so we do
import
from react router
Dom and this will be use
navigate okay oh I got it what is the
reason if the result is not true we have
to make this set blog list as empty see
this is the re but I'll show you the
second way also now it will work for
sure let's go here let's try to add add
another one let's add here now let's
delete see now we getting but I'll show
you another one how we are able to do
that so let's I'll add some
random
add add and I'll add another
one okay now you'll see so either you
can call this method again or else you
can also do this navigate so navigate or
of zero what this will do this will
basically call the same uh page or
refresh the same page again let's see
what is happening so I'll just refresh
this I'll see if I just delete this one
see it is refreshing this page again I
hope you're getting right so if I again
click this one so it is refreshing and
if I click again it is refreshing but I
think it will be better if you call this
sem instead of refreshing the page again
and again so I think this is the best
approach all right so this is all about
the delete functionality that we are
having now let's start working on this
edit one now for edit what we'll be
doing so let's say I'll add a new one
add add something now whenever I'll
click it will go to the ad page so it
will go to this page and it will
automatically fill this one and this add
will be getting changed and this will be
getting changed to edit all right so
let's see how we are going to basically
do that all right so we'll go to First
our context
and here I'll add another state and this
will be
current edited
data Set current edited
data and this will be equal to use state
or let's do one thing we'll do EAS
edit and we'll do set e edit and this
will be equal to
false now I'll copy this
and I'll pass it
here awesome so now we'll go to our home
and here we are having this
edit icon so we'll do on click and we'll
do handle edit now this will also get
the current blog
item all right so
here we create this method so this will
be
function handle edit so this will be get
current blog
item and let's see what we
getting okay so now we'll go to our home
let's add this one so you're getting the
data so now we have to navigate to the
add page and then we also have to pass
the data in our state so how you will be
basically doing that to do that what you
need to do we can simply call this
navigate method that we are having so we
having
navigate so navigate will here you have
to pass the two so it will go to the uh
so let's say we are going to this add
blog so it will go to this page
correct and then here what you have to
pass you have to pass the state so we do
state state here I'm going to pass the
uh title or let's do one thing let's
pass this gate current blog item
full let's save it so now if I go to
this add blog page I have to get the uh
I have to extract the state how we are
going to do that so for this one we are
having another uh hook and that is
called use
location so we do location will be use
location and now here let's take a use
effect
and we'll take this location and we'll
log this location
here save it now let's see what is
happening okay currently we can see that
we are not getting anything but if I now
go to home and click here and I'll see
if I expand this we are getting a state
and here we getting gate current blog
item and inside this we're getting all
the data so we can now simply check if
this location state. gate current blog
item so here we'll check if location.
state if this is true so this gate
current blog item we will be able to
take location. state from location.
State and now what we can do we can
simply make this set form data will be
title which will be get current blog
item do title and description will be
get current blog item do
description see if I now save this see
now you're getting this two data
automatically filled up here correct so
now what we can do simply we can go to
our context and here we are having this
set is
edit so this one we will be able to
extract from here and we'll do e
edit and here we'll
do set is edit will be
true and here we'll
do if is edit is true we we'll do
edit a
blog or or else we do add a
Blog save
this and same we can do it here
also so we'll do e edit do edit blog or
else we'll do to add
blog let's save it now here you are
getting edit blog edit a Blog now on
submit here we are saving so here
basically we need to basically check if
it is EAS edit so we have to call a
different endpoint if it is a only add
so we have to call this endpoint so we
can simply check if this Eed it is true
so we'll do AIT AOS do
putut so we'll do this on access do
putut and here you have to pass the URL
and then here you'll be passing the
title which will be again your form
data. title and description will be your
form data do
description now here what you have to
pass so let me just do one
thing so we'll go here
all right so you can see that we having
SL update SL ID of ID so you have to
pass it here and let me just copy from
here only no need to write
again okay so going to 5,000 SL API blog
SL update and now ID will be what will
be the id id will be this gate current
blog item. ID so from here you'll be
able to get it I hope you're getting so
here you can simply do
this
location dot
state do get current blog item do
ID all right so now let's see what is
happening and if the result is true what
we need to do we'll again make this set
is edit as
false all right now let's save it now
let's see what is
happening now I'll go to home first
I'll click on edit and I'll do add
edited
edit okay so you're getting some
error Let me refresh this
again all right so we are getting some
error and that is cannot set headers
after they send to client res status
send St instead of
3314 okay sry we have to do status here
and same we can do
here okay now let's see so let me just
refresh this
first okay now this is edited although
but let me just edit it again so edited
again and this is also
edited now click on edit so edited again
if I go to add we are getting add if I
go here it's edited let's add another
one
here so now I'll click on edit so now
this one this one is
edited edit so edited delete this is
deleted and if I delete this one no
blocks are added all right so now I
think we have almost completed all the
functionality I hope that this will
definitely give you some idea how you
can create a full stack mod project from
scratch and also with this project we
have have completed all the projects in
this particular video and this video
will definitely going to help you if
you're completing these projects
whatever we have done in this particular
video all right so all the best and I'll
see you in my next video till then good
luck and
peace